if you have a democratic style of
governance you are interesting people
with one of the most awesome and radical
of responsibilities and that's saying
that you're going to pick the people
that are going to make some of the
hardest decisions in all of human
history if you're going to trust people
to vote correctly you have to be able to
trust them to have open and honest
dialogue with each other whether that's
Nazis or KKK people or whoever talking
you have to believe that your people are
going to be able to rise above and make
the correct determinations when they
hear these types of speeches and if
you're so worried that somebody's going
to hear a certain political figure and
they're going to be completely
radicalized instantly then what that
tells me is that you don't have enough
faith in humans for democracy to be a
viable institution which is fine you can
be anti-democratic but you I don't think
you can be pro-democracy and anti-free
speech
the following is a conversation with
Stephen Bonnell also known online as
Destiny he's a video game streamer and
political commentator one of the early
pioneers of both live streaming in
general and live streamed political
debate and discourse politically he is a
progressive identifying is either left
or far left depending on your
perspective
there are many reasons I wanted to talk
to Stephen first I just talked to Ben
Shapiro and many people have told me
that Stephen is the Ben Shapiro of the
left in terms of political perspective
and exceptional debate skills second
reason is he skillfully defends some
nuanced non-standard views
at the same time being pro-establishment
pro institutions and pro-biden while
also being pro-capitalism and pro-free
speech
third reason is he has been there at the
beginning and throughout the meteoric
rise of the video game live streaming
community in some mainstream circles
this community is not taken seriously
perhaps because of its demographic
distribution skewing young or perhaps
because of the sometimes hard style of
communication
but I think this community should be
taken seriously and shown respect
millions of young minds tune into live
streams like Destinies to question and
to try to understand what is going on
with the world often exploring
challenging even controversial ideas
the language is sometimes harsher and
the humor sometimes meaner than I would
prefer but I Grandpa Lex put on my rain
boots and went into the beautiful
chaotic muck of online discourse and
have so far survived to tell the tale
with a smile and even more love in my
heart than before
on top of all this we were lucky to have
Molina Goranson a popular streamer and
World traveler join us at the end of the
conversation you can check out her
channel on twitch.tv Molina and you can
check out Steven's channel on
youtube.com destiny
this is the Lex Freedom podcast to
support it please check out our sponsors
in the description and now dear friends
here's destiny
I don't know if you watched me watching
your yay interview yeah thank you so
much I'm so curious when you're
navigating a conversation like that
are you how intentional is the thought
process between like building Rapport
and pushing and and giving a little like
zero zero attention I was watching and
thank you so much I was very kind for
you to review that conversation it meant
a lot that you were complimenting Parts
on the technical aspects of the
conversation but no zero and I'm
actually deliberately
uh trying to avoid I think you've called
it debate brain uh which is just another
flavor of thinking about
like The Meta conversation trying to
optimize how should this conversation go
because I feel like the more you do that
the better you get at that
the less human connection you have like
the less genuinely you're actually
sitting there in the moment and
listening to the person you're more like
calculating what's the right thing to
say versus like feeling what is uh what
is that person feeling right now what
are they thinking that's what I'm trying
to do is like putting myself in their
mind and thinking what does the world
look like to them what does the world
feel like to them and so from that I
truly try to listen now I'm also
learning
especially because Rogan and others have
been giving me [ __ ] for not pushing back
it's good sometimes to say
from a place of care for the other human
being to say stop
what did you just say I don't think
that's represents who you are and what
you really mean or maybe
if it does at that time represents who
they are
I could see a better
a better world if they grow into a
different direction and try to point
that direction out to them it was a
really complicated dance between letting
somebody share their full story versus
letting somebody like essentially I
guess like proselytize your audience and
it's like okay hold on let's take a
minute here but yeah I used to be four
or five years ago it was attack attack
attack attack attack whatever you said
and now I'm leaning way more towards
though like okay well tell me how you
feel about everything and then we'll go
from there so a lot of people like my
new approach some older fans will watch
and they're like why are you letting
this guy just Ramble On you know he said
like five or six wrong things and you're
only gonna call them out on two of them
and it's like it's different styles of
conversation but you know do you do a
lot of research beforehand too depending
on the conversation yeah so if we're
going to talk like vaccines and stuff
yeah that's a ton of reading and stuff
that I never thought I'd know going into
it um if it's a more personal like
political philosophy conversation
there's not as much you can prepare for
just it truly depends on the
conversation how much are you actually
listening to the other person I'm always
listening you have to listen because as
soon as you stop listening the quality
of everything falls apart the connection
disappears The Call the conversation
disappears but my natural inclination is
to just be way more aggressive than
normal so I have to constantly remind
myself I guess you would call it a meta
conversation when you're like okay he's
probably saying this because of that or
we'll let him go here and then we'll
stop later but um yeah because my my
preferred style of conversation is like
I'm gonna talk and the second I say
something you disagree with then let's
iron it out right like like I think in
like syllogisms like okay here's the
premise a be good okay premise B okay
and then conclusion and then as long as
we're both deductively sound we're not
crazy no psychosis then we're gonna
agree on everything whereas other people
like to most people think in stories
like narratives like a whole there's a
whole like narrative in the individual
facts don't matter as much because
they'll pick and choose what they want
and it's really hard because everybody
thinks negative so I have to function in
that world but it's uh frustrating for
me sometimes well I've seen uh you've
had a lot of excellent debates one of
them I just recently last night watched
is a on systemic racism and it's the
first time I've seen you completely lose
your [ __ ] oh shoot who was that against
I'm not sure exactly but you were just
very frustrated and sorry not lose your
[ __ ] but you were frustrated constantly
because of the thing let's lay out one
two three and every time you try to lay
it out it would falter I think it had to
do with sort of can you use data to make
an argument or do you need to use a
study that does an interpretation of
that data and then there's like this
tension between I think this is a
behavioral Economist that you were
talking to and the point is you do this
kind of nice layout that the whole point
of Behavioral economics is says there's
more to it than just the data you have
to give the context and like do the rich
rigorous interpretation in the context
of the full human story and then there
was like a dance back and forth
sometimes use data sometimes not and
you're getting really frustrated and
shutting down and so that felt like a
failure mode I've seen Sam Harris have
similar sticking points like if we can't
agree on the terminology we can't go on
to me I feel like uh I'm just sort of
the the winkenstein perspective is like
I think if you get stuck on any one
thing you're just not going to make
progress you have to
part of the conversation has to be
about
uh doing a good dance together
versus being dogmatically stuck on the
path to truth I think the true challenge
is identifying what of those sticking
points are important versus what is not
important it's like if I'm having an
argument with somebody about like Jewish
representation and media they might it
might be like a big conversation and
they might say a couple things like I
think Jewish people you know they tend
to help their own or whatever they're
saying okay but like for the purpose of
the conversation we can keep moving but
if they casually drop like you know yeah
and I think that's why the Holocaust
numbers are blown up from like a hundred
thousand to six million and that's why I
was like okay hold on wait if you think
this we have to stop here because this
is going to be it's not just a language
game in this part if you really believe
this fact then the whole rest of the
conversation is going to be informed by
that belief you know and it has to be
something that doesn't bother you
personally you have to step outside your
own ego
so holga's denial is somebody that would
bother a lot of people and there's some
things just just observing you I feel
like when you get really good at
conversation you can become a stickler
to
um you might have your favorite terms
that really bothers you people don't
agree on those terms begs the question
you mean raising the question yeah I
usually just want if people say stuff I
just let it slide yeah you can't because
if you fight when you're having a
conversation with somebody and you're
talking to their audience at the same
time because that's really what's
happening um you never want to come off
as over combative or over aggressive
because it puts people in like there's
there's like a trigger in your brain and
this is true of relationships and
friendships of persuasive rhetoric or
whatever there's a trigger in the brain
and as soon as that defensive trigger
gets like flipped on everything is over
you've lost the ability to persuade
because everything becomes a fight at
that point yeah well I wanted to talk to
you because I heard somewhere that uh
you were referred to as the Ben Shapiro
of the left and since I'm talking with
Ben as well I wanted to sort of complete
spiritually
this platonic political philosophy
puzzle in my head you are a progressive
but a progressive with many non-standard
Progressive views and you had a heck of
a fascinating journey through all of
that and like I said I think you argue
with passion sometimes with excessive
amounts of passion but don't really
polite way of saying that almost always
with uh good faith and with rigor with
seriousness I asked on your subreddit
which is an excellent subreddit shout
out to the destiny subreddit so much at
least for that particular post what I
really loved is when I asked for
questions for you they were like holy
[ __ ] there's adults in there let's all
behave yeah like nobody say incest I was
like what what's what's going on here
but actually the the the questions that
Rose to the top were really good so uh
somebody said that Destiny was
speaking of your journey was a
conservative in his early teens then he
became a Libertarian then he became a
left-wing social justice Warrior then he
flirted with socialism and now he is a
Social Democrat liberal I've also heard
you refer to yourself as a far left
person so to the degree there's truth to
that Journey can you take me through
your evolution
uh through the landscape of political
ideologies
that you went through so my dad comes
from Kentucky and my mom is a Cuban
immigrant uh Cubans are notorious for
being very conservative in the United
States
um for historical reasons and for other
reasons but um my upbringing was a very
Republican one I grew up listening to
Rush Limbaugh Glenn Beck Michael Savage
on the radio Billy Cunningham
I think Sean Hannity a little bit later
on like uh that was like my whole
upbringing politically I remember I was
writing
I'd written like articles for the school
Journal like in favor of uh defending
the war in Iraq and you know defending
bush from all the criticism et cetera so
that was my upbringing I think once I
hit High School College I had my edgy
like libertarian-esque high school phase
of like reading Iran Rand
um of figuring out that like oh my God
nothing in life matters except for class
and money that's actually the answer to
everything and I got the college I
became a Ron Paul fan very big Ron Paul
fan and then
from there I kind of work do life life
happens at the kind of the lowest point
of my life in terms of where I'm working
financially everything is like kind of
in ruined in my life there's a whole
bunch of dumb stuff that's happened
probably my most conservative point I
don't know what it is about like being
poor and thinking like you can work your
way out of it you can do whatever it's
just my upbringing is always just like
if you're not if you're not if you're
not having financial success work work
work work
um and then I got into streaming very
very lucky break everything just lined
up the right time and then as I've
progressed through streaming I would say
through the years I've gradually Fallen
more and more to the left especially
once my kid turned four five six years
old and I started to see like how much
different his life was just because of
the financial opportunities that I was
able to provide for him through no merit
of his own and that started to radically
change how I viewed the world in a lot
of ways so actually let's like lingo on
that yeah low point
he worked at McDonald's you worked at a
casino
you uh did carpet cleaning what was the
the lowest point definitely the carpet
cleaning really absolutely why why was
it the lowest point that's when you were
just flirting with starting uh streaming
my whole life has been a series of Lucky
breaks really truly uh I grew up playing
a lot of video games but back in my day
our day
um you had to read there's a lot of text
on the screen back in my day we used to
play they didn't all talk stuck yeah
because nowadays everything's voice
acted but back then you would read a lot
I was a really good reader and a really
good vocabulary yeah where'd you
actually say that what games are we
talking about what what do you mean just
reading you're talking about like RPG
yeah jrpg so like Final Fantasy games
fantasy stars like all of these like any
RPG that would have been on the SNES
Sega PlayStation these are the things
that I'm pause on that okay I just
talked to Todd Howard who's
um of the Elder Scrolls Fame and the
Fallout Fame and Beyond what's your
thoughts on Elder Scrolls why is Skyrim
the greatest RPG of all time man and I
really don't like Skyrim or Fallout
games oh really no not at all why do you
hate Skyrim yeah so I really like
characters and like compelling stories
and narratives around those characters
and I like to see them kind of like grow
and change kind of like a movie or a
story so in your like Final Fantasy
games you've got characters
um there are a lot of like um like
classical tropes of like a character
starts off kind of like edgy angsty all
on their own they develop relationships
friendships they realize that the life
is more about themselves and they do
that and I like that that growth that's
kind of what you see in all of those old
uh role-playing games
um I didn't like the open world ones as
much because your main character is just
like a blank slate never talks it's for
you to like project onto but there's not
the same like uh linear Narrative of
like growth for the camera that's
fascinating There's an actual story arc
to the character that's more crafted
yeah in a beautiful way by the designers
of the game yeah that's another one is
better or worse I tend towards like I
want to hear a compelling story around
like a set of characters that like grow
and changes again oh that's beautifully
put in yeah I I just really loved being
able to leave the town
you go outside the town and you look
outside its nature and the world of
possibilities is before you you can do
whatever the [ __ ] you want I mean that
immensity of just being lost in the
world is really immersive for me but
yeah you're right whatever attracts you
about a world so you were just starting
to
play video games you go out play the
video games that's one of your lucky
breaks there's just like a lot of random
skills you pick up depending on the type
of game you play I played a lot of
text-based games on the computer so I
was a very fast typer I'm still a very
fast typer
um read a lot you know learned weird
kind of math stuff for some of the
calculations some of the games I think
I'm pretty good at getting information
figuring stuff out learning patterns all
of that and then that plus the reading
and everything of the games meant that I
I don't want to say I excelled in school
because my grades were pretty bad but I
was in like all honors all AP classes or
whatever a lot of dual enrollment a lot
of AP credit going into college so I did
pretty well in school probably better
than I should have but it was because I
had the game stuff that was like really
powering a lot of my brain there while I
was trying to sleep through class so
yeah so you're able to soak in
information integrate it and be quickly
take notes generally I think I'm pretty
good at that yeah what uh you do this a
lot when you stream your typing stuff is
there a system in that note taking and
what note what do you use for note
taking uh doesn't matter I use a notepad
notepad the original notepad yep
notepad.exe not the plus plus not is
there genius to the madness behind that
or you just don't give a [ __ ] no I mean
like it's going to depend on the style
of conversation if I'm with somebody
that is very meticulously organized
their thoughts and they're a uh find a
better word here for Rambler you can
edit that in better word for Rambler
yeah something that talks a lot a lot
I'll start like taking notes bullet
points like this this this this this
this because um there's a style of
conversation where I say seven or eight
different things and then when you go to
respond to everything I said I cut you
off immediately and we argue that point
but if somebody's gonna do that he's
just like hold on you just said these
eight things I'm going to respond to
every single one I've written them all
down and then you can go if you want to
go Point by point we can but you just
said all this and I wrote it down so
we're gonna go so what are you actually
writing down like a couple words per
point they left honestly like there are
very few unique conversations in
politics like a lot of them are kind of
retreading old ground so for having a
debate on abortion
um somebody might say like oh well I
believe this thing about viability and I
believe this thing about you know when
when there are fetus versus a human and
I'll just write down like those points
so that when I go to respond I kind of
have like uh like note cards like a
guiding thing there to keep me centered
on my response political discourse is
the kind of tree you're walking down I
got it and you're like taking just to
keep my focus guided so I'm not like
running off on a weird tangent or
responding to something I didn't say or
something yeah what about like doing
research it's just is there a system to
your note taking because mentally you
seem to be one of the most organized
people I've listened to so is there is
it in your mind or is there a system
that's on paper a little of both I feel
like the human mind is a beautiful thing
if you have interest in an area uh so
like what I'll tell people is let's say
there's like a totally new topic that
I'm researching I don't know anything
and I'll do a couple of these on stream
I think they're born people watch it I
might open a Wikipedia article and I'll
read and I hit something I don't know
and then I open the next Wikipedia
article and I'll read into and then I
might have like seven tabs open and I'll
read and I'll read and I'll read
um and I'll read a ton of stuff maybe
for hour two three four hours of stuff
and then by the end you know someone in
chat will ask me like do you even
remember like this this particular thing
and I'll say not really no not too much
but what happens is as long as you've
seen it once what will happen is like
the next day the day after we'll read
something else and we're like oh I
remember that thing from this thing I
remember like vaguely that and then if
you see it like a third time you're like
oh this makes sense because especially
when it comes to oh here's like a little
trick on stuff if you're ever reading
any news and there's a place that pops
up always look at it on a map because so
much of history is like on a map it's so
important to like know the geography it
makes things make so much more sense
um but yeah once I once I start to see
stuff over and over again just because
I've like read it a few times stuff will
start to kind of connect to my mind and
like oh yeah well this makes sense of
course these people believe this because
of this or of course like this happen
here it's because you know that happened
there
um so yeah it's a lot of that if there's
like a topic that I'm doing specific
research for
um so like vaccine related stuff is a
big one the Ukrainian Russian conflict
is a big one that I'll break out a note
um I'll probably get like a Google doc
and I'll just start like writing like an
outline of kind of the rough points of
everything just to organize is my
thoughts around different topics yeah
we're just going to go tangent upon a
tangent upon a tangent so we'll return
to the low point of your life at some
point okay always returning from the
philosophy to the psychology so you did
uh the Ukraine topic
one question is
what role does US play
in this war could they have done
something to avoid the war
uh the devil to play in forcing Vladimir
Putin's hand
do they have a role to play in um
de-escalating the war towards a peace
agreement and the opposite if it does
escalate
uh towards something like the use of a
tactical nuclear weapon are they to
blame are we to blame oh man somebody
sent me an email a while ago with great
words
um there's a specific way to navigate a
conversation where you can kind of like
contribute to a negative event but
you're not really the one responsible
for it
um like the classic example is a woman
goes out late at night gets a little bit
too drunk and then something happens and
it's like well there might have been
steps you could have taken to mitigate
the risk it's not her fault of what
happened because the responsibility
rests on the on the agent making the
choice right there's a Chooser at some
point that is choosing to do wrong or
evil
I don't believe in any of the arguments
that say the United States has
contributed to Russia's position on
Ukraine or the actions they've taken on
Ukraine there are several arguments that
some people uh some even political
Scholars are are putting out there to
say that the United States is to blame
but I find them completely unconvincing
I think that when you ask the question
of like what is the United States role
or what has our role been I think it's
really important for us I don't think we
even agree as a country on what our role
should be which I think is a hard one
because you've got this kind of there's
this growing populist movement in the
United States it might be the far left
in the far right and I think populous
tend to have this kind of isolationist
view of the world where the United
States should just be our own thing we
shouldn't be telling anybody what to do
we shouldn't be the World Police and
then kind of more in these like Center
left center right positions and then
across a lot of Europe you've got well
okay the United States is kind of like
the big kid on the Block like we're
looking to them for guidance and
Leadership on situations like what's
going on in Ukraine so insofar as uh the
original question is like what what is
like the United States responsibility I
think we have a responsibility to ensure
the relative like Freedom prosperity and
stability across Europe I think that
defending Ukraine's sovereignty and
right to their borders is a part of that
and I don't believe that prior to the
invasion in 2822 I don't think the
United States was contributing to Russia
invading that country I know there are
arguments given that like the expansion
of NATO you know has something that's
been threatening to Russia but the
baltics joined and Russia didn't do
anything about it the invasion to Crimea
was very clearly a response to the
revolution in 2014 The Invasion on the
borders is clearly a response to Ukraine
winning that Civil War in the Southeast
and the donbos and Russia becoming more
aggressive I don't think that you can
blame any of that on on NATO expansion
there's no NATO countries that are
threatening Russia orbiting Russia do
you think there is a nuclear threat
do you think about this do you worry
about this that there is a threat of a
tactical nuclear weapon being dropped I
think that possibility exists either way
and I think the responsibility for that
is on Russia because it can't it just
can't be the case that if you have nukes
you're allowed to invade countries and
take their land because of anything I
think that that down the road also
increased increases the potential for
nuclear problems in the future right
because at that point either every
single country has to acquire their own
nuclear weapons because if you don't
Russia is going to mess with you or
every single country has to join NATO
and now what we're back at square zero
Ground Zero square one where people like
oh well look all these countries joining
NATO is aggressive towards Russia like
what are you gonna do
yeah you've mentioned that um there's a
complicated calculus going on with the
countries that have uh they have nuclear
weapons and what's our responsibility
are you allowed to do anything you want
to countries that don't have nuclear
weapons
that's a really tricky discussion for
sure because what is UI supposed to do
if Russia drops a tactic when you grow
weapon there's a set of options
none of which are good and
it's such a tricky moment right now
because uh the things that Biden and
other public figures say I feel like has
a significant impact on the way this
game turns out because I think mutually
sure destruction is partially a game of
words now I mean I believe in the power
of our conversation
of leaders talking to each other I feel
like
you have to have a balance between
threat and compromise
and like
empathy for the needs the geopolitical
the economic needs of a Nation but also
sort of respect
and represent your own interests so it's
a tricky one like how do you play the
how do you play the hand it reminds me
of um I don't know if you've ever heard
in like evolutionary psych Evolution or
biology there are things called Tit for
Tat strategies it kind of reminds me of
that where it's like if like uh there
are a whole bunch of these little
biological mechanisms where creatures
will develop like socializing like Tit
for Tat if you do something bad to me
I'm gonna do something bad for you and
then more complicated schemes will come
out where it'll be like tit tip for Tat
or it's like you can make one mistake
and then I'm gonna get you if you do a
second one or could be Tit for Tat or
they're gonna be tit for a tat tat for
there's like all these like back and
forths where creatures kind of optimize
themselves and
um yeah I think something the United
States did really well in terms of that
kind of conversational strategy and I
approved of this in the beginning was
Biden was very clear about setting out
like the exact level of U.S involvement
for the war we're not going to do a
no-fly zone there's not going to be US
troops on the ground in Ukraine but we
are going to send a whole bunch of money
and a whole bunch of arms and a whole
bunch of Intel to them and I thought he
did a good job at laying out like the
limitation of the OS involvement while
opening as much as we could in the ways
we could help but the um yeah that
looming threat of some sort of tactical
nuclear weapon I think on the table
right now is like it's going to be the
annihilation of like Russian sea forces
and everything but you know what happens
if it continues to escalate that's like
a world that nobody wants to nobody
wants to be in yeah
so we talked about difficult
conversations and again thank you so
much for reviewing the yay conversation
let me ask you about Putin
speaking of difficult conversations so
if you sit down if I sit down with
somebody like Vladimir Putin or Vladimir
zielinski
what's the right way to have that
conversation oh man we can talk about
that one we could talk about
somebody more well understood
through history like some like Stalin or
Hitler somebody like that maybe that's
an easier example to illustrate
how to handle extremely difficult
conversations yeah I mean I can have a
really difficult conversation between
like two people
um leaders of countries though you're
there's so much that you are
representing in that conversation I
guess the thing that would be
interesting to me
would be like what is Vladimir Putin's
interest like what is the genuine
interest that he has in the conflict
because I think finding out like what is
your buy-in or what is your like what is
the driving force keeping you here is
probably the most important thing
um I think first zolensky I think it's a
it's quite a bit more simpler because
he's he's on the defense so he's
defending his country and his people
um for Putin I've heard all sorts of
things uh you know Dugan has his
writings on uh you know like the East
versus the West the collapse of the West
and the face of like all of the
liberalism and the weird LGBT stuff that
they criticize you've got the desire to
like return to this like former Soviet
union-esque thing you've got Putin's
quotes that the collapse of the Soviet
Union was the biggest geopolitical
disaster you know of 20th century and I
guess figuring out like what is Putin
after I'm not actually sure I don't know
the answer that question a lot of people
write about it but yeah well there's a
lot of answers to that question there's
a lot of answers that he can give to
that question so say I sit down with him
for three hours and talk about it
I think
this is a really interesting distinction
because you do do difficult
conversations in the space of ideas but
also in your stream you have I mean
there's a bunch of drama going on
there's there's a human psychology is
laid out uh in its full richness before
you so to me with leaders I think
a part of the conversation has to be
about the human psychology sure
not like a meta conversation but like
really understand what they feel what
they fear who they are as a human being
like as a family man
as a as a person proud of their country
as a person with an ego as a person
who's been affected if not corrupted by
Powers all of us can be and likely are
so all of that that gives context to
then the answers about what do you want
in this war because the answers about
what you want in this war will be
political answers it's like it's like a
game that's being played again with
words and politicians are incredibly
good at playing that game I think the
deeper truth
comes from understanding the human being
from which those words come
and I think that's what you do I don't
know if you do those kinds of
conversations where I've never talk to
any country later so no not not a
country leader but say a controversial
figure or somebody that represents a
certain idea don't just talk in the
space of ideas or challenge the ideas
but understand who is this person how
did you come to those ideas oh yeah when
I've had there have been a couple of
very controversial right-leaning figures
um so the two obviously the My Stream is
Lauren Southern and Nick Fuentes and
those types of conversations initially
aren't very political at all yeah it's
more like like obviously we believe in
very very different things but like
beliefs don't happen accidentally so how
did you get to where you are those are
way more personal conversations that's
true now is there things you regret
about those conversations where you
failed is there things you're proud of
what you succeeded for things that I'm
proud of I feel like I feel like I'm
really good at attempting to understand
people without judgment that I think a
lot of people feel like they can have
conversations with me where they can
share a lot and I'm not going to jump
down their throat for them having a
politically incorrect observation or for
them being judgmental to somebody else
or having like a feeling that's maybe
not something they should have something
embarrassed about so I think I do a
really good job at that and then by
extension of that I've gotten the
ability to hear perspective from so many
different people that I think I can
understand a lot of different
perspectives
um for failures of mine I mean it's
always going to be
on stream it'll be like I didn't push
back hard enough or I didn't know like a
certain fact for a conversation these
are usually the they're going to be on
these like very technical grounds
generally I'm pretty happy with like the
direction my conversations have gone uh
recently especially over like the past
six months so your goal is to
de-radicalize the audience of those
folks and so that used to be my goal uh
my goal was de-radicalization now I'm
kind of hoping that that's just the
byproduct so the goal I think is to talk
to somebody and to show they believe
this because of these reasons and if you
want to change people's beliefs we have
to talk about the underlying reasons for
why they think the things they think
it's not enough to just say like that
belief is bad because it's like well
they believe it for a whole bunch of
things that are true and real to them at
least so you have to address all the
underlying things that they believe
before you can change the overlying
belief so if I'm having a conversation
with somebody it'll be like okay why do
you feel this about that that and that
okay I understand that maybe like a
better way to solve that would be like
this or that instead of this thing so to
what degree do you have to empathize
with the person's world view
versus pushback that's that's always the
hard one uh when I'm talking to other
people it's almost always me stepping as
much inside their bubble as I can I have
to like live and breathe their worldview
and be able to speak their world view in
order to like navigate their thoughts
because my world view is um I don't I'm
not even using as an insult I don't know
if I am a little bit Autistic or
something but when I break apart things
I just want to see like study study
study fact fact that's how my mind works
for everything that's just that's what I
like to see like um personal stories
don't do much for me narratives don't do
much for me just show me like the the
data and the studies or whatever but for
other people I think most brains are
more human than that and they tend to
see things in more kind of like uh
surreal pictures that are kind of
painted and the brush Strokes are way
broader and you know they don't care
about the itty bitty tiny fact
um so if I'm talking to somebody else
and I'm trying to get into their head
and I'm trying to change their mind on
things I'm going to be stepping into
their world
and I'm going to try to be working
through that framework really good
example might be
um we'll say like when it comes to trans
issues for minors okay 16 or 17 year old
needs to get on puberty blockers the way
that I want that debate to play out is
uh let's look at all the data let's see
what are the outcomes uh let's see what
are the processes for getting a
medication and then we'll evaluate all
of that and then we'll go in whatever
like points more favorably but that's
wholly unconvincing to most people right
so as a parent if I'm having that
conversation with another parent the
easiest way for me to have that
conversation is like hey we both have
kids imagine how horrible it would be if
we felt like our kids needed help and
the government was trying to get between
us and and their doctor and that
conversation that might be how that talk
plays out which I think that's a really
good argument because I think there
probably are times when the government
should get in between but I'll have that
conversation because now I'm in a world
where they understand what I'm saying
I'm resonating with the way that they
feel about things and then I can make
progress with the way that they're kind
of viewing the world because I'm talking
in a language they understand so on this
particular topic of trans issues is that
the reason you were banned from twitch
I'm not sure I don't know uh they just
said hate speech but I don't use like
slurs or anything so it's hard to know
exactly so I think you made the claim
that trans women shouldn't compete with
CIS women in the women's Athletics
can you
make this case and can you still man the
case against it I think in your
community there's a lot of trans folks
who love you and there's a lot who hate
you yeah and so if you can walk the
tightrope of this conversation to try to
steal me on both sides one of the
argumentative strategies I say is that
like any time you have a conversation
you should be able to argue both sides
better than anybody else you know so um
for the for the my side the genuine
belief side
um it feels like overwhelmingly all of
the data is showing that trans mostly
trans women uh even after I think three
years on some sort of like HRT or you
know estrogen uh stuff they're still
maintaining these advantages from their
male puberty over cisgender women and if
that is the case if we are going to draw
these distinctions around our Sports
between women and men it feels unfair to
have a category inside the women's
sports that are maintaining advantages
that are coming from a male puberty
regardless of the amount of time they've
spent on hormone replacement therapy
so that would be my argument on that
side so it's unfair from a performance
enhancement aspect so the same way we've
been
performance performance enhancing drugs
that involve increasing of testosterone
in that same way would be unfair
essentially yeah so what's the case uh
against the key yeah so the case in
favor of them competing together is that
realistically there's not going to be a
transports category uh realistically
trans women aren't going to be
competitive with CIS men because they've
gone through these huge uh you know like
hormone changes by the medication
they're taking
and that when we look at how sports are
kind of done anyway there's a whole
bunch of biological differences between
people within sports categories that are
determining their placement in the
professional world so for instance
um somebody like me is probably never
going to go far in the NBA because I'm
not tall enough I think the average
height in the NBA don't doubt yourselves
don't doubt myself yeah I want to say
it's like six six or something they're
huge people
um or you know you look at like Michael
Phelps as a classic example of a guy
whose torso is like so long his body is
built for swimming and I think there are
some trans people that will look at that
or somebody advocating for this position
they'll look at that they'll go okay
realistically the way that Michael
Phelps body processes lactic acid the
shape physiologically of his body is
going to put him in a level of
competition that so many men are never
going to reach just because of biology
how is it fair that you can have these
biological outliers competing in these
categories but then when we come to like
sports categories with translucentous
women you're going to take trans women
and say that they can't compete against
women can't you also just say that they
have some level of biological difference
there like is it really going to be that
great of a difference than what Michael
Phelps has versus the average swimmer or
an NBA player has versus like the
average height male
yeah
do you think we're going to get into
some tricky ethical territory as we
start to be able to uh through biology
and genetics modify the human body
absolutely I feel like those things are
coming sooner than uh we want to assume
them to uh the uh oh man dude the a have
you seen the AI art yes that's a of
course I'm an AI person oh okay then
yeah yeah that's a uh that's always been
like uh what's gonna happen when uh when
robots can do art better than humans LOL
like well we'll see in 20 years in 20
years and 20 years and now you have ai
art winning competitions and it's funny
because
robots are essentially the robot behind
you by the way the robot behind me oh
nice
um robots are really good careful what
you say yeah I got it I'll be careful um
that's not like one of the Chinese ones
with a gun on it right oh okay uh
hopefully not uh we'll see depending on
what you say yeah okay robots are really
good at showing the limitations of the
human mind in categories that we didn't
believe we were limited before I I think
that humans have this idea intrinsically
that we have like some type of like
Innovative Creative Drive that is just
outside of the bounds of physical
understanding and with a sophisticated
enough program we see that maybe that's
not actually true and that's a really
scary thing philosophically to deal with
because we feel like we're very special
right we own the planet we make
computers and the idea that you can
start to get these robots that can do
things that's like okay you can do math
fine okay you can do calculations
because it's fine but you can't do art
that's the human stuff and then when
they start to do that it's like oh shoot
and that terrifies you a little bit like
a losing the human species losing
control of our dominance I don't think
it's necessarily losing control of our
dominance I mean I guess like a Skynet
thing could come in at some point but I
think I think it more it it brings us to
this really fundamental level of like
what does it mean to be human what is it
that we're good at
um what should we be doing with
technology we never really asked that
question in the western world it's
always the technology is like normative
and that technology equals good and more
technology equals better that's been
like the default assumption in fact if
you ask a lot of people how do you know
if civilization has progressed over the
past 100 or 200 years they don't say we
have better relationships we um you know
have longer marriages we blah blah
they'll say technology has improved
we've got crazy phones we've got crazy
computers and um the idea that more
technology might be bad has never even
crossed somebody's mind unless it's used
for like a really bad thing so well it's
interesting we kind of think as more and
more automation is happening we're going
to get more and more meaning from things
like being artists and doing creative
Pursuits and here's like oh [ __ ]
if the r if the creative proceeds are
also being automated then what are we
going to gain meaning from what are the
activities from what you'll gain meaning
you know my whole life I've been working
on artificial intelligence systems
there's been different revolutions one
of them is is the is the machine
learning Revolution and
it's interesting to build up intuition
and destroy that intuition about what is
and isn't solvable by machines I think
um for the longest time I grew up
thinking go is not the game will go is
not solvable uh because my understanding
of AI systems is ultimately that it's
is is fundamentally a search mechanism
that is fundamentally going to be Brute
Force there's no shortcuts sure like I
try like if it can't solve the traveling
salesman problem it's not even going to
be able to give you an approximation so
most interesting problems are giant
travel salesman problem and then so of
course it's not gonna be able to solve
that and then you then uh the Deep
learning Revolution made you realize
holy [ __ ] these large neural networks
are the giant number of knobs is able to
actually somehow uh estimate functions
that can do a pretty good job of
understanding deep representation of a
thing whether that's a game of Go or
whether it's the human natural language
or if it's images and video or
um audio and even actions and different
video games and actions of Robotics and
so on and then you realize with
diffusion models and different different
generative models you start to realize
holy [ __ ] it can actually generate not
not just
interesting
representations or interesting
manifestations of the representations of
forms but it's able to do something that
impresses humans in its creativity it's
it's beautiful in the way we think of
art is beautiful like it surprises us
and makes us chuckle it makes us sit
back in awe and all those kinds of
things and yet the thing that it seems
to struggle with the most is the
physical world currently
so that that's a counterintuitive we
humans think that it's um it's pretty
trivial the being able to pick up a cup
being able to like write with a pen like
in the physical space would think that's
trivial we give ourselves respect for
being great artists and great uh
mathematicians and all that kind of
stuff and that seems to be much easier
than the physical space our bodies are
really cool yeah there is a um I don't
know it's probably Asimov or something
there's some science fiction writer that
had a short story and it was like an
alien that had landed on Earth and it
was describing our bodies from a totally
alien perspective and when you think
about all the things we can do it's
pretty cool we can you know climb
through a whole multitude of
environments we can exist in a multitude
of temperatures we can manipulate things
um just with our hands and you know the
way that we can interact with things
around us and yeah we're very capable on
like a physical level even though like
you said we think about ourselves like
oh well human beings have really big
brains and we do we're really
intelligent as well but yeah our bodies
are pretty cool too
and it's a fascinating hierarchical
biological system like um
that were made up of a bunch of
different
like living organisms
that all don't know about the big
picture of our body and it's all
functioning its own little local world
and it's doing its thing but together it
has a of it forms a super resilient
system all of that comes from
a very uh compressed
encoding of what makes a human you start
with the DNA and it builds up from a
single cell to a giant organism I mean
and because of the DNA through the
evolution process you can constantly
create new humans and new living
organisms that adapt to the environment
like that resilience to the physical
world
it seems like running the whole earth
over again
the whole evolutionary process over
again is uh might be the only way to do
it so to create a robot that actually
adapts
is as resilient to the dynamic world
might be a really difficult problem
possibly well it's going to say like in
a programming environment you can do
things on time scales that are
impossible in the real world right like
the benefit to Ai and computers is a
computational they can compute so much
data so quickly whereas on human
timetables we have to wait when you talk
about Evolution
um you know it's generation after
generation after generation you know
maybe in a virtual environment that
could be simulated and then those
changes Could Happen a lot quicker with
this in a human time scale but you have
to look at Earth
at a Quantum as a quantum mechanical
system the computation is happening
super fast this is a giant computer
doing a giant simulation so just because
for us humans it's slow there's like
trillions of organisms involved in you
Destiny being you sure but the next
iteration of like from Human to human
even if under the quantum love is a lot
of stuff going on you talk about like um
like changes in DNA for instance right
like that's happening from a generation
a generation time scale like in a
virtual environment that could
theoretically happen well it already is
there's like protein folding like huge
cloud computing probably ml stuff that's
like working on doing all that stuff and
it'll run like trillions and trillions
of simulations you know every second and
stuff maybe not every second but still
slower than the actual protein folding
much slower the that's for the problem
of solving protein folding uh to
estimate the 3D structure but the actual
body does the actual protein folding way
faster so like we're the question is can
we shortcut the simulation of human
evolution try to figure out how to build
up an organism without simulating all
the details because we have to simulate
all the details of biology were screwed
we don't have our chair we'd have to put
something in a pond and then watch it
for that might be the only way to do it
sure that's what the universe most
likely is it's a kind of simulation
created by a teenager in their basement
to to try to see what happens it's a
it's a computer game that might be the
most efficient way to create interesting
organisms but within this system is
perhaps possible to create
other robots that will be of use and
will entertain us in a way that other
humans entertain us and that's a really
interesting of course problem but it's
surprising how difficult it has been
to create systems that operate in the
physical world and operate in that
physical world in a way that's safe to
humans and interesting to humans because
there's also the human factor the human
robot interaction to me that's like the
most interesting problem to figure out
how to do that well and uh so
Elon Musk and others Boston Dynamics
have worked on legged robots so I I
really care about legged robots
those are super interesting how to make
them such that they're
able to operate successfully in a
dynamic environment super tricky they're
like they're like the dumbest of dogs
speaking of which there's a dog barking
outside I mean it's it's really tricky
to create those kinds of organisms that
live in a in the human world then again
if more and more of us move into the
digital world
so you stream a lot like part of Who You
Are
exists in the digital space the fact
that you have a physical representation
also
maybe more and more will become not
important
I hope that's the case because I bought
a lot of stock in meta and man it's down
met at the company yeah is there some
degree like can you can you can you look
at yourself like Stephen the physical
meat vehicle and then the destiny this
digital space like digital
Avatar do you sense that in a certain
way you're the digital Avatar I've
always tried to keep my on-stream
personality as genuine as possible so
they're one and the same to me I don't
really view them as two separate
entities so but I mean I always view
myself as Stephen the real life person
my Destiny's my online name but no but
because so many your social network is
established the digital space like so
many people know you through the digital
space can there be can we swap out
another person that looks like you
and like an AI system and then that
entity known as Destiny will continue
existing so I mean it must be like there
must be some level of sophistication
that could emulate a human brain I would
imagine right
probably the text not there yet but well
the question is what's the level of
sophistication of the audience that
would recognize that something has
changed
like it's the touring test yeah how hard
is it to trick your audience your your
large audience of fans that watch your
streams that when you swap out in the AI
that emulates you that nothing has
changed
and the question is do you have to
really simulate so much of the human
brain for that I don't think so probably
not and so I mean like you said a lot of
political discourses just walking down
the tree together so you can probably
emulate a lot of that discussion yeah it
would depend on if you're doing old data
sets and you're training on that and I'm
having conversations about abortion and
Ukrainian vaccines I imagine it could do
it for quite a while the only thing that
would be weird is when novel issues pop
up then you probably need a more
sophisticated resemblance of the inner
brain right now you have to keep keep
training on the internet so how the
language models and that's the most
incredible breakthroughs is the language
models you just have to keep retraining
the system on Reddit which is actually
what a lot of it is trained on it's just
hilarious I do think it's really
interesting that like kind of like funny
problems like the trolley problem that
we can kind of work through our
normative ethical systems on are now
like real questions like if you're
driving a Tesla and it's on autopilot
and you're going to hit somebody but it
can swerve and hit somebody else like
what what ought the system do like we
went very quickly from fun kind of like
project in philosophy class too we need
to solve this for insurance purposes
like as quickly as possible it's kind of
interesting to think about well I
actually have uh I'll bring up the
trolley problem with you later there's a
fascinating version of it that I find
hilarious okay uh let's let's return to
your low point oh yeah uh
uh you started playing video games that
was a lucky break you uh you did
text-based ones that was a lucky break
because you gotten to be pretty good at
learning and then you started thinking
about going to college and so on what
happened next I mean I went to like a
prep school so you kind of have to go to
college after that's like the point
right I was also a millennial they all
of us had to go to college that's always
what they told us so
um my life was kind of uh it's hard to
describe I don't really think much of
the future I was just kind of enjoying
the day-to-day because everything in my
life was pretty weird both my parents
had moved to Florida by the time I was
16 17. I was looking like Grandma I was
working I had a girlfriend moved out we
got a place did College
uh by the time I got into college I had
transitioned from working at McDonald's
to I was like working in a casino
restaurant basically and I was really
good at that job so a high level of
patience for drunk people and same
people and I was doing music in school
because I've really grown to love music
and my kind of thought process was my
thought process was I can do music as a
hobby I guess unless I get really good
and maybe I can make money with that but
otherwise I love music I'm okay going to
school for music getting good at it and
then just doing that on the side and
then my main job would kind of be this
career was building at the casino
and basically the trying to balance
personal life plus graveyard shift six
day hour weeks at a casino and then a
full-time music degree was not possible
for me and eventually I had to drop
school after I think it was like three
years and after I dropped school to
maintain my Casino job
um after a few months I got fired from
my Casino job so I'd essentially just
thrown away like the past like three or
four years of my life why'd you get
fired from the casino job I heard
there's a story behind that yeah there's
a story basically I was just really dumb
when it came to understanding corporate
politics and I this is funny because the
same attitude kind of followed me into
the streaming world my thought process
has kind of always been
um that like as long as I'm really good
at what I do I should be Untouchable if
I'm really good you can't do anything to
me I don't have to play any dumb games
or whatever
and at the casino I think I was the
youngest it was originally shiftly the
supervisor position at the casino and
when I started to get my own shifts
there were problems that I would run
into on graveyard shift because of
carryover from the swing shift remember
one of these problems was underneath the
soda machine they weren't cleaning it
properly and fruit flies were showing up
and I my the manager came in one morning
and she was like uh hey what's going on
with the machine and I was like listen I
can't do I can't take everything from
swing shift and do everything at
grapeshift I can't do this they need to
figure out their stuff better or I need
more employees it's not possible for me
and she's like what did you tell anybody
else yeah I complained to the supervisor
on the swing shift all the time and she
told me if you're not getting the answer
that you like then it's your
responsibility to email the next person
up I was like oh okay that's interesting
and some months went on and I ran into
more problems Jake is on graveyard
here's how I don't know if it's
everywhere but morning shift is the
easiest and that's when you're the most
overstaffed because that's when all the
VPS are in and that's when all the
managers are there and everybody blah
blah swing shift is the most challenging
it's with your highest flow of customers
is you're also decently staffed there
but there's a lot of stuff going on and
graveyard nobody cares at all about you
they don't give you any employees you
might get swamped you might not who
cares make sure it's clean for day shift
that's the only thing that matters a
quick question of clarification so this
is a 24-hour 24-hour diner yeah this is
the dining Casino oh by the way I had an
amazing moment uh dying in a casino
recently it's a special place a dining
casino is a place of magic there's a lot
of magic there's a lot of other worldly
stuff going on there's characters
there's and uh the they had an
interaction with the waitress that was
the sweetest waitress in the world and
it was just like I don't know made me
feel less alone on this cruel world of
ours uh so graveyard begins when for me
my shift was 10 pm to 6 a.m or sometimes
I got called in early so be 8 P.M to 6
a.m that's uh no love for that shift no
especially not trying to do school at
the same time absolutely not
um but yeah basically long story short I
ran into a problem with my super where I
didn't have enough employees on my shift
VPS were coming in the morning they're
like hey the diner's kind of dirty and
I'm like you've cut all my employees
past 4 am like on some nights I'm
literally cooking and doing front of
house like all on my own like I can't do
this and my manager Pam told me well you
got to figure it out and so I remembered
her advice so I emailed the VP of food
and beverage and I cc'd her and I said
I'm not getting the help I need in my
restaurant now I didn't know at the time
that I was basically completely throwing
her under the bus because of that email
but I retroactively when I look back on
things or retrospectively I see that was
the moment that I got like marked for
deletion and I didn't really understand
it even though I heard terminology for
papering somebody out the door but after
that point I started to get written up
for like a lot of little random things
like I'll come like I'd missed one day
of work in my three years at the casino
and I started to get rid enough for like
showing up like one or two minutes late
that's kind of weird that's whatever or
written up for random ways about filing
paperwork and then eventually there came
a situation with another employee where
they were it's complicated it has to
like call that stuff but basically they
wanted to come or they wanted to call
out and I told them if they called out
they were gonna get fired because they
were at like 10 points they were at nine
points and ten points of firing blah
blah blah Pam Toby uh you can tell her
that she's gonna get a point but you
can't tell if she's gonna get fired I
don't know what that meant and then I
told her that if you call out you're
gonna get you know you're [ __ ] you're
gonna get fired or you're going to be at
10 points and then I got called in early
like three days later and Pam was like
uh you inappropriately communicated with
an employee because you said the f word
in a text message and I'm like really
there's no shot and she's like well you
also tried to fire the employee and it's
like no I told her she was gonna get 10
points she's like well you use the f
word I'm like that this is insane and uh
I didn't just because I was such a such
a high performing employees like there's
no way I'm getting fired and then I did
and I was like yeah cash out my 401k and
moped for like three months because I
had thrown away school for this casino
job and then I got fired from this job
that like yeah nobody believed I got
fired it was just insane so if you look
back if you were allowed to not just to
look back to your own memory but
actually watch yourself like somebody
recorded video that whole time do you
think you would be surprised you would
notice some things like potentially of
not having a self-awareness not having
like social
like a Civility and social etiquette
that's played in the human relations
yeah absolutely
so is that is that at the core of it
essentially yeah I think so I mean that
follows me even to this day there's a
lot of um I don't know if you're
recording or not but when we spoke
earlier about like meta conversations I
have to think a lot sometimes about meta
conversations because the way that I
want to drive a conversation will
sometimes be way different than what is
like the best way to have a conversation
whereas I just want to like go really
hard on like some itty bitty like some
idiosyncrasy or some Factor figure
whatever but that's not like the human
conversation I need to have you know
yeah so you got fired slash left that
job uh and then took you to the the job
that would be the lowest point yeah
because there was a huge downgrade in
Pay I went from getting like I think at
the casino because I worked so much
overtime I was getting like 22.50 an
hour on all my overtime Fifth and this
was back in 2008 2009 as like a college
student like it's amazing pay
um I had benefits like everything was
good and then the carpet cleaning was
like I was probably getting my paycheck
like every other week was maybe 1500
bucks or a thousand dollars and I'm
working like 13 day stretches like I
have every other Sunday off and it's so
many hours like I have to show up at the
shop at like seven or six and then I go
home at like eight or nine depending on
when my jobs are throughout the day are
you doing uh businesses or residential
or what are you doing everything
everything are you working for a company
that is
okay so like there's a schedule thing
you have to go to it and so on yeah but
so like this is why the schedule would
start because sometimes I'd show up at I
I think we had to be in the shop at I
think it was 7am we show up at the shop
at 7am first job might be at eight or
nine but that job might be like a one
hour job so I might show up at 7am and
have a job from 8 30 to 9 30. then my
next job might not be from until like
say 11. so from 8 30 9 30 I'll do one
job and then I'm going to drop from like
11 to 12 or something then I might have
like a decent job from like five to
eight
but like my whole day is destroyed
and I'm I'm doing like three smallish
jobs so I'm getting like 30 bucks maybe
for being in the shop or you know my job
for like 10 or 11 hours and it's just
like horrible so here's somebody that
seems to be extremely good at thinking
and conversation and so have a bit of an
ego perhaps uh in in the both the
negative and the positive sense of that
word was there some aspect of working a
McDonald's
and then working at the casino and
working for the uh as a carpet cleaner
that was humbling no never
um I had a the ego burned bright through
it all the well or no yeah you can push
back on the eagle yeah no I understand I
totally get what you mean um I had a
really close friend growing up whose
name was Chris and I think we probably
met when he was we were like four or
five I think he lived behind me and I
grew up with him and I'd always been
kind of an outsider to the world that I
was in once I got to high school for
sure because all of those kids were
incredibly wealthy you know Corvettes
and Mustangs when they turned 16 it was
a prep school and I was doing the they
had like a work study program there
where you could stay after school from 2
30 to 5 every day to kind of like work
to pay for your tuition so I've been
working like throughout all of high
school I got another job at McDonald's
when I was 18 worked at the casino like
I'd always been doing that kind of work
I never really viewed it as like beneath
me or anything it's not like I don't
have like a family of doctors or lawyers
or anything and then me and my other
friend uh Chris guy we'd always make fun
of everybody else for being kind of like
uh you know like preppy kids and
everything so so there was a there's
some pride to that sort of hard work
yeah I guess a little bit Yeah because
yeah looking especially my dad like the
solution to every problem was just throw
more hours of work at it basically so
that was always my yeah go-to and I
never yeah what was psychologically the
low point
I think psychologically the low point
was that um as I'm doing this carpet
cleaning job uh driving around my city
there's like this feeling of
I guess for a lot of people it's
probably college but there's a feeling
when you're in high school that
everything is like so exciting and the
whole world is kind of in front of you
and there are a trillion trillion
different branching Paths of
possibilities and you know even through
high school you're thinking like am I
going to be a doctor or a lawyer or can
I join the MBA or can I do this or that
there's all these things in front of you
and when I I especially felt it when I
was doing these carpet cleaning jobs and
um
I think it was in the fall I'd be
outside some of these houses and I just
kind of look around and I'd recognize a
lot of these neighborhoods that I drive
around with friends in or I'd you know
be walking through I ran cross country
some of them I'd be running through
these neighborhoods and it was just kind
of like this feeling of looking around
and it was like
when I was here in the past this was
like kind of like a transitionary phase
of my life where I'm doing this and it's
so fun and exciting and then I'm going
to move on to something else and it's
going to be fun and exciting and awesome
and then like you know two years later
my whole life has collapsed like I'm in
a house that I can't afford anymore my
ex that I hate is pregnant with my kid
and I have no money I've got no upward
Mobility I failed College I my job is
horrible like just every single out like
this is like my all of those the wave
function had collapsed into one thing
and that one thing was the worst thing
that it could have possibly been at the
time for me yeah like everything was
gone and horrible so yeah that was the
feeling ahead of the time do you ever
gone to play suicide I thought about
thinking about it but I've just never
been that kind of person so I mean
basically as a way to escape from the
hardship something that I'm so
incredibly lucky I don't know why or how
I'm just gonna chalk it up to biology
I've always had really high mental
Baseline I've like depression and all of
that there have been a few short stints
I've dealt with it past 30 because I did
a lot of drugs but um other than that my
mental Baseline is just so high and even
in the carpet cleaning days
um like if you man the videos might
still be there I think on my old YouTube
channel channel where I'll be like
playing Starcraft when I first started
getting into streaming and I'll be
calling up customers like this is Steve
from Guaranteed Clean we had to move
your job back one hour is it okay if I
show up instead of 2 30 and then I hang
up it's like all right guys we got three
more games and it's like let's go like
stuff like that so my Baseline has
always been like really high for mental
function so even in the low Point
there's that you had strength is there
is there anything you can give by way of
advice from people that for home to wave
function collapses as it does for many
of us like holy [ __ ] the the world is
not full of opportunity and you're kind
of a failure like I've I've been there
yeah I don't know the it's rough because
like I usually ask for compassion from
people that I have it better off because
like once you're down there like the
only reason I say I got lucky but it
wasn't even really lucky like or it was
lucky but it was more lucky I wasn't
just lucky that I got into streaming it
was lucky that I was into computers at
an early age it was lucky that I played
video games at an early age it was lucky
that all the tech came up at exactly
that right point in time
um like I was a pretty smart guy but it
was definitely a preparation meets
opportunity and that opportunity was
like at the exact precise moment of my
life if anything had gone differently
then I would just be cleaning carpets
today so so in the many worlds
interpretation of quantum mechanics
this is like one out of like there's
many many Stevens that are just still
carpet cleaning and they're full of pain
and resentment yeah the the one piece of
advice that I give and I hate that I
have to push back against all these
crypto Bros and everybody online for
decently intelligent people that are
successful I've never heard anybody give
a contradiction of this maybe you will
you can tell me if you disagree
I always look at kids in high school and
I'm like just try a little bit harder
like 30 minutes a night if you don't
study just do 30 winches do a little bit
more
um it is you're laying the foundation
for the rest of your life and you can't
appreciate it in high school and college
but oh my god when you get out
everything in your life is so much
easier you have probably more
responsibility over the direction of
your life when you're like 13 14 years
old than you ever will once you're like
25 and older because this is like when
you're determining the foundations that
everything's gonna build up yeah 100 so
first of all it does seem that
the liberating aspect of being young is
like anything you learn
so working hard at learning something
will pay off in like non-linear ways
like you said with video games I feel
like so like people who are like I hate
school all right well fine but find
something
where you're challenging yourself you're
growing you're learning you're learning
a skill you're learning about a thing
of course you know you could push back
and say well there's some trajectories
that might not be productive like if you
spend the entirety of your teen years
playing I don't know League of Legends
game you have love and hate relationship
with no just a hate and hate
relationship okay well we'll talk about
I think you have a love-hate
relationship with hate in general we'll
just hit and love okay we'll try to
decomplexify that one uh I think in
general just invest in yourself fully
with passion it really does pay off but
that said also School
I feel like doesn't get enough credit
like High School in particular middle
school and high school because it's
general education
if
I I think if you if you're especially if
you're lucky to have good teachers but
honestly I haven't mostly the textbooks
themselves were good teachers it's a one
chance in life you have to really
explore a subject [ __ ] Grace like
getting good grades
is attention I would say with actual
learning that is true but just get a
biology textbook and to explore ideas in
biology and allowing yourself to be
um inspired by the beauty of it
yeah I don't know I I think that really
really pays off and you never get a
chance to do that again and maybe not
even textbooks like reading straight up
reading I think I think if you read this
is a one time in life you get a chance
to read
really read like read a book a day read
you you could really invest you can
really grow by reading I mean you know I
must all those guys talk about it like
it's very very rare that you meet like a
dumb person who reads a lot I don't know
if that's ever happened in my life yeah
dumb or not successful and this and the
cool thing is it seems like the reading
this like investment the reading you do
early on in high school pays off way
more than the reading you do later
uh so like the the really influential
reading is uh uh is it did during those
high school years because you're
basically learning from others the
mistakes they've made the solutions to
problems you're basically learning the
shortcuts to life like whatever the hell
you want to do music read from the best
people uh that the music theory like
learn music theory learn uh read
biographies about jazz musicians Blues
musicians see their like see all the
mistakes see what they did see the
shortcuts if you want to do podcasting
read about other podcasts if you want to
do stream and read about other streamers
physicists and so on and I feel like you
figure out all the mistakes and you get
the shortcut through life because most
people show up to college without having
done that and now you get a chance to
shortcut your way past them yeah 100 I'm
I'm gonna but nobody really teaches you
that they're like go to school
this from this time to that time that
you're shut up you this is just what you
do eat your broccoli I think it's like
there's two huge problems one is um Now
That I'm Older because you know you
don't know anything as a kid you can't
really criticize as adults as a kid
because you're a kid you're ageist if I
mean I am super ageless as soon as I get
older I get even more ages you there are
a lot of people who are arguing I was
like man dude you're really 22 Archer I
can tell every word you say so there's
six of like 22 year old notes but that's
okay I love that for you yeah no I could
just say because you mentioned this so
uh your wife is a fellow streamer Molina
you mentioned that this is a source of
fights uh for the two of you that and I
could just feel that there is truth to
what you're saying which is like all
right you're saying that because you're
22. just wait until you're 25 and you
won't be saying that anymore sure now
that is the most annoying thing for
people yeah you can't ever say that of
course because it's actually usually
true because because we do go through
phases in life and you can understand
that most things are phases so just in
general you can say just just wait
just wait you won't see this you won't
feel this way again I could say that to
you you could say that to yourself just
wait whatever you're feeling like just
wait in five ten years you'll be a
different person and you will laugh at
the things you take seriously now that
that they're causing you pain now all
that kind of stuff but people hate
hearing that anyway absolutely I think
the joke that I always say is that like
if I could literally step into a time
machine and I could come back out and
see myself as a 17 year old and I could
say hey I'm literally you from the
future you see the time machine and I
would look at me and I would see the
time machine and I would give myself the
best advice in the world to be the most
successful person I would ignore all of
it even knowing it came for myself like
this guy sold out this dude doesn't know
what the [ __ ] he's talking about like
nah I'll figure it out better like he
must have made some that's what I would
think is the 17th and I knew it was
myself in the future I would just 100
never believe it and knowing that is
very frustrating but I keep that in mind
when I deal with younger people that's
why like I never I always say on stream
when I'm talking to like there's been
stuff with like sneakos another girl an
ice cream called lab like when I see the
way the I see the mistakes they're
making oftentimes because I've made all
all of these mistakes sometimes in the
most public and horrible fashion ever
but I'm never like a mentor I'm not
gonna sit there and like tell you like
oh do this or that or that or that
because like I don't know if you're
gonna listen to me and I don't want to
condescend you and you know you figure
stuff out I'll be here if you want to
talk about it but yeah there was a one
of those stories there was a company
that didn't work with me because I I was
very adamant on defending like very
radical Notions about language and
racial slurs and everything when I was
like 22 or whatever and there was a
company and they said well we don't want
to work with this guy for an event and
after they had said that I read an
article on my website called the company
was gigabyte they make motherboards and
I said [ __ ] gigabyte in the ass that was
the title to my article and I was like
well if they don't want to work with me
I'm going to blow them up and never do
anything ever with them again and it was
just like like looking back at it now
obviously as a as an older person like
hey you need to pump the brakes and
chill you're destroying yourself but um
yeah as a young person it's like yeah
you're 22 of course you think that you
can say whatever and do whatever and as
long as you're good at what you're doing
You've Got the Whole World behind you
and yeah geez well let's go there you
have a history of using offensive
language like the r word
the n-word including the n-word with a
hard r
uh calling women [ __ ]
talking about rape in a nonchalant way
um
what part of that do you regret and what
part of that do you not language is very
complicated when it comes to stuff
relating to slurs there's been like a
whole trajectory of feelings on
everything related to language so my for
you personally and for the internet as a
whole yeah I don't care about the
internet almost for me personally in my
early 20s I'll say like 20 to 23 I think
probably when I first started streaming
my feeling is that any word is just a
word and if it hurts you that's your
fault take responsibility for yourself
um this probably came from my background
of being like a really independent
person so that's just kind of like the
mind that I had for everything and
there are basically they were like a
collection of experiences that I had
that As I Grew I started to realize like
okay well I feel differently about some
of these words depending on the context
and I can see how they can affect other
people depending on the context so as
I've kind of like grown I think I've
developed a more sophisticated
understanding of how different words are
used and how they affect people whether
they like it or not and more importantly
whether I like it or not and that words
can even if I don't want it to be they
can be a vehicle for emboldening certain
types of ideas that I don't want to
embolden and yeah that's kind of been
the whole like growth I've been lucky
that in the time that I came up on the
internet I was able to learn these
lessons because if I was trying to learn
those same lessons today I would have
been completely destroyed because I had
insane views on language like 10 years
ago we could talk about the past we
could talk about the president let's
talk about the past first so how do you
deal with the fact that there's videos
of you in the past saying the n-word
including the n-word with a hard R so
generally and once the contest can you
give me like yeah your memory what would
be the context usually when I lay out
this defense it's not because I wouldn't
have used the n-word generally whenever
I said the N word it was usually an
example of like this is something that
like a racist person would say I don't
think I've ever on the internet I don't
think I've ever called anybody like the
N word with a hard R
um not because I wouldn't have but just
because it wasn't in my vocabulary I
played uh RTS real-time strategy and we
use the the F slur for gay people that's
the one and I use that one a ton and
I've called people that a ton in the
past
um so I should actually just as a small
tangent yeah go for it and this is what
I'd like to explore with you
there's a ruthlessness to the language
in uh the gaming world yeah and there's
different communities they have
different flavors of language of hate
speech essentially and uh there's also a
humor to it
which
really bothers me in a dark way that I
haven't been able to really think
through
because humor seems to be a kind of
catalyst for hate it seems to normalize
hate like uh you say
basically it's like Lucy case has a lot
of edgy things but you take something
Lucy K says and do it in a non-funny way
and do it over and over and over and
keep uh increasing the hatefulness of it
the vitriol and somehow you find
yourself like Alice in Wonderland in a
world full of hate where there's no good
and evil it's all the same in fact the
good
is to be mocked and the evil is to be
celebrated for the humor of it basically
not taking the ideas of evil seriously
and I don't know what it it reveals
something about human nature that you
can let go the moral of relativism that
can happen when you do that kind of
stuff at the same time I'm a fan of dark
humor
when done well anyway for people who are
not familiar I just wanted to mention
that
some of the worst
hate speech that ends in LOL happens in
gaming communities yeah the um and
that's where you come from in certain
parts a lot of people don't remember
this or don't know this because they're
younger but way back in the day in the
uh late 90s early mid 2000s of the
internet the way that online kind of
like [ __ ] talk worked was you were just
trying to ramp up to the most insanely
edgy crazy stuff you could say to like
provoke a reaction have you ever heard
of something called The Aristocrats that
it's like a joke the joke oh yeah the
joke yeah there's a movie on it yeah
okay basically every single like should
talk back and forth in the internet was
like that like what is the most
increasingly depraved and back then you
didn't get banned for slurs or anything
on any of these chat rooms so it was
just like an insane world to walk into
and I was fully 100 a part of a product
of and a contributor to that world so
that probably still goes on on the
internet in some way and that probably
still goes on the internet you know
maybe a more pacified way only end
darker parts of the internet I'd say for
the most part most well compared to back
then compared to 20 years ago the
internet is way cleaned up now there are
still going to be boards you can go on
or parts of the internet where you see
that type of humor but not nowhere near
as mainstream like back then you could
open your mic on Xbox Live and hear some
insane stuff when that first started
nowhere near what you'd hear today
although there's still elements of
escalation that happen that just seems
to be part of human nature on the
internet the because we don't get the
feedback of actually hurting people
directly so the the trolling
like for the lulls you'll do like
whatever like you you will still
escalate within the bounds you're just
saying that there's more bounds now on
Reddit there's more bounds and so on so
the P you know there's moderators that
kind of yell at you that ban you and so
on if you cross those bounds but overall
that basic human instinct to escalate uh
especially under the veil of anonymity
is still there I don't know it's dark
it's dark yeah just there's a lot of
different ways to look at it and there's
different ways you can break that art
like for instance like you mentioned
dark humor and you say that like uh like
sometimes dark humor is funny and
sometimes it's not I think that it's
really important to dig into and figure
out like why certain things are funny
okay give you an example yeah go it's
from your subreddit oh boy no that made
me laugh and I felt wrong about it oh no
so this is uh
nine I already know what this is yeah
yeah
so this is a trolley problem to me it
connects because I I think about the TR
it keeps because I worked on autonomous
vehicles the trolley problem the
philosophical thought experiment kids
brought up a lot you know when AI is
part of making the decision do I kill
three people here or five people here
then AI makes that decision how do you
do that calculus and this this
particular there's a
there's a deep so satire that reveals
some kind of flaw in society I feel like
that's that's what dark humor does
successful dark humor does and that was
a flaw I feel like certain there's a
certain brand of dark humor and I think
the reason I think the reasons one is
why it's good or or why it is good humor
I think it's because I don't think it
necessarily reveals a flaw sometimes I
feel like it reveals like a kind of
virtue I think like if you look at this
particular thing can I explain what yeah
we're just listening uh the titles of
the Reddit post is you know what to pick
uh and it says uh five people are going
to die either way but if you flip the
lever the trolley will do a sick [ __ ]
Loop first
and also the top comment
is a question saying which I think is
also part of the document where that's
successful can I get the gender and
ethnic backgrounds of the groups first
and the top answer is both groups are
each comprised of five white orphaned
CIS male
heavy math users who are consistently in
and out of drug rehab all who identifies
right wing extremists humor is so it's
such a sophisticated thing that we
engage in humor is like really
complicated
um but I would argue that like hopefully
the humor here shows the virtue of like
this is obviously horrible but that's
kind of why it's funny it's funny
because it's such a horrible question to
ask like do we kill five people in a
boring way or in a really entertaining
way and it's like that's really that's
really and then when you ask even more
like what are the ethnic backgrounds
like that's even worse to say that you
know so I feel like that's like the type
of there's a way that you can engage
with dark humor where it's like oof like
it's funny because it's so wrong and so
typical we all know that it's wrong in
taboo and that's kind of where the
shared laugh comes from so for me the
question that is asking the the
diversity question is a sophisticated
way of revealing the absurdity of asking
about diversity when it's talking about
human life oh interesting because the
way that I took that was I think it
reveals the absurdity of how people will
weigh different ethnic backgrounds so
differently when it comes to value of
human life like I'm actually thinking of
that in terms of like a an immigration
related question where people are really
keen and quick to dehumanize like black
or brown people so like the question is
like well if five of them are brown and
five are white well I know which one I'm
gonna you know pull the lever for that's
how I read that but it's satirizing that
ass yeah exactly yes of course yeah but
that's what I mean that that's the flaw
to me at least it showed that Humanity
or social networks that are easy to be
outraged and love the outrage and the
chaos
that Twitter and social networks will
pull that lever like they would they
would always try to maximize the fun and
there's like there's a sick aspect to
all the atrocities all the tragedies
that happen in the world that we kind of
always lean towards the
um the outrageous narrative weaved
around it the
yeah the the one that leads to sort of
the most clicks to the most uh attention
to the most outraged to all the all that
kind of so that that's almost like a
satire of society when they are faced
with tragedy
they will maximize trying to think of a
word that's not fun but entertainment
maximize the entertainment yeah this is
a big criticism I give especially to
conservative crowds
um you know left lane appeal everybody
doesn't I don't like when people blame
the media for the state of the media
today I very much believe that
everything in society is a feedback loop
and that if you're really unhappy with
the state of the media I think that the
media is a good reflection for what
people want to see because there is a
room right now in the United States
where somebody could start a company
where all they do is completely factual
reporting they don't have a political
slant and they're not giving you these
like sensationalist narratives or
stories and that Media Company would
fail in two weeks because people don't
want to see that generally people really
want to see the like show me the guy
that really believes in what I say that
calls the other guy an idiot the guys
that are screaming on TV or on the radio
like this is what I really want
um and people will engage in that and
that feedback loop will continue for
generations and then all of a sudden
people like why is the media so biased
why is the media driving so many
narratives I was like what do you mean
this is exactly what you want to see
and that's that's frustrating for me
that's one of my big kind of when I
defend establishments or when I talk
about like the interplay between Citizen
and
and all these institutions we have that
the institutions are very much a
reflection of the population at least in
Democratic societies and I think that
people very much try to elude the
personal responsibility or the country's
responsibility to why some of them look
the way that they do
but that takes us back to the n-word
with a hard R sure why
for the particular examples that I was
giving for the particular conversations
that I was having if you're going to
have challenging conversations around
certain words I think you should
probably be able to say them otherwise
it feels really ridiculous to me that's
why you still believe that
um for com yes and not like calling
people those words but having
conversations about those words I would
say that I still believe I am but don't
you think as you said that using those
words
actually gives motivation and strength
to people who have hate in their hearts
I think depending on the context of
what's going on
um I think that that's going to be a big
driver in terms of how people are going
to perceive or take it so in a
conversation about the n-word I don't
think I would normally say the n-word we
just talk about the word much the same
way that like in um like say like in a
movie like in Django the people use the
N word should that be censored in that
movie or in the context of that movie is
it being employed in a way where these
aren't good people you're not supposed
to like them and that's what the
audience walks away with
yeah but that context is different than
conversation it feels like in
conversation
you using that word normalizes it and
that normalizing that word is going to
make it easier for people who use that
word in a hateful way to use it same
with the f word this the F slur
if you use that
casually and normalize it
in a way that's not hateful you use in a
way that's not hateful but you the side
effect is that it normalizes it then
people who do use it in a hateful way
will be more likely to use it therefore
mathematically looking at the equation
of the number of times the n-word or the
f word is used throughout the world it
increases the number of times it's used
in a hateful way yeah I think the human
and you're part of that problem Stephen
I don't I don't agree I understand I
understand the thought process
um but I don't know if using certain
words within different contexts is going
to necessarily normalize like the
hateful use of that word
um that is an argument that I've heard
people use somebody will say like okay
well hold on that should never be used
ever because by virtue of you
normalizing it even in an inoffensive
environment you increase the proclivity
for people to use it in a potentially
more offensive environment and my
argument is always like no I don't think
that crossover exists but if you did
want to take that argument and maybe you
do feel this way I think that you get
really problematic when you run into
communities that do use certain words
that people would say well they should
be allowed to do it so for instance if
you think that any utterance of the
n-word at all is highly problematic it
might increase hatred then like the
entire rap industry has to dramatically
change the way that they engage with the
n-word and obviously a lot of people
that criticize people's use of the
n-word aren't going to turn to rappers
and say well you guys can't say it
either no it's who I mean it's who uses
the n-word that's what it's not so it's
not just the word it's the
the it it is context dependent uh but I
would say that you as a white person
having conversations
the context there is the kind that would
lead to an increase in hate do you think
the N word should be censored in the
dictionary no and I believe there's a
Wikipedia page on it and it's not
censored uh yeah I think it should be in
the dictionary I think the context of
casual conversation
like like I said I just believe that on
the internet
having humor having fun conversations as
you have on your streams
that leads to the normalization of the
word without any educational value
I think I would I think I would agree
with that no sorry so there's a
difference between absolar and n-word
and both I think
should not be used in a fun way but the
f word was used in the fun way for the
longest time for sure uh and I I'll tell
you something that bothers me about your
streams not your your streams and
basically every other stream is the the
Casual use of the r word oh the ableism
yeah I don't know if it's about the able
I don't even know
listen it's complicated I'm not like
virtue signaling here no it's just
ableism isn't a virtue signal I mean
like it's a legitimate yeah like I get
emails from fans that say like hey like
I deal with this particular issue every
time you use this word kind of feels
like you're attacking me like just like
so it's not it's a valid concept yeah
it's just something Cuts wrong for me
like for example I'm not bothered by
I am bothered by the excessive use of
the word [ __ ] okay but not
in the same way the moderate use of the
word [ __ ] what is it I'm curious and
when somebody calls somebody an r word
what is it that what is the feeling that
you get that makes you feel bad about it
it signals to me that you don't
give a damn about
people who are struggling
in ways that you are not struggling like
that that signals to me like um about
the experience of others
do you think that there are other other
words also that could convey like a
similar feeling to your wife because it
feels like you've drawn a pretty special
circle around because like I imagine oh
this guy's you're an uneducated dumb
[ __ ] you're a networker like
I think that's what the the whole point
with the culture so I'm trying to feel
my feeling is a kind of you know I'm a
human being that exists in the social
context that we're all evolving that
language together and just feels wrong
like you know the word [ __ ] for example
it really bought like a friend on your
streams and in general calling a woman a
stupid [ __ ] really bothers me but it's
not just the word [ __ ] it's context
like for example me personally I'm
speaking to me personally like badass
[ __ ]
is is different than stupid [ __ ] way
bad [ __ ] or something is different than
yeah of course way different sure I
think it speaks to a bigger sense of
Civility and respect for human beings
that are not like you
that's what that's that's the feeling
that I'm bothering so I guess what I'm
trying to say here is um
just because people speak in this kind
of way
in the gaming world and streams doesn't
mean that you like a lot of people look
up to you it doesn't mean young people
especially doesn't mean that you don't
have the responsibility to sort of stand
alone from the crowd because you're
somebody that values the power of
affected discourse
and
to be effective discourse there's some
level of Civility so you can be the sort
of the beacon of Civility in that world
versus giving in to the uh the
derogatory words because like yeah you
have to
you have to lift people out of that
world out of the muck of
um what I would say is like drama and
ineffective discourses like I think
that's one of your missions right is
like to inspire the world through
conversation through debate through
effective discourse yeah so I guess I'm
just calling you out that I I think
using our word for me personally as a
fan that that believes in your mission
it just makes you look
ineffective and bad and uninspiring to
young people that look up to you because
those young people are going to use
those words that you're using and
they'll do it much less effectively sure
this the problem yeah I guess the
challenge is always just like finding
the line like yeah my my vocabulary
shifted dramatically from even even from
like two or three years ago I think my
vocabulary shifted quite a bit as we've
like we've kind of gotten rid of some
words and some things are kind of coming
out
um the r word is one that has kind of
gone out and come back and gone out and
come back that one we've definitely gone
back and forth on I know there are
different thoughts about it in different
communities on the internet this is
interesting I'm just telling you yeah
for me it cuts
and I'm not a social justice Warrior
type it costs pretty hard
like what you're saying is I'm going to
lose a subscriber if I'm no it's not no
I'm just kidding I know I just I
actually have had to empathize harder
because I'm like maybe this is not a
very good person that's what I feel like
if you're so carelessly using that word
then maybe you're not actually thinking
deeply about
the suffering in the world like to be a
student of human nature you really have
to think about other humans and other
experiences that are unlike your own
yeah of course and so that's the sense I
get but at the same time you're you're
also like the grandpa I mean ages who's
trying to be cool with the young kids a
lot a lot of the reason young kids look
up to you is like you also know the
language of the internet yeah but I mean
it doesn't that's not an excuse to use
words we think shouldn't be used I guess
the question that I that I would have
because it's always a struggle and to
some extent it's kind of happened is
let's say that like three years ago I
would have said I'm no longer saying the
artwork that's just I'm just gonna get
rid of that in my vocabulary like is
there a chance that today we would be
having a conversation about like why do
you call people dumb [ __ ] like is that
really appropriate like does this attack
at the core of like somebody's like
level of intelligence education
opportunities in life like is that where
they you know you don't think so I think
that's a as the kids say cope do you
really think so I think because because
the words have been moved in a way where
it's like this was okay now it's not
this is know so you're standing your
ground by using listen you could you you
could you could
but I think it's better to use those
words if you want to defend the ground
word stand on to use them rarely and
deliberately versus how you currently
use them which is to express and emotion
like you I'm going to be honest you use
our word not when you're at your best
true and so that's not that's generally
that could be true for a lot of swearing
too though but yeah I know what you mean
no but like you know that our word is
offensive you know and there's a part of
it is like the the you tell yourself
that like you're still kind of fighting
political correctness by using it a
little bit when you say it no I don't
think so I think I'm trying to think in
terms of like where is The Virtue where
like there's a whole bunch of arguments
for why some words are okay some words
aren't okay or whatever and I try to
like think more along those lines rather
than but um like there's gonna be like a
lot of phrases where like if the r word
has come out the conversation is over
like I know that like things my brain is
shut down the person I'm talking to is
but there's like there's a lot of words
also in terms of like it like if you
ever hear me say like [ __ ] [ __ ] in a
debate it's like it's done like this
conversation is over there's no way that
anything productive is happening past
that point I think [ __ ] [ __ ] is not
I think it's ineffective it's not civil
but it's not
it doesn't bother me in the way
is is basically when you speak in a way
that I know there's a group that's going
to be heard by that
not only do I think about the hurt that
group experiences I think of you as a
lesser intellectual like as a lesser
person who's thinking about the world
what bothers me the most is just what
kind of um mindset that inspires and
young young people or especially when
you're in a public figure and a lot of
people look up to you so I definitely
don't think sort of this idea
the r word is not the battleground of
expanding the Overton window of
discourse okay like I I don't think
it'll lead to dumb [ __ ]
being canceled uh two years later unless
that word is hurting people's experience
which I don't foresee that happening I
think legitimately
our word and F slur and calling women
[ __ ]
it's context matters here too like of
course but just the way I've heard you
use it it is not is from emotion and
it's from frustration and It ultimately
is rooted in disrespect I don't I think
it's ineffective and of course like who
gets to say I don't know but I'm saying
somebody who would my like I admire
effective conversations and I admire
great humor dark humor wit
to me oftentimes the use of the r word
in the way you've used in the way I see
the community use it is none of those
things it contributes not at all to the
humor and so on now I could see it might
contribute to the to the camaraderie of
that particular group especially when
they normalize the use of that word
you kind of take some of the edge off
but you forget that there's a a large
number of other people that don't have
the chemistry that don't hear the music
of the friendship that you have the
relationship you have instead they hear
the normalization of a hateful word and
It ultimately has an impact that's
hateful and then people like me who show
up you know I haven't watched much of
your stuff it turns me off from like uh
a couple of times your content came came
before me like and I listened to it a
little bit it turned me off completely I
didn't understand
how good your heart is I didn't
understand how your mission of actually
uh direct do you radicalized people help
people like you're uh and increase the
level of good faith discourse in the
world I didn't understand any of that
because like what I was hearing is
pretty rough the the r award type of
stuff and I just feel like the benefit
cost analysis is heavy on the cost
gotcha that's so I just have to sort of
call this out okay I think it and I
straight up think it's wrong
but that's my own that's why do you
think it's wrong
because it's hurting people without any
benefit to you whatsoever when you say
hurting people do you mean the person
I'm using it at or do you think there's
like things like the third group the
third third group it's good feedback
right I always consider everything
especially I respect you a lot you're a
really smart guy
um something that I always kind of like
foreign fight over in terms of like
language or like who to attack or what
to attack or what to do is that um it's
very hard to draw like what boxes
um are okay to install people on versus
one aren't so for instance if I call
somebody like a Nazi with a lot of
vitriol I am okay with every single Nazi
being negatively affected by that
because
that category intrinsically calls upon
at some level of more condemnation for
me right whereas like if I'm out there I
try not to do like image related jokes
right I don't want to call you like oh
you're a fat [ __ ] loser because
there's a lot of people that are fat
that are overweight where I don't want
them to feel bad I don't want them I'm
not trying to call you out or like
insult you so there's like a lot of um
you say cost benefit I like like a lot
of collateral damage from a world like
that where there's no purpose in doing
that
um so certain words are easy to get rid
of they're off the table right epsler
and we're like like these are not words
you call people because you're there's
so much collateral it's not worth it
we've got some words where it's like if
you have some form of like mental thing
it is a bad thing you're not a bad
person somebody just using that word
could feel like a collateral damage to
those people and then there's other
categories of words so like if I say
that like um this person is like they're
it's a stupid [ __ ] Republican right
there's probably some Republicans that
aren't dumb that I don't want to feel
called out by that like are those types
of phrases that you think should be
completely removed as well or I'm kind
of curious so this completely removed
just so we're clear yeah I'm not
referring to censorship oh no I'm not
even talking about I'm just just a
person like emotionally like removed is
the wrong word though like I care about
like I'm not trying to listen to people
on the internet saying like you
shouldn't say that word that's not good
I mean you
I'm trying to look to your mind and
heart okay we're talking today is you're
betraying your gift you're better than
this you think it's indicative of like a
more flippant thought process where it's
like the only way you can say that word
is if you're ignoring the hurt and
suffering of those people and if you're
somebody that says even those people
you're ignoring the the state of
language because I think you're getting
to the point because it's not about a
single word it's about like uh it's
music and I just feel like there is uh
it's a strong note that ruins the melody
gotcha and I don't think I can say you
know you shouldn't use the r word or
whatever I'm just speaking to I'm just
listening to music and reviewing the the
final result it's not necessarily
because maybe one use of the word the r
word
uh strategically or part of an actual
like or when you've built up a
camaraderie that's sandwiched in in like
some love but then you try to reveal
there like because you're talking about
a lot of there's a bunch of drama you
have a but you have friends with whom
you're worrying and stuff and they're
all a little bit beautifully insane and
you've said that you are becoming more
and more insane it's beautiful to watch
it's The Human Condition laid before us
wonderful and some of that is swearing
and so on so it's a tricky thing but
um the whole skill of
discourse just like it is with dark
humor is walking that line I just feel
like it's uh
overuse of the r word and I don't want
to die in that ground because I don't
think it's that that represents like
there's certain things like that
it feels like it ruins the music and I
don't you know it's just saying like a
dumb Republican or a dumb Democrat I
don't
yeah that ruins it too a little bit
depends on how you use it uh you can be
lazy with that yeah you know like even
overuse of the word I think Bots is
what's used for people who don't think
or something I don't actually know the
definition I'm offended on the on behalf
of robots
and that might be a compliment soon
exactly what I guess bot means you don't
think yeah you're like an NPC you're
just kind of interesting again I'm
offended on behalf of NPCs I I count
myself as one but there's a sense if you
say Bots too much
that you're just dismissing people like
everything I say is right and anyone
that disagrees with me is a bot that
that's lazy too sometimes you're funny
sometimes it's effective uh basically
saying a lot of people in the mainstream
Media or something like that are Bots
okay that's a little bit of that is
effective but too much it becomes
ineffective and I'm trying to speak to
that yeah and I'm just the reason we're
highlighting clear examples like the
n-word
uh Joe Rogan had to contend with that
all right yeah
I think it's ineffective it makes you
less effective at this course I but like
like you've talked about many times
language is a tricky one it's always
hard because you talk about like
constructing a Melody there's not one
Melody that sounds good to everyone
but there are probably certain notes
that like if you got rid of them
everybody's still going to like it about
as much and you don't really lose
anything there's a whole other part of
an audience that might be more willing
to listen yeah of course and it's not
about losing the magic of that Melody
like you don't want to be vanilla
I just feel like there's stuff that
doesn't need to be there yeah for sure
it's fat but then again you're the other
thing that people should understand
that might be listening to this you're
streaming many hours a day
for many years I don't know it's 11 or
12 I think yeah I started in 2010. and
so one of the things that people can do
is just clip out anything you're going
through the full Human Experience of
emotion anger fear frustration all of it
so of course there's going to be moments
when you're not the best version of
yourself
anything else to say about the language
it's complicated I'm still always trying
to figure it out you know there are
opinions that I have that have changed
throughout the years it's possible that
the r word has always been the next one
on the chopping block that we're all
kind of looking at but people always
worried about that treadmill but it's
possible in a year or two I'll have a
different view on it or I'll have
changed away some of the words I use and
that um yeah it's definitely like a it's
always like a work in progress there's
always like different communities that
feel different ways about different
words yeah
yeah but you acknowledge that there's
people out there that are never going to
talk to you
they're never gonna think of you as a
good man because you use the on N word
with the hard R publicly in the past I
mean yeah those people exist but I mean
there are some people that are beyond my
reach which I'm okay with like there's
gonna be some people because of things
that have been involved or even ideas
that I have now that might make them
beyond my reach
um something you said earlier is very
true I think the goal is to like
identify what are the elements that you
can cut out that aren't integral to your
message but it could be alienating to
more people and those are probably the
things that you identify but I think
that you can get lost in yourself or
lost on the Internet or lost in a you
know at the outside of yourself if
you're trying to appeal to every single
person it's just never going to be the
case and for I actually I like that I've
had the journey that I've had on the
internet that you can find me saying and
defending a lot of insane stuff 10 years
ago because I think it shows like a
level of progress and I think I do get a
lot of respect and buying to certain
communities where it's like I'm not just
some random dude telling you that like
oh you should shouldn't say you know the
f word or the N word like I'm a guy
that's been there that's done it that's
defended it and you can see my whole
past my whole history is laid bare for
you to watch every of you know thousands
of hours of it um but I can show that
like there's growth and evolution and
change that can happen in a person so
yeah and you're honest about that growth
It's Tricky thing because people just
call bring up stuff from your past for
sure I I hope we figure out as a
civilization a mechanism
to Clearly say this was this was me two
years ago this was me five years ago
this I'm a different person and like
um because Twitter doesn't care about
that these social mechanisms that bring
stuff up doesn't care about that it's
like one stupid thing you say
it becomes like a Scarlet Letter and I
don't know how to fight that It's tricky
to fight that have you ever seen Men In
Black yes when K and J are on the bench
and he says uh person is smart but
people are stupid dumb finicky animals
or whatever there's something that
changes for human dynamics when there is
a group of people that make it so hard
to control like I think one-on-one
anybody can sit across on somebody and
admit to some horrible stuff I used to
be uh you know I abused my husband when
I was you know 20 and I'm 35 and I see
it's wrong or I did this I was addicted
to whatever and you know I made these
mistakes one-on-one it's always easy but
in um in group environments that in
group out group tribalistic thing of
like identifying one thing and then
coming to destroy a person's life is
like it's such a huge like impulse we
have and I think probably when we were
like hunter-gatherers in the force
probably good because you really want to
push weird people out or anything like
that but now on the internet when we can
hunt for any dissenting opinion and just
with ruthless Precision destroy
somebody's life over it it's pretty
scary dynamic I think one of the
mechanisms that could fix it is make it
super easy for each individual person to
analyze all the stupid [ __ ] they
themselves have said in the past like a
full recording
because I think people are just honestly
paint a very Rosy picture to their own
brain of of who they have been in the
past yeah of course if we can have
empathy for the fact that we've said
stupid [ __ ] or we're drunk the the
ridiculous things you say the offensive
things you might have said offensive
things you might have done I just feel
like that would give us the ammunition
to have empathy for others that are like
okay yeah this guy five years ago said
this maybe that doesn't represent them
who doesn't represent who they are any
more than stuff I said five years ago
represents who I am today yeah I feel
like technology can actually enable that
maybe although you're talking about more
more recording and more stuff which
people are already wary of but um it's a
double-edged sword I think there's there
is going to be more and more recording
we have to figure out how to do that in
a way that respects people privacy and
gives them ownership of their data and
so on I've looked at the search history
I've done on Google which for most
people is available like your Google
search history and it's fascinating to
watch the evolution of a human being
like it doesn't seem like the same
person it's like a different person for
sure it's weird it's also hard too with
the internet today I'm gonna be ageist
again but like now all of the people are
thrown together you know whereas like
like I don't want a 27 year old judging
they're usually like a 15 or 16 year
world like obviously he's in high school
like there is that story that came out
of the um there was a kid that saved the
recording of I think it was like some
white girl I think that she like got her
driver's license and she's like I can
drive now and words with the a or
whatever his dumb she shouldn't have
said it but I think she was like 15 or
16 when she Tick Tock this or whatever
and he held all of that recording until
she applied and got accepted to college
three years later and then he released
it to get her kicked out of college and
I'm like damn
everything that I had ever said as like
a 15 16 year old was like immortalized
on the internet my my life wouldn't have
even begun
um because those are insanely high
standards to hold people to
um not that like obviously you shouldn't
be saying those uh you shouldn't be
saying certain words or whatever but you
have to be able to make mistakes in
adolescence like everybody does we all
did everybody did it growing up you know
why do you think there is so much
misogyny in the streaming community
and how can you fight it because you've
you've shown
a lot of interest in fighting it trying
to decrease or eliminate misogyny from
your community
I think it's really difficult I think
that eliminating racism is easier than
eliminating misogyny because on the
internet you mean on anywhere because I
think fundamentally I don't think
there's that much difference between
like white people and black people and
brown people and Asian people or
whatever you know we have different
cultures and stuff but at the end of the
day we're all people
but I think there are differences
between men and women like throughout
all of you like all of history and time
and then even today in every culture and
when when real differences do exist it's
harder to account for them in a way that
can we have conversations with each
other without it becoming very gendered
in a negative way right negative way of
generating something like a misogynistic
way of doing it of course
it's unclear to me that it's so
difficult to um
to avoid the negative gendering versus
the positive because there's a lot of
positive to the the tension the dance
between the different genders and so on
maybe in this particular moment in
history it's not but it's not trivial to
me that racism is easier to eliminate
it's an interesting hypothesis just
because there's more biological
difference between men and women that
means it's harder to eliminate but I
don't know if there's a Troy I hear this
a lot I feel like I've read the story
but I need to get a better Source if I
repeat it everywhere but I've heard that
like in the US military for instance
they've gotten exceedingly well they do
an exceedingly good job at getting
different people of different races to
integrate and it's like not a huge
problem once you're through basic
training all the training everything
but for a different sex as it still
represents a significant problem that
the military hasn't figured out and I
actually looked like what's the military
doing because if you know if something
was solvable like can we sleep for four
hours a night be healthy if we could I
bet the military would know you know so
I kind of look sometimes for them to see
their integration but um it might be
that there are other issues there that
make it yeah it feels like the military
is a very particular country for sure
yeah it could be the actual task at hand
might uh bias the difficulty of the
process potentially yeah there's been a
lot of interesting
um talk about like women integrating
into male groups and how do you do this
in a way where everybody is happy with
the outcome and there's not like issues
um I think Jordan Peterson spoke about
this a little bit and then workplace
culture speaks about this a bit would
you happen to remember I want to say it
was like five or ten years ago there was
a big Tech conference and there were two
guys behind a woman and they made a joke
about like a USB dongle like dongle was
a dick and this woman turned around she
tweeted pictures of them spoke about
like misogyny and then every that up
into a huge ordeal that like um yeah
there was this there's this interesting
phenomenon that
and a
less misogynistic and more inclusive
workplace environment
some women might end up feeling worse
because in a more misogynistic
environment you're thinking like okay
that's a woman she doesn't get our humor
I'm going to treat her in a very
indifferent you know very dispassionate
cold way and whatever and then I'm gonna
have my my boys over here
um and then you've got like these
environments where they're a little bit
more warmer and it's like oh cool we're
going to bring this woman into our
environment and we're going to make all
the same types of like crash jokes we
did before and it's actually worse now
another woman feels even more otherwise
because like oh my God why do you talk
like this I think that internet
communities especially online ones that
do like political debate and video games
are very much like big boys clubs so
it's not enough to just say you can't be
misogynistic to get rid of misogyny
there's always going to be an othering
effect on women there's a lot of like
behaviors that are unintuitive that you
have to account for and you've got to
try to like push that back and that's
just a very very challenging thing to do
um so like I I like to deal with
concrete examples more so here's a
concrete example and this is like a
recent initiative in my community
because I'm trying to like be because
misogyny hasn't been fixed anywhere on
the internet and I'm curious well there
are ways that I can push my community to
do this
um I don't think you should almost ever
make a comment on a woman's appearance
ever if they're appearing in like some
political or professional manner even if
it's a positive comment I think it's
equally bad to a negative comment it's
just never good to do and that's kind of
an unintuitive thing because it's like
well a woman appears wow she's really
cute it seems like a nice comment you're
being nice you know she looks cute
whatever but it's like it's not at all
the point of why she's there and just by
saying that you're kind of like
authorizing her as like a person to like
think she looks good rather than
listening to anything she has to say you
know well there's a lot of stuff that
you're saying and
that is a part of massaging it's almost
like obvious like any woman will tell
you that woman well yeah but they're not
in these spaces and a lot of the guys
don't know I think what that requires
is just empathy
you don't need you don't need you need
to consider the female experience
that's it like you have to either read
about or talk with women you learn like
the low-hanging food is very easy to
learn it feels like just the level of
social skill
oftentimes in Internet communities is
quite low I disagree I don't like to say
here's the problem with empathy is it's
very hard to have empathy for
experiences that are so outside of your
own it well maybe some people there
might be some people that can do it I
can't there's a lot of stuff that I had
to learn women are half the population
but they're women
they're totally different
they're totally different okay so here
here's what we talk about yeah yeah so
this is not totally totally so here's an
example Okay so
especially for me my archetype makes up
a lot of the internet white man
um there's never been a point the name
of a beautiful woman who might be a
dancer what's the backstory from New
Orleans or from I haven't thought that
through yet all right um yeah it's
ambiguous okay like an open world open
world I want you to project whatever
wherever you want Destiny the dancer to
be from that's in your mind okay all
right well I'll save that for later
tonight yeah okay
as a white guy there I don't know if
there's ever been a spot that I've been
in where I've made been made to feel
like I don't belong there just by virtue
of who I am I don't I actually don't I
it's impossible for me to empathize that
because I don't even have that
experience if you go back eight nine
years one of the big issues that came up
was harassment and gaming against women
and I was one of the big Debaters
against that saying that like sure women
might get harassment but everybody gets
harassment if you're a woman and you're
in gaming and you get harassed
congratulations you're being treated
like a man what you're actually asking
for is for us to actually treat you
differently you don't want to be
insulted you don't want to be treated
like a man and that's actually a
misogyny is women making that argument
you still stand by that is that a
problem if I do
no I'm just kidding well okay hold on a
little it's a little while I disagree
with it sure okay that's good you should
a little while later
um I had a friend uh Jessica super cool
girl we go to play games she was between
jobs and she's like I've got like two
months and we're gonna grind CS go and
I'm like okay this is awesome let's do
it uh CS go um Counter-Strike Global
Offensive shooter game FPS microphones
first day we start playing okay hop into
our first game obviously she talks
everybody's making is that a 12 year old
boy why aren't you making sandwiches
blah blah blah yeah okay whatever player
first game play our second game same
jokes third game fourth game by like the
fourth or fifth game I was actually
starting to feel triggered like every
time the game started I was like can you
just like talk so we can get over like
the stupid [ __ ] jokes it's so [ __ ]
stupid and you hear the same [ __ ]
joke every single time and it took one
day of that experience for me to realize
it's not about being insulted it's like
this othering feeling that you don't
belong and I've never felt that because
I'm a white guy like it's just not to be
like virtually similar so but like
there's just there's no places where
it's like you're white you don't belong
here you're guy you don't belong here
like I've never felt that not inclusion
and playing with her there's a different
feeling when it's the same types of
jokes coming from a group of people to
make you feel like you don't belong
there where I was like damn this
actually feels really bad and it feels
bad in a different way where it's like
if you call me
um like NF slur or any other type of
swear word or insult like yeah you can
call me that but at the end of the day
like we're all kind of the same we're
all white dudes and we call each other
names but like this is a woman and this
is not her place and she doesn't belong
here
kind of the analogy that I would make um
because I after getting these
experiences I've learned this afterwards
if I tell you that there's another guy
in a room and you need to think of the
worst insults ever for that person
without ever knowing anything about them
or meeting them if I tell you that it's
like a white straight guy and you have
to write insults you're [ __ ] maybe you
can do like school shooter there's not
really much you can say at the end of
the day but if I tell you it's a woman
we could there are so many different
jokes you can write if it's a black
person so many different racist things
we can say are you sure I can come up
with a lot of stuff for a white guy in
terms of stuff that is just intrinsic to
him being a white guy yeah like there's
really wait a minute what are you
talking about there's a lot the internet
has sharpened that sword in terms of
like jokes that are targeted at his sex
and cells virgin
weak some of the anselves Virgin maybe
yeah that's getting there sure that's
for sure
um that's recent though sorry I'm older
on the internet we didn't have those
words way back then when I was making
these analogies that installing version
my day we didn't have generation there
were no installs back then none of us
had sex we just accepted we were all
computer Gamers nobody had sex to play
video games back then okay people don't
remember that there wasn't the Big Bang
Theory you were just a loser that was
stuck I didn't even know sex exists we
had to download sexual pictures and they
took two minutes and you didn't even
know if you were gonna get the right
thing by the time it finished loading
but but what I'm saying is they're like
okay so you think you agree that like if
somebody gives you like a race like a
black person who's a woman we can write
like very cutting scathing like insults
for that person that are very
authorizing oh words that would really
hurt yeah that are very cutting to the
person but like for a White Guy
um it's kind of hard because it's like
that's like the default there's not as
much other rising of those people yeah
so that's kind of the insults you have
from white guy the white guy the insults
are much harsher so when you start to
apply the same kind of harshness to
other groups you can make them feel like
they really don't belong and that other
Rising effect is something that's very
hard for me I can't really empathize
like I've never felt it so I have to
intellectualize it and then sympathize
with it it's like a whole process I have
to go through and then I try to walk
other people through that because if
you're a white guy on the internet which
is a lot of the internet you really
don't know what that feels like you've
never felt like that before yes so
you're now in a leadership position uh
Grandpa Destiny so that's a lot of
people look up to you for that for that
sort of Pathway to empathy yeah
not to uh otherwise I mean you have felt
other eyes in you you mentioned High
School people like not being
yeah but those were always for things
that like it's different to insult
somebody for a non-immutable
characteristic like okay you think
poorly about me because I'm like not
enough money or I don't have money but I
could get more money and I could change
that but it's different for somebody to
really attack you for like your gender
or attack you for like your race a lot
of the attacks that hit the hardest is
not about gender
it's
it's I do think that they're like the
way women are attacked on the internet
it's the same kind of attacks you would
do towards other guys but you go harsher
I feel like they're fundamentally
different I feel like when we're
attacking guys I'm not usually attacking
you on like
the virtue of you being a guy but like
if it's a woman and she's typing
something like oh did your boyfriend
type that for you or like what are you
even doing here like don't you shouldn't
you be trying to find a husband or like
oh you're like a stupid kind of like
ghost died and only fans or no but the
stupidity the intelligence aspect is
what's attacked yeah but it's so much
different like you can call a guy stupid
but that's because he's a guy that's
being stupid but when you call a woman
stupid she's stupid because she's a
woman yeah but I honestly think that
women are called stupid more than men on
the internet but I've got nothing to do
like the attack is not gendered it's the
gender inspires an increased level of
attack I feel like it is gendered I wish
we had data on this have you ever heard
of the xkcd Comics yes it's a really
good comic wear and I this is something
that I've dealt with a lot in my
community okay there's a guy at a board
and he [ __ ] up a math equation and it's
like wow you suck at math and then the
next panel is there's a girl that does
it and she [ __ ] it up and it's like wow
women suck at math and there's like that
feeling that happens where when I bring
on
um I want usernames but they're like
YouTube people that I've run on that
have crazy opinions and when they're men
that person is crazy oh my God he said
the crazy stuff he's so dumb he's so
crazy so stupid but when it's a woman
it's like oh my God why do you always
bring dumb women here why do so many
women on the internet have crazy
opinions there's a different like
minority character that has to like
stand it and like represent like their
whole group where like white men don't
typically have to speaking of groups
versus individuals yes but then what I
feel happens is then another person from
that group comes another woman comes and
people before she says anything
will already feel like they're ready
with that attack for sure but they're
ready for the attack she's a woman
they're gonna call her she's stupid
because she's not because she said
something about just because she's a
woman
so like uh the group
in their brain accumulates all the
negative characteristics of the
individuals they've met not the positive
the negative and it becomes like this
ball of stickiness and then that becomes
the bias for their judgment of a new
person that comes with white men there's
more of a blank slate in terms of bias
of how they analyze the person with any
any of the minority group they're
basically make a judgment
based on the negative characteristics of
the individuals they met in the past I
just that leads to a system where you're
just harsher towards minority groups and
towards women how do you solve that the
first the most important thing for any
problem ever is step one is to be aware
of it if you're not aware of it then
you're hopelessly lost at sea but yeah
the first thing I like to say is just
like be aware of it like I've had
there's a girl that I've had on recently
and she says a lot of in my opinion kind
of crazy things but people will use her
as like this is why women shouldn't be
here this is like she's crazy and she's
a woman and blah blah blah but I can
bring on a guy who's similarly dumb
things and he's evaluated on his own
merits because it's a guy you know
there's never ever ever been a case
where I brought a stupid guy on stream
and everybody's like this guy makes me
hate men this guy makes me hate white
people that has never happened but then
there's like other women that come on
and it's like now I know why installs
exist or I totally understand where red
pill ideology comes from you know and
even if the statements are kind of true
when you're making these observations
over and over and over and over again it
it damages your ability to individually
perceive somebody and then two people
that make the same statements one can be
perceived more harshly just because of
that like group bias you've got built up
I think there's something about
streaming that just brings that out of
people like because you have to talk for
like seven hours so you're like all
right well whatever psychological issues
and complexities I I have I'm going to
explore that it's magnified magnified
and then we'll and then it's uh as you
talked about the memetic uh uh Theory so
gerardian like whatever
the things that are very similar and
you're going to magnify the conflicts
that you have and you're going to
explore the all the different
perspectives on those different
conflicts and I mean I don't I don't
know if it's just anecdotal but it's
nice to have women on stream and I think
the dynamic uh that you guys have is is
is wonderful is it's really interesting
so yeah it's just a female voice in
general I love having women on the
podcast the female voice I feel like is
under heard on the internet for sure and
I would love the internet to be a place
where women feel safe to speak
all right given that you're like we
talked about a progressive with
non-standard Progressive views so you're
very pro-free speech pro-capitalism
so given that it's very interesting that
you're also pro-establishment and pro
institutions uh so right now if you look
at the world there's a significant
distrust of Institutions uh at least in
sort of public intellectual discourse uh
what is the nature of your support for
government and institutions can you make
the case for and against them
broadly speaking
there is a synergistic effect when two
humans come together if I can speak very
broadly in terms of we'll say utility
okay my happiness with one person might
be ten the happiness of the person might
be ten but when they come together it's
like 50 between the two of them there's
like the synergistic effect when humans
work together that the sum is greater
than all the individual parts or
whatever there's like an emergent thing
that happens there there's a capacity
there's a possibility of that yeah a
possibility sure things could go really
wrong there could be a cannibalistic
tribe that all eats each other sure but
for the purpose of this there's other
failure modes but yes okay sure yeah
further for the but well I think broadly
speaking you're are you going to be the
well actually guy okay if you wanna okay
well actually well actually sometimes
yeah they're actually good foreign true
yeah sometimes things do going but I
think broadly speaking the fact that
you're sitting here in clothing that you
didn't make and I'm sitting here on an
airplane that I don't know how to fly or
Bill like right there's a lot of cool
stuff that happens when people come
together and they make civilizations and
part of that civilization building is
the fact that we can specialize and it's
the fact that we can offload a bunch of
trust onto third parties that we
delegate the power to make important
decisions about our lives right I don't
know anything about how to like build
like a combustion engine but I know that
when I push the button on my car it's
going to drive around and the fumes
aren't going to kill me and I can park
it in garages and the building's not
going to collapse and the only reason
all of this works is because I've
offloaded a lot of trust under these
third-party things and I would say that
the pillars of these third-party things
that Society is built on are roughly
speaking institutions so that might be
the institution of peer review for
scientific articles it might be the
institution of uh voting for government
right or the the ability for us to vote
in that whole process it might yeah all
the FDA like all of these institutions
and things that they need to exist
because we don't have the time or the
capability to individually sort through
all of our all of these things
individually we have to rely on some
certain to do it okay so you believe at
scale the when we're together we're
greater than the sum of our parts that's
the case for institutions absolutely
what about the inefficiencies of
bureaucracy is there some aspect when at
scale
different Dynamics come into play than
they do when there's two people together
two people that love each other the
birds and the bees is there some aspect
that leads more to cannibalism at scale
so like corruption inefficiencies that
due to bureaucracy and so on bureaucracy
which is not I hate it when people try
to say bureaucracy is government because
bureaucracy exists a ton in private
environments as well right in businesses
and everything
um bureaucracy introduces its own set of
problems but I mean a bureaucracy is
necessary because it's coordinating all
of the underlying things in order in
order to create something that's greater
than the sum of its parts right like all
of the software developers in the world
are useless without being paired with
good designers in order to make their
products usable by a person and the
coordination of those people and the
coordination of increasingly more and
more things necessitates some level of
bureaucracy I think we always say
bureaucracy when it's like a bad it's
like a slur almost like you're a
bureaucrat you're bureaucratic the
bureaucracy is slowing everything down
it's like sure the bureaucracy slows
things down but bureaucracy also gives
us things like you know safe medicine
and safe water to drink for most of the
US or safe buildings to live in or safe
cars to drive so so the managers and
institution versus like the software
developers and the designers the
managers is the bureaucracy the the
reason bureaucracy is used as a slur is
that something about human nature
leads to bureaucracy often growing
growing indefinitely becoming less and
less efficient without a I mean this is
what capitalism can come in that
capitalism puts a pressure on the
bureaucracy not to grow too much because
you want the bureaucracy to be useful
but not large yeah and to be a certain
size yeah of course to be the minimum
size
to get the job done and so capitalism
provides that mechanism
government
does not always and so that's the
criticism of government of Institutions
where it can grow without a significant
mechanism that says there's a cost to
bureaucracy that's not being accounted
for here we're just paying for the
increasing size of government without
the benefit yeah government is a special
institution because it doesn't have to
show itself to be financially viable and
we kind of live in a capitalist economy
where that's generally the case so
government gets its powers from votes
from the people which introduces a whole
new set of possible positives and
possible negatives right having
something for instance that gives food
or shelter to homeless people maybe you
don't want that to have to run at a
profit but giving you know an
organization that can self-justify its
budgets perpetually and definitely
growing maybe that's not the best thing
yeah we always have to figure out how to
do the constraints there but what about
the the corrupting nature of power
that comes with institutions as well
absolutely so then you better pick your
your style of institution very carefully
I think that the Democratic institution
we have in the United States today I
think works very well but I mean there
are other styles of government that have
been tried in the past that I think lend
themselves more to corruption not to say
that by the way there's not corruption
in the United States of course there's
going to be varying levels of corruption
at like all
um at all levels but you run you run
into this interesting problem where
authoritarian regimes can act with
ruthless precision and swiftness because
they don't have to ask any questions
they just do do do do and that's it
um but the problem is is it's an
authoritarian regime they're prone to
missteps they're slow to respond to
changing or evolving needs there's an
interesting study that was put out a
while ago that showed that like every
single famine that happened around the
world almost all like 98 of them happen
under authoritarian regimes where like
freedom of speech is very limited it's
very rare for a famine to happen under
uh democracy because press and
everything makes the government more
responsive to the needs of the people
power can corrupt their levels of
corruption but you have to have like a
system of checks and balances on on all
of those different levels to make sure
it doesn't run off the rails I guess and
do a sick loop-de-loop and you know half
the population gets
nice call back there's a lot of people
that will listen to you say that the
Democracy in the United States is
working pretty damn well and and they
will spit out the drink if they're
drinking a drink
and uh be very upset uh can you make the
case that they're right and you're wrong
can I make the case the steel man there
right yeah well the steel man for them
is that people have a lot of problems on
the day-to-day and when they look and
they see what government is doing they
might see potholes outside their house
homeless people all over their downtown
and the United States just approved
another x billion amount of dollars for
Ukraine or they might be living in a
city where half the factories are shut
down a lot of their people out of work
but the president is on the TV talking
about how to find jobs for immigrants
coming in from Mexico and for these
people they have problems that exist in
their lives there some of them are
paying taxes to alleviate these problems
and then we listen to the when they
listen to the government talk feels like
the government is not responding to the
needs that they have and then that's one
problem then on top of that you've got
all of these people working in
alternative media they can show you well
look at this politician wasting this
much money or look at him double
speaking here or there look at Hillary
Clinton saying she's got a private
position in a public position look at
how all of these politicians have family
members that are getting rich because of
their relationships with people in
Congress look at the revolve door
between capitalist companies and the
government how can you look at all of
that take into account that the
government's not responding to your
needs and then really feel like it's a
government by the people and for the
people yeah this was very good good
Steel Man and good question how can you
how can you how can you tell that
they're not just politicians that care
more about continuously winning the
elections versus being uh running
government effectively they should care
about winning the elections that's the
first misconception a lot of people say
if this guy only cares about getting
voted in this guy like he doesn't even
believe about in a in fracking or
abortion he just changed his opinion to
get voted in anytime somebody says that
you should say that's really good you
want them to change their opinion so
they get put it in that's the whole
point of a democracy you don't want them
to be remain obstinate you don't want
them to say I'm not changing my opinion
no matter what the people want you want
them to evolve and adopt new opinions
based on what the population their
constituents are voting for yeah but the
cynical take is that they're the cert on
the surface they're changing their
opinion but that there's a boys club
where boys means the elite that under in
the smoke filled rooms
in secret they're actually have their
own agenda and they're following that
agenda and they're just saying anything
publicly duplicate the public based on
whatever the the the new trends are so
this is yeah I understand somebody asked
me this question and it flipped I I 180
completely um I was a Bernie Sanders
supporter in 2016 and my my single issue
voting thing was lobbying I thought that
lobbying the government was corrupt they
weren't responding to people it was
completely destroyed my faith in
government everything and I had one
question posed To Me by a conservative
that used to come home ice cream and
chat with me and he said
um and then he asked me can you think of
any
any popular opinion that the American
public has that the government is
unresponsive to is there some big piece
of legislation or policy or whatever
that people want that the government
isn't doing
they asked me that I couldn't think of a
single good answer I'm like oh geez this
is a good answer there's drugs there's
not drugs legalization of drugs yeah go
for it all right well shoot you're doing
The Joe Rogan thing you're pushing back
because I brought up weed go ahead
I'm sorry I have become meme
[Laughter]
uh no uh because people bring up okay
okay there's no issues there's no issues
that the government is not representing
of the public so here's the issue so
somebody will bring up like well what
about the legalization of drugs okay the
first issue people have is one they look
at National polling yeah very few things
are decided on a national level so
that's the first huge mistake arguably a
lot of BLM made mistakes in this um
Arena where they're saying like why
isn't the government doing anything
about policing federal government can't
do anything about policing that's going
to be your sometimes any of your state
government some of your local city
government the people that like elect
like your chief of um police your Police
Commissioner that's coming from your
mayor right
um so you've got people looking one at
the wrong parts of the government to
even figure out the solution to the
problem two oftentimes for polling the
questions are vague enough that you can
pull very high when you get into the
Weeds on things no pun intended um you
start to realize like oh shoot this is
more complicated I thought I don't know
the numbers in particular for
legalization of of marijuana but this is
what I'm going to guess is the case if
you pull and you say should we legalize
marijuana that number might pull at like
65 70 percent
but that's including people that are in
favor of medical marijuana if you were
to pull like should we legalize should
we decriminalize recreational use of
marijuana that never might drop to like
52 and then if you pull like should we
completely legalize not just completely
legalize recreationalism that never mind
dropped like 40 there's like all these
different ways you can pull around
issues where people like oh no we
broadly agree on this topic when you
really figure well do you do we really
agree or is it just like broad consensus
around a thing that's never going to
show up like in a piece of legislation a
really good example one example I do
know is socialized health care I think
if you pull there's a time a few years
ago where if you pull America do you
think every American citizen should have
access to uh like free health care I
think that answer that pulled like 74
yes but when you asked should the
government be the Sole Provider of
Health Care it dropped to like 26
percent dropped 50 points and you could
see it was both asking questions about
single-payer but the way that it was
asked was so different that even if you
all it looks like there's consensus
there's not nearly as much consensus as
people think around certain ideas
you're right you're right you're right
that polls the way you ask the polls
really matters but when you ask should
the government be in charge of a thing
that also biases the answer right that
like because there's such a Negative
experience with government creating
a.gov site that runs the thing but
sometimes sometimes I think if you dig
in if you have a one-hour conversation
with each individual citizen sure I
think you will understand that yes there
is support for socialized medicine like
it's not the argument has to be made
though yeah what do you mean like if you
just ask a conservative like what about
single-payer they're gonna tell you no
you might be able to build up to an
argument for it but you're gonna have to
make the case for it no but I thought
we're talking about
the feeling deep inside your mind and
heart does the government represent that
oh so it's not like some shallow surface
layer public opinion does the government
effectively represent what the people
want
not a shallow survey but a deeply what
they want I'm not actually that familiar
with the debates over health care but
let's maybe look at an easier one maybe
you'll say it's harder war war is a
really good example where the government
was very responsive I think to the
people you think so so Iraq Afghanistan
the government didn't manipulate
public opinion there's an argument to be
made that they did in terms of like wmd
and everything but after 9 11 were you
in the United States after 9 11 after 9
11. dude I legit seems accusatory like
what were you and then
just checking okay all right cool I have
evidence and uh oh sure Witnesses no
okay all right I'm very defensive right
now it's very strange looking look into
it Alex yeah I think after 9 11 we could
have gone to Country we could have gone
to war with any country in the world we
would have we were ready because all of
America was like oh my God and they
pointed to Iraq and you know the reasons
for the wmds was kind of dumb but I
don't think we even needed wmds to go to
Iraq we could have just said you know
Saddam Hussein was giving Medical Aid to
Taliban Al-Qaeda Iraq let's go and we
would have gone for it but um post Iraq
Iraq was for a while popular and then
became obviously deeply unpopular Iraq
and Afghanistan and I think you could
see that influence other foreign policy
that the United States had for instance
we opted more towards like drone Warfare
than troops on the ground for places
like Yemen we opted more towards like
kind of like sending money and help
instead of boots on the ground for
places like Syria and I think that a lot
of that was kind of in response to how
unpopular the Iraq stuff had became and
when you looked at a lot of Elections
afterwards even for Obama like one of
the defining characteristics of a lot of
campaigns were like I'm going to close
Guantanamo Bay I'm going to get us out
of Foreign Wars even up to Trump I'm
going to I'm you know I'm not going to
stop doing all this weird stuff in the
Middle East but they didn't still
withdraw from a guest then they didn't
withdraw but they definitely like
tapered off and weren't like as
aggressively pushing those types of
conflicts because they knew it was
unpopular but I think if you also
consider perfect information or or good
information if you ask a lot of people
are you okay spending this amount of
money money
for this purpose so military conflict in
Iraq and Afghanistan I think almost from
the very beginning they would say no
after 9 11 I feel like maybe like a few
days after 9 11 like I remember what was
it
well there's there's some memes and so
on yes but the nature of the public
support for the war
was there public support in 2003 which
is when The Invasion happened
I feel like initially there was a lot I
remember seeing it on but then I also
lived in a republican household and I
was not very like media Savvy at the
time I don't know if the nature of that
public support had to do with wmds or
with 911 because the weird came about
wmds but I wonder what what is the name
if you were to pull people and let's say
hypothetically there was above 50
support for the war what would be the
nature of that support and
due to what degrees the government
actually representing the will of the
people versus
some complex mechanism like the
military-industrial complex is
manipulating The Narrative that's
controlling public opinion and then
there's the media that uh gets a lot of
attention by being divided and how
they're shaping The Narrative through
the mechanism of division so what
there's a lot of complicated things yes
it's not just like the people and then
the government and that's yeah for sure
I agree that there are going to be
different elements at play and how much
of those elements that lead us astray
can be attributed to the largeness of
the different systems so and the
different institutions like the the
media institutions and government
the institutions that have a monopoly on
violence let's put it this way which is
what one way to define government sure
it's complicated
um there's definitely different
institutions at play I but I think that
like all I would say is like in
reference to my original point when
there becomes like broad consensus
around a thing I think the government
will usually follow it's not going to
fight it's going to follow more often
than not
um but I think that a lot of times I
think Americans think that there's more
consensus around certain issues and
there actually are um so like a really
good example we're on that warp Point
too
um what caused like the lowest dip in
Biden's approval rating
I'm pretty sure it was right after we
pulled out of Afghanistan which I think
if I would have asked people like a year
before like let's assume that we could
pull out of Afghanistan
um the government's probably going to
collapse after we leave because they
just don't have the will to fight they
don't have the support they don't
whatever they're just not going to work
but like no Americans are going to die
there might be a couple other people but
like no America's gonna die we're gonna
say would you support that I think
broadly speaking I think I think like
more than 60 or 70 of Americans are like
yeah that would be fine but then when it
actually plays it on TV when we see the
people hang on to the planes when we see
like helicopter Embassy some of the
quotes from politicians well now it's
like oh my God this was horrible and it
was so botched and it was so like it
could have gone so much better well
could it have gone better like maybe
maybe not but I mean it seems like you
can have consensus around its own
opinion but the way that things play out
and the way that people actually feel
it's actually way way way more
complicated and there's not usually this
broad consensus opinion when all right
yeah go ahead I'd like to believe that I
mean just to leave my cars out on the
table
I have uh faith
in the power of Effective Government
I just
have
um a lot of concern about what happens
as institutions grow in size for sure
and I just have a lot of worry about the
natural corrupting influence on the
individuals and on the system as a whole
like the the boys club nature of it I
don't know there must be a better term
but basically they
they agreed to the game and they play
the game and there's a generational
aspect momentum to the game and they
more and more stop being responsive to
the people that they represent I just
feel like there is that mechanism and I
think the nice thing democracy elections
are resistance to that natural human
mechanism
um also the balances of power is a
resistance to that mechanism in some
ways the media that reveals the [ __ ]
of politicians is also a resistance to
that mechanism it's it's hard to be full
of [ __ ] as a politician because people
try to catch you on it so there's a
honesty method there that keeps you
honest it's to some degree but it still
feels like
it still feels like politicians are
going to politician
yeah they definitely play their games
that is true but there's probably always
going to be that meta narrative over
like governance that just develops as
like you have to form relationships and
play games to play get legislation
passed and everything the all the only
reason why I don't like it when people
attack institutions is because one
institutions are incredibly important
arguably Paramount no they are to
keeping Society Running and two I think
sometimes when we shift the blame onto
institutions too much I think that we
lose sight of what the real problems are
so for instance in the United States
today people might be very critical of
the government not getting much done but
then everybody turns their eyes to the
government for being ineffective but
what I would argue is I would say the
government is actually incredibly
effective and it's showcasing the will
of the American people really well right
now which is we are historically more
divided than we have ever been and if I
were to just look at the people and I
would say we have a historic divide that
is getting like rapidly blown apart by
things like the internet and the media
right if that exists well what would I
expect the government to look like I
wouldn't expect the government to be
governing very fast I would expect that
government to show that legitimate
divide in people do you think that
divide we have a perception of a large
divide between left and right do you
think that's a real divide this in this
country narrow the language what do you
mean by real divide
do you think there is that divide in
ideology that there's a large number of
people that believe a certain set of
policies and the different set of
policies I think that's the perception
of the on on Twitter no I think there is
a large divide in terms of belief I
don't think that's very much divided
between any people in terms of like what
they like on the most fundamental levels
want in terms like human beings but in
terms of like Democrat risk Republican
right now I think there is a huge divide
in terms of the direction they want to
see the country go and what they believe
really and what they even believe is
reality right unfortunately that's where
we've gotten to
can I just speak about the mechanism of
the left and right here maybe on the
memetic ratherly aspect is there some
aspect to the left on which you're part
of that attacks their own
for ideological impurity more than the
right does is it the bigotry of small
differences there's a name there's a
concept where
um when you're near somebody who is very
slightly different than you you want to
destroy but when you're with something
that's way different than you you don't
um I think the left does it but I think
the right does it too I didn't realize
until I started dipping more into
conservative communities but oh my God
the people from The Daily wire and the
people from turning point and um the
America First all the all these
different groups of people hate each
other and they fight each other so much
they hire and fire sometimes employees
they talk smack about each other I think
there's a lot of political division
between both sides I think that the left
just kind of gets highlighted more
because it's like the internet and a lot
of the internet spaces have a lot of
left-leaning people so you see like the
crazy Communists and the crazy
progressives and the crazy center-left
liberals and the crazy blah blah blah
whereas like a lot of the right-leaning
people have kind of been pushed off of
the main areas of the internet now
interesting my sense was that it's hard
to exist on the center left
but maybe because I just don't have the
full spectrum view of the political
divide it felt like Central Lots is a
difficult position to occupy yeah I
would definitely say so yeah I don't
know if it's that difficult to be center
right it's very difficult to be center
right I think actually maybe even more
difficult because the center right
person might be somebody who's like
conservative but not a fan of trump and
you're like over like look like Liz
Cheney right you've had politicians that
are just like they didn't back the Trump
stuff and now they're gone or you might
be like center right but like you don't
think the election was stolen and now
you're like half the Republican party is
looking you're like you're crazy you
know
um that's true yeah that's true I think
uh there's a Ben Shapiro who I'm talking
with I think he publicly spoke against
Trump right he did initially but I feel
like he softened his language up on him
pretty significantly but so there's a
significant pressure to kind of coverage
out to a certain kind of messaging which
the whole Republican party is feeling
right now geez that two years from now
that election is going to be insane it's
just hard okay so to generalize it's
hard to be in the center it feels like
for sure Center and then like do like a
random walk
among the policies around that I don't
know what that mechanism is I mean it
makes people like me not feel good being
in the center it seems like people are
just not nice to people in the center
like the the public uh the Twitter
machine is not nice to people who are
open-minded in the center
is that there's some truth to that two
reasons for that one is because I think
a lot of people that market themselves
as Center are legitimately spineless
cowards and deserve to be called out
like like I've never killed the man but
today might be my first I don't know
um there I'll take over like I told you
I'll take over your stream with the AI
is that guy going to be streaming the
best
okay gotcha gotcha gotcha gotcha lots of
guys lots of gotchas okay guys okay
gotcha okay and uh decrease the amount
which already is a pretty low level of
emotion just decrease it completely when
people are screaming at you and accusing
stuff just remain calm absolutely
emotionless the gaslighter strategy yeah
okay so what we're talking about so I I
don't uh I don't even I don't ever
identify Center anything because it's
got such a bad reputation because [ __ ]
that I stand center with the spine it's
called being open-minded and it's not
Central left and right those are just
labels here's a really good quote my mom
said to me when I was really young she
said Stevie don't ever let your mind be
so open that your brain falls out and
that's what I find that a lot of Center
people do that's not what she told me
last night so why are you like this
I'm sorry okay I'm glad I can glad I can
bring that I'm glad you feel like it's a
safe space like I said before
non-judgmental if you want to talk about
[ __ ] my mom you know what you're
totally within your rights I didn't say
that you said that I support that she's
a beautiful woman her husband probably
wouldn't be too happy about it but you
know I didn't say there's any sexual
relations I it was just that having a
conversation with her you projected that
that says more by you than me anyway go
ahead about spineless Center
there are some aspects to that which is
like amorphous to me Center means you
you think freely about each individual
policy without being stuck to a case
some idea yeah but a lot of people don't
do that they call themselves Centrist
but then they're just they're
anti-establishment essentially on
everything I don't know your position on
like vaccines or anything
um but like I've met a lot of like free
and open thinkers who are like you know
what I'm open to everything and it's an
experimental vaccine and I'm gonna eat
hydroxychloroquine and Ivermectin
because that's what the institutions are
telling me not to take and I think fauci
got too much money from that company and
these are but I'm an open thinker and
I'm and they what what open thinker
because I'm an MIT what do you think
about position of vaccines is exactly I
hear a lot of crazy things from a lot of
people okay you might be from MIT but I
know you're from the internet okay
people from the internet are weird and
crazy so yeah
well I uh who knows I don't like
arrogance and I have criticized
scientists during covet a lot of people
but scientists included having arrogance
which is fair but and that's and I think
there's a lot of good criticism to be
made of different
um scientific and medical establishments
over a lot of stuff but nobody can make
those good criticisms because they're
too like obsessed over like just trying
to have the anti-establishment answer
and that is what is upsetting me the
most like I think there are good
conversations to be had
about a lot of stuff related to how we
handle the coronavirus you know we're
lockdowns effective was there enough
data to support the huge measures we
took
um you know why didn't we have the
option to show I was infected a month
ago why do I need to be vaccinated why
wasn't that option everything in the
United States I don't think it was
um there are really good questions to be
asked there but all the people asking
the questions are also trying to tell
you that Ivermectin and monoclonal
antibodies are the way to go for
everything and the vaccine is evil and
it's going to turn you gay like the
frogs and it's like Jesus like you can
there's like no place to reasonably
criticize from because all of the people
that are criticizing aren't doing it
with an open mind or you know they're
not reading studies that do anything
they're saying like I do my own research
which means they listen to whatever the
last game Joe Rogan said and now they're
parroting that opinion easy no yeah the
last guy on Joe Rook I'm not sure we're
working okay that Robert Malone guy on
Joe Rogan got me real fast that's one
guest people see him as like the father
of mRNA technology he published one
paper okay what do you mean people which
people think that Joe Rogan fans I get
like I run into these people I start
arguing when they start studying me what
about I'm a Joe Rogan fan and I
appreciate the vaccine that's good I'm
glad you do but there's definitely sorry
also but you said there's a type there's
a type what's the type what's the type
of Joe Rogan fan anti-establishment
I think that's not Joe Rogan that's a
that's a general public discourse
there's a default anti-establishment on
the on the right and the left that's the
default easy thing to go to I think Joe
Rogan fans are definitely a certain type
of anti-establishment though like I
could guess to Joe Rogan fell like if I
were to do general population versus Joe
Rogan fan who do you think is more
likely to be anti-vaccine
do you have data on this are you just
guessing yeah just guessing yeah I think
you are actually judging I am I think
you're judging because I think you're
also
the beautiful thing about podcasting
this could be similar streaming is
there's a large number of people that
just listen like what what does it mean
to be a Joe Rogan fan I don't think you
just listen I think people listen and
absorb the information I would say that
Joe Rogan fanbase is as divided in the
vaccine as the general public gotcha man
I'm gonna look for pulling data on that
I'm sure somebody's got to have done it
out there but no but you're you're
basically revealing the fact they have
no data you're using your own judgment
for sure uh based on how he's had
conversations about how his experience
with the coronavirus and then based on
the guests that have come on that have
talked and echoed a lot of like anti-vax
talking points and been completely
unchallenged and then based on
statements he's made about like
myocarditis and the vaccine and
everything as well yeah so the it's the
level of Challenge and not that he's
doing well yeah and then what his true
positions are and then the types of
guests he typically chooses to bring on
to talk about the vaccines yeah okay but
that represents somehow a deep
anti-establishment feeling versus just
the vaccine I mean I've seen the vaccine
and other things being
a thing that broke people in front of
virus that whole one or two years broke
a lot of people there's a lot of emotion
and emotion quickly uh solidified into
an opinion that almost had nothing to do
with like re like thinking through and
updating your knowledge and so on you
just made up a made up your mind yeah
but I think a lot of it comes from that
anti-social place like what the vaccine
represents the ultimate of establishment
it was a huge private company backed by
a huge uh public government and there's
fouchy and there's Biden and there's
Pfizer and there's all these countries
locking us up in our homes telling us to
do a thing like the vaccine was like the
ultimate like submission tool to like
show you that the government owns you
not only you have to get injected once
it's a series and then you got to get
boosters and it's like they're trying to
keep you under their thumb and it's
that's the control
um I Feel Like That vaccine became like
the ultimate rallying cry between like
do you support are you a sellout that is
going to believe whatever the government
tells the Sheep to take or are you going
to be like the guy that stands against
the crowd and gets fired from his job
and pulls his kids from school because
they're not going to let the evil fouchy
medicine you know jab them in the arm
and the funny thing is the crowd that
stands against
the institution is not larger than the
crowd of sheep there's like one sheep
standing there charm yeah or it feels
that way sometimes sheep well okay uh
what's the defensive institutions how do
you regain the trust of Institutions
like
first of all do you think that there's
ways in which who CDC failed and do you
think there's criticism towards Pfizer
and the big Pharma companies that's
deserve it the Hamptons it's the Pharma
companies I'm not sure for CDC and who
so here's a criticism that I have of all
of Academia and I feel it stronger
stronger every day I don't think it's
enough to be a researcher or to be
correct about issues Academia needs to
increase its ability to communicate
um it is just an an unbelievable
unmitigated failure that academics are
unwilling to wade into the complicated
topics uh that exist today because other
people are you know first you call me
spineless and then you call me a bad
communicator but no look you're here
you're doing it so you get props for me
okay good job but there are like so many
but I'm sure you've I'm sure that you
must have
um heard another fellow academic a
fellow colleague expressed some amount
of frustration about like and there's
specific discipline they know something
to be true and they know that like a lot
of the messaging is like wrong or bad in
the public about it but they're never
going to step out and say anything
because either one they're very measured
and careful with their take which they
feel is incompatible with what people
want to hear or two they're really
worried that they might be incorrect so
they're going to be cautious while
everybody else is going out in like
hardcore and they also don't have the
supportive institutions for them to go
out on a limb yeah so like to take risks
for example I've heard that with uh lab
League Theory I've had a lot of
biologists biologists friends they're
like yeah it's obviously leaked from a
lab like early on oh maybe okay we can
fight over this one but sorry guys we
can fight over this like they okay I
should sort of backstep and say like
that's like you talk about shooting the
shed you haven't really investigated but
it's your gut like this doesn't make any
sense there would never say that
publicly of course mostly because you're
saying like what they would all say is
like we want to see data yeah which
would be good which is fine so they're
going with like like this is too many
coincidence in the same place that's the
the logic but they don't want to say
anything because there's no data you
need to have evidence you need to have
actual evidence to say one way or the
other there's that but there's also just
like you said I mean if effective
effective communication you're a fan of
Sean Carroll yes he's like one of the
only people in this whole planet that I
like besides you I love Sean this is any
time Sean Carroll is brought up as
evidenced there's a smile that comes
over your face I love of like Joy yeah
of like a little kid thinking about
Santa Claus okay I love Sean Carol too I
love Sean Carroll because there I hate
this divide between like you're either
stem or you're like philosophy arts and
all that other stuff and the Two Worlds
kind of across and I love that it was so
good at physics but like explores and
pays attention to all of the like
sociological stuff too it's so rare to
find that quality in a person he's legit
one of the really really special minds
but you don't have to be a Sean Carl you
can be just a little better at educating
another person in the uh in the medical
in the health space is somebody named
Andrew huberman a friend of mine from uh
Stanford he's an incredible educator
there's the kind of process in science
that you should call like review or
survey papers where you basically
summarize all that's going on integrate
it and like draw wisdom from it and also
project like where's the discipline head
and and Andrew does that basically on
all these sub-components of the
different stuff going on in in
neuroscience and biology and
neurobiology all that he's able to he
does a podcast called huberman lab where
he just summarizes on and is able to
explain like what does that actually
mean for your for your life in terms of
Protocols of how to make your life
better I feel like people should be able
to do that more and more but with viral
virology and oh boy that's a tricky one
that's a really tricky one I wish that
people could have honest conversations
like I attack a lot of people that do
the lab League Theory stuff but truly we
should be able to have that conversation
publicly it just it always feels like
the people that are having the
conversation don't ever really want to
have the conversation they're not being
honest like like I'm a guy that like
does his own research and it's so boring
reading studies and a lot of it I can
only do abstracts and like I like it's
so much work but I'll never ever say
that about myself I'm a guy that does
his own research because every time I
hear somebody say that they don't do any
research when they say they do their own
research with immunities they've seen
one podcast and their opinion on this
podcast is that definitely not mine
because it was mine I wouldn't be
criticizing anything they say
um but yeah so like lab leak is another
one where it's like well how do you know
it's lap League how do I know it's lab
leak uh because fauci lied and Hunter
Biden uh laptop okay come on you haven't
engaged with it at all there's really
interesting interesting research that
shows us a really strong study that
shows that there's like a high degree of
certainty that it came from the wet
markets very very high degree of
certainty and there was an article that
came out recently where it's like Senate
concludes that virus actually came from
the Wuhan virology lab or whatever
um and that whole article if you
actually read it it never says that in
the article I don't know why they
tweeted it with that headline
um but yeah it's to back up I'm sorry I
think we should have good you should be
sorry yeah I'm not sorry actually I get
to ramble here okay I'm here for a long
time I rescind my apology okay I
actually rescind my apology
um we should be able to have challenging
conversations about things but you gotta
man be well read on both sides not not
this like I do my own research so I
don't believe anything that fauci says
like come on dude do you think you can
do better than that not you personally
but gotcha
how does that feel it feels all right so
people who don't know feel understood
that's the catchphrase gotcha through
all tragedy and Triumph through all the
roller coaster of Life your response to
it is gotcha yeah
it's uh well actually let me jump to
that before I continue to with political
discourse
um psychologically you are in a lot of
heated debates and you're usually super
calm Under Fire until you're not
sometimes you lose your temper
completely very rarely but that's like
your opinion man let me ask you about
your psychology what are psychologically
your strengths and weaknesses that
you're self-aware about I think I'm very
non-judgmental so I can entertain a lot
of different thoughts without agreeing
with them or condoning them I think
that's a really big benefit to me
um for whatever reason I seem to be like
pretty calm in dealing with annoying
people it's why I got promoted at the
casino so fast I could deal with like
drunks or whatever like it just didn't
affect me that much what percent of the
population is annoying
depends on how you're engaging with them
most people aren't really annoying ever
but they're doing like political debate
um how what percentage is annoying I
guess it depends on who I'm debating and
what the topic is well I guess I'm
trying to point out the fact that
sometimes you can say
that reveals something about you if you
think a large percent of people are
annoying well I would say working
graveyard shift when alcohol is involved
that percentage of people goes very very
high or to be more fair actually it's
not a high percentage truly but if
you're a server one bad customer can
ruin the rest your shift so you only
need like one or two people acting in
that manner to just like totally throw
you off and you're able to at least
these days not allow that one customer
to throw you off quote unquote yeah very
much like a um I noticed especially
after having a son there's something
about like six-year-old kids or whatever
where it's like if they get mad they're
never gonna be mad for that long like
they'll move on like that's my mentality
I'm like a six-year-old kid like I might
be mad about something but I'll get over
in like 30 minutes or an hour like yeah
um I'm pretty good about not carrying
that through it's very rare that I'll
like hold a grudge against anybody or
like be angry about something or really
disaffected by something over the long
term it almost never happens to me what
are your weaknesses psychologically I
should say I still have a problem with
projecting I think we all probably do
but like my mind onto others it's like
if I understand this and I've said this
you should understand it and if you're
not you're dumb that's like an issue
that I I still have that where I project
too much what about like holding grudges
and stuff like that I'd never hold
grudges I'm like the least grudgy person
ever it's kind of a me and my community
because anybody can always like come
back
um as long as they're acting different
yeah what about this as long as they're
acting differently I mean all right the
reason why I say that is because um so
for instance nobody likes this but I
have a strong stance on apologies and
then I hate them I don't ever want to
hear an apology I don't care about them
ever they don't mean anything to me if
you did something bad as long as you've
like fixed the behavior and you're not
doing that thing then we're generally
chill it's like there's been a lot of
people that have been involved in weird
stuff with me but then like they they go
off they do their thing and they come
back and it's like okay cool as long as
you don't do it again like we're fine
like it's all good
I'm sorry you feel that way
it's not your fault Steven it's not your
fault okay gotcha you've said plenty of
negative stuff positive stuff and
negative stuff about Hassan yeah this is
my podcast I get to get you to force you
to say positive things what do you love
oh I'm All About Love let's go back to
grilling me on the r word stuff where
you're gonna make me compliment Hassan
this is gonna be a harder conversation
than that all right you're there's we're
going to get you to feel emotions okay
uh so he's another for people who don't
know he's another popular political
streamer I think you had uh as the kids
call it a bridge burning over Bernie
Sanders I don't know my research is very
limited on this sure but
um what do you respect and love most
about Hassan
he puts in a lot of work when he was
like growing his stream from 2 000
Concord viewers to 15 000 he was
streaming like it was like 12 hours a
day like every single day
um so that was that we're gonna get a
lot of work
um he does seem to be pretty good at
networking and like socializing and
making the correct friends and
connections to continue to build his
business what about him as a political
thinker I know you don't think I leave
him on that on that regardless
that's not fair I honestly want to push
back on that because okay I have zero
respect for him as a political thinker
oh there's not going to be almost
anything so I will say I I admire the
fact that through no actual capability
or ability of his own he manages to wind
up at some of the correct answers just
because he's Towing the lines that is
good job for him on that he's got a lot
of correct opinions just he has no idea
why so I think that's undeserved I think
that's too harsh Man Okay the reason I
bring that up is I feel like there is
a deep Grudge in there somehow so you're
the the father now so since you're so
old the grandfather of the uh uh
political debate on stream on live
stream political debater so
there could be some Grudge about that
split that happened or not enough credit
given all that kind of stuff I just I
just think he's somebody that has uh
a left-leaning ideology that's different
than yours he was a Bernie supporter
right and I guess you were not
can you can you explain to me where the
division is he exemplifies everything
that I absolutely hate about which is
what which is shallow engagement uh
heavily ideologically driven and you're
not ideologically different absolutely
not absolutely that's that's what we're
talking about like the free thinker in
the real meaning of that word yeah so
the way let me let me qualify your
thinking let me qualify what I mean when
I say that
um I spent a lot of time unfortunate
time delving into the boring world of
philosophy I spent a lot of time
thinking about like what are my ethical
positions how do I feel about myself
like people around me and how that
relates to the world around me and then
from all of these positions I think you
might have used the phrase first
principles earlier
um from these kind of like first
principles out of that is where all of
my political positions are built out of
like full stop so if you ask me a
question like how do you feel about like
the right to own a firearm or how do you
feel about social health care like we
can walk through well this is how I feel
about it as like a thing from the
government this is where the government
gets its power this is ethically how
groups of people are supposed to
function this is morally how we relate
to each other and personally this is how
I feel like I'll be able to do every
single political belief back there it's
not like I'm telling you like if I were
to ask Hassan
um what do you feel about this political
topic he's going to tell me what
progressives are supposed to say I don't
know what he thinks about I don't know
don't you think that's a cynical take
why is he just because his views
coincide with the mainstream narrative
mainstream viewpoints of progressive
things because this I mean why does that
mean he's not thinking
because it's engagement with every
subject is incredibly shallow 100
predictable like I could write like a I
could probably program a script to like
give you every single potential answer
you could have to any single question
you could give again I think that's
pretty cynical take okay it could be the
case that his brain perfectly aligns
with every single manner but I don't
know if you know it is perfectly aligns
because I think you're just taking a
very select just like streamers do of
each other a very select slice that
represents the perfect alignment as
opposed to looking at a person
struggling with ideas and thinking
through ideas and then giving them a
pass like a lot of people like I give
you a pass on just the fact that you say
a lot of crazy [ __ ] on stream for drama
like which is I don't say things for
drama it might be dramatic but
I mean you've evolved as a fish evolves
legs you've evolved a mechanism about
which creates controversy sure that you
could say it's not intention but it
happens I think okay sure the extremists
kind of learn that kind of thing and so
I'm sure Hassan does the same kind of
stuff and so like underneath it there's
still thinking being that's that's
contending with political ideas you
don't think so does a really good job at
hiding it there are other political
figures that I really don't like that I
wouldn't say the same thing about so
like I don't know if you have vosh right
in there I'm like okay if that's a
person that watched he also split out of
my community and grew up to something I
know he hates me and he's an anti-fan
community and they all have hey tell me
something you love about what my [ __ ] I
can tell you a lot of things about vosh
I think vosh legitimately thinks through
a lot of his political positions
um I admire or did admire that he has
like his own like positions he would
take someone's contrary to people
further left than him um he's got some
positions that don't fit his ideology
kind of at all like he's his own
independent thinker rhetorically he's
very effective he was willing to sit
down and do research for like his baits
and everything he would spend a lot of
time practicing like his rhetorical
Effectiveness and navigating
conversations he intentionally
purposefully built like a community that
exemplified his values
um yeah I've got a lot I don't we're we
are completely split and hate each other
now but like I have a lot why why first
of all hate is a strong what why the
hate okay I don't hate him but he hates
me because we had a couple of really big
debates what happened well one had to do
with whether or not you should live your
values and can you give me the story
that's a charitable interpretation I
always give charitable interpretation
you don't you don't absolutely do you
don't wait
seven five minutes ago you talking about
Hassan everything I said about sound is
true there is no Steel Man there okay
not charitable
I'm sorry if you can if you can prove me
wrong I would love for you to do it okay
I'm using my gut instinct usually when
somebody feels strongly about another
person in that way it's not coming from
a place of data and reason is coming
from a place of emotion it's coming from
a place of resentment and Grudge and all
that kind of stuff yeah there's deep
there's emotions deep in there so the
gotcha is hiding the the gotcha is is a
surface of an iceberg and there's a deep
ocean underneath that you yourself have
not explored I disagree but I understand
my love is actually a doorway the young
lavasadory for you to explore the depths
get into that ocean to find my fish my
pre-evolved form yeah um I understand
why you think the way you do and you
should you shouldn't believe me and I
understand that because if somebody told
me the same thing I think you probably
just really don't like this person for a
reason or two I understand what you
think that way okay the reality is
though for any political person that I
disagree with like I can give them a
fair Shake it's one of the few things I
think I do exceedingly well on my stream
even with Hassan there's been drama that
he's been involved in and I've like very
when I'm involved in drama he'll always
throw me under the bus but when he's
involved in stuff I'll always like oh
like I think his son was right here or I
think that he meant this
um there was a there was a thing that
came up once we're on well ice cream
fail he was getting roasted because he
referred to somebody he used the
expression [ __ ] skin to refer to
somebody's like the way they looked and
I have only ever heard that in the
context of 4chan people talking about
like Indians or like black people like
it's a racial thing but I could tell the
context and everything that he was
saying he was insulting some guy I think
it was kind of like ncel version
whatever he was going for like acne skin
I think that's what he meant when he
said it and there were a whole bunch of
people that were insulting like oh my
god did he just say racist term and I
was like no I don't think he was racist
I think he was like he was just reaching
for words and that's what came out
um so like that's an example of me being
sure but okay but didn't you criticize
him for something I I was trying to uh
like Googled why the hell you guys split
out because I thought your friends you
should be
I feel like you criticized them over
something
and I'm okay this is very vague memory
but you criticize them over something
and I felt that criticism wasn't
charitable was it Pete Buda Church stuff
yeah Pete booty yes yes yes yes yeah so
I've said this a million times but
there's no amount of context or no
amount of nuances is ever acceptable
people I don't think Hassan is
homophobic but I think the comments made
about Pete booty judge were really
homophone that's what he said right yeah
and there were a lot of people making a
lot of comments that made me really
uncomfortable about Pete Buddha judge
that was insane to me spurred by the
comments of Hassan no but it was an
environment of progressives all the
progressives were attacking Pete and I
felt like his gayness became like the
subject yeah why why throw Hassan under
the bus for that because he was jumping
along with all of those types of like
insults you don't think you've done the
same kind of stuff if I do call me out
and I'll probably that's what the r
award was about that's a good call out
yeah no but like your friend like you
should privately tell them right like
hey well no by then we were sworn
enemies so so that wasn't the reason no
no it was over at Kamala Harris videos
sworn enemies yeah he hates me what am I
supposed I listen for all of these
people I will accept them back into my
life if they ever want to come back in
at any point in time but usually they're
the ones if they correct themselves
right
no not I'm not expecting anybody here's
so here's the deal with vashina son
these are like the three we're the three
guys online none of us will talk to each
other
um Hassan because he won't give clout to
anybody and vosh because
um he thinks I'm bad faith and then
neither of them will talk to me because
they both hate me you guys should go
like on a camping trip together it's
like broke Back Mountain but three-way
and just like rejoin refine yeah for
each other honestly just from the
internet perspective for me as a just
stepping into this world
um there's some aspect to which you have
a responsibility I hate that word you
have another word you have an
opportunity I I wish you guys would kind
of be the beacon of like uh forgiveness
and friendship and like camaraderie and
that yeah I agree and even if we
disagree it would be really good content
yeah [ __ ] talk like friends [ __ ] talk
sure versus not like the fact that you
guys don't talk to each other
like I would love for you to [ __ ] talk
publicly with the camaraderie always
there like there's love in the in the
beginning love in the end but you beat
the [ __ ] out of each other in the middle
and that's what live streaming is for
the political discourses that's that's
great political discourse versus I think
what underlies is some jealousy and so
on with this you get this many
I just want to make sure you're clearly
everybody has to your audience yeah I'm
sure you have flaws and I'm just not I
mean in this Dynamic hard to find you
know because I'm your only flaws you're
too modest yeah so what why did you guys
split up because I I would love it
honestly just let me just put that idea
out there for you guys to to make up and
so yeah it's out there of course
Everybody Talks me Vash Anna son it's
crazy that like the three largest like
political debate left-lining people
online like can't do any type of content
or collaboration at all it's so stupid
um what was the reason you guys split up
the the Kamala Harris so Hassan's entry
into kind of like the twitch political
debate world was and I think 2018 I
think he did a debate with Charlie Kirk
and he reached out to me to kind of like
review that debate to like go on to go
over it on stream and he came on we went
over it and then we kind of friendship
developed we hung out of real life I
think when I came to La I think I slept
on his couch we played with his dog we
were like kind of friends
um and as time went on and he was a
little bit more
um he was farther left than he let on so
like I was a Social Democrat he was a
Social Democrat but back in those days
like 2018 when people said they were a
Social Democrat they really met
socialists but they just didn't want to
say it so he was farther left than me
and we had a lot of deep divides in our
approach to politics whereas like I was
very much like a first principal this is
my whole political position and he was
very much kind of like a this is like
the political ideology I'm involved in
and this is kind of like the field that
I kind of like navigate in so there were
a couple instances where these divides
would be laid very bare one was when I
it was either him or The Young Turks I
think it was him
there was a shooting in a neighborhood
where very young black child gets killed
by a white shooter and they did a video
about like hate crimes and how hate
crimes are on the rise between races and
white people are evil and blah blah blah
not that but like white people
committing hate crimes against black
people and I remember saying gentleman
was like hey we don't have all the data
yet for this it feels really bad to make
videos about this beforehand because
it's the same type of [ __ ] that happens
at airports you know uh is there a thing
going on was it a brown person are they
Muslim it's Islamic extremism we see
this played out so many times in recent
history probably not a good idea to jump
to conclusions and he's like well no you
don't understand like it's not that big
a deal whatever and obviously as The
Story Goes Tale As Old As Time the data
comes out it was just an errant shot
there was like gang violence shot goes
out of nowhere hits a kid in the car it
wasn't like a hate crime like I was
trying to kill a kid but yeah we
basically we bump up against a few kind
of political disagreements like this and
an annoying thing is happening in my
community where Hassan is like the
series political figure because he's
from The Young Turks and I'm just kind
of like I do politics but I also game
and anytime I criticize a song like
Destiny you need to be more respectful
he does this full time if you're going
to bring criticisms you need to be like
really well read and researched because
he's got a you know more serious
whatever which I thought was ridiculous
so by the way if people don't know he
worked at The Young Turks which is like
the largest left-leaning YouTube channel
probably at least at the time yeah
so finally he did a video on WE skip
ahead to some more minor disciplines he
does a video on Kamala Harris he calls
it Kamala Harris and it's like seven or
eight horrible things about Kamala
Harris and I'm like okay I know at least
one or two of these things are not fully
accurate so I'm gonna do all the
research I'm going to have all the
sources we're gonna have a long
conversation about it so that now when I
provide criticism to him it's not going
to be like this horrible like just me
saying something flippantly or whatever
it's going to be like substantial
criticism so I was on a plane ride
um JFK to Orlando whatever flying to
Sweden to visit my wife and on the plane
I review all the video all the data do
all the research and I read everything I
was like okay I get to my um my wife's
dad's house and I'm at the table we're
having a conversation like hey we should
talk about the Kamala Harris stuff and
he's like okay well let's do it and we
go over it and I'll leave to the
audience to watch the video enough
people say this I feel pretty confident
in this I was pretty reasonable pretty
measured pretty calm the whole time and
think he started to get increasingly
irritated that I was levying like more
and more serious criticisms at like the
quality of work that he did
um probably because he felt a little bit
intimidated I think by my willingness to
like dive through political stuff
there'd been a couple of awkward blobs
where like on um there's like a show
called the Raj Royale where sometimes
politics would come up and his son would
kind of try to explain something and
there was another person one time on the
show that made the joke it's like
instead of Hassan taking 10 minutes to
explain this contestant he just come
here and explain it in 30 seconds and he
like exploded that he got so [ __ ] mad
at that
um so yeah I think that when I made that
kind of call-out or critique of him over
the Kamal Harris stuff he's probably
feeling like increasingly irritated
threatened agitated and then that's kind
of what began the huge split so you
don't think you were a dick at all I
don't think so in that conversation
um especially given that like at that
point because this is still 20 18 or 20
this might be 2019 I'm still known at
that point as being very aggressive
towards conservatives oh gosh yeah so
and with lefties is what I call them I
think I'm being very gentle like my
conversation will start with
conservatives like you're a [ __ ] dude
you're so dumbled like that's how I'm
like doing something with him I'm like
well don't you think that like this is
like a little bit of like an
inconsistent presentation about like I
feel like I'm being honest but I always
leave to the audience so they can go and
watch that Kamala video Kamala Harris
video Destiny Assan if they think that I
was being doing that but a lot of people
watching said I was being pretty gentle
so well let me say as a new fan of this
space I hope you guys make up and I hope
you guys fight it out in the space of
discourse and ideas me too and also with
the empathy understanding what the
strength of the other person is what
their buttons are and you know there's
like an unspoken rule that you don't
press the buttons that you don't need to
unless you're doing it mutually and it's
fun because you know it's on the piece
each other off so yeah that's kind of
like what friends do you don't cross a
certain line but then other than that
you fight it out okay let's step back
one other super interesting aspect of
your world view is your big supporter of
Biden
can you explain what you love about
Biden do you love Biden more than Sean
Carroll or less Sean Carol's just like
in another world of gosh admiration I
feel like I'm culturally appropriating
You by saying gotcha now but it's so
convenient it's an easy word you're just
I know we're on the same wavelength okay
we're synchronizing that's good I mean
it is really interesting because even
the people that support Biden usually
don't say they love sort of they don't
support it strongly you know
ideologically philosophically the reason
why I like Biden is because he's really
committed to this bringing the left and
right together which is something we so
desperately need in the country and his
you know statements over and over again
of like I'm not a the Democrat president
or the Republican president I'm the
president of the United States his
desire to bring Republicans together to
work on things like the infrastructure
bill
um that's so incredibly needed and I
have a huge amount of respect and
admiration for him for trying to push
through on that message do you think
then it's unfortunate that he made that
comment about Maga Mega Republicans yeah
I mean I forget what the comment was but
it's Mega Republicans are not good
people kind of there I watched the full
video and he's right there is this toxic
aspect and it's hard to call out because
they're always going to spend like oh he
hits our Republicans he's not if you
watch the quote he's very specifically
calling out like this this group of
people that think that the election was
fraudulent is it clear it is what he
meant by we can bring it up all right
this is oh no oh did I remember watching
our stream it was like if you said it
yeah that's bad you're probably like
YouTube maggot Republicans Biden but
like it feels like it's pretty clear
he's talking about the people that are
like election denying
too much of what's happening in our
country today is not normal
Donald Trump and the Maggie Republicans
represented extremism that threatens the
very foundations of our Republic
I want to be very clear listen to this
question clear up front foreign
not every Republican not even the
majority Republicans are Maggie
Republicans
not every Republican Embraces their
extreme ideology
I know
because I've been able to work with
these mainstream Republicans
but there's no question
that the Republican party today is
dominated driven and intimidated
by Donald Trump and the Maggie
Republicans
and that is a threat to this country
I disagree with that man he didn't
Clearly say
extremist ideology he didn't say the
people that doubt the validity of the
election I mean that's Donald Trump no
but there's that's all the candidates
that Donald Trump is supporting how many
what is it like 40 50 how many
candidates right now that are Mega
candidates are electioned no but there's
uh you know 80 million or whatever
people voted for Donald Trump you could
say that's the mega Republicans so it to
me it sounded like he was referring to
not even the majority I mean that that's
one nice helpful clarifying
statement but it's basically there's the
mainstream Republicans and then there's
those that voted for Donald Trump that's
the way I heard it okay and it's like so
maybe you should have done a better job
at clarifying but yeah I feel like
there's like a clear there is a huge
problem with this group of Americans I
think like the election is stolen I feel
like that's what he's trying to no
matter
if that's what he meant
even flirting with that line is not a
person who's bringing people together I
feel like the extending a hand to the
like most I've worked with republicans
in Congress not all but not even a
majority of Republicans are like this
no but why say not the majority of
Republicans that like to say like we are
like we're one country we believe the
same thing so like focus on the uniting
part versus saying he does before and
after that was 50 seconds okay but that
you never know the point is you never
say something like that listen like that
you you've spoken about the Bosnia
speech which is your favorite of his
yeah I went back to and listened to it
before I move to that just on this it's
really hard for him to call out that
group of like election deniers I think
without it always feeling well why call
them out because it's arguably one of
the most destructive forces that exists
in this country today did it destroy
anything they were trying to did it
though
it didn't did it so does that mean we
don't call it out we wait till next time
because calling it out is giving fuel to
the division
like the people that doubted the
validity of the election that's anger
that's frustration with the other side
you heal that as opposed to saying all
those people that believed that at any
time are idiots they're Un-American I
mean they don't think the election was
real I don't know if Biden has The Heirs
of these people at all I don't know what
he can do for there's people that
believe the same thing on the in 2016
with the Russian hacking right there's
this down hold on yes
that is a super not fair comparison
there are definitely the mainstream
Democrat opinion was that Russian
um intrusion in terms of like social
media and stuff happen but there was
never a claim that like the election was
stolen no main or at least I don't know
of any mainstream Democrat that
supported that Donald Trump is not just
saying there was interference Donald
Trump is literally saying the election
was literally stolen that vote boxes
were ballot boxes were hidden that vote
tallies were manipulated that I think
the claim is there's a huge Gulf of
difference between the two so you can
attack Donald Trump for that yeah
I believe it's not the words of a uniter
to attack
people that believe that
You could argue maybe it's okay
but especially not being super clear
about that about who you're referring to
when you say bag of Republicans okay
because Maga
is a hat
and a slogan
that refers to
whatever the number is 70 million people
whoever that voted for Donald Trump
like if all the Republicans are consider
this Mega Republicans what percentage of
them do you think believe the election
was stolen
I feel like that number is I don't have
the Palm but I feel your number is like
probably more than 70 percent
what's what's America Republican maybe
I'm not like Trump like a trump
supporting we're probably a mega
Republican they're there for Trump
what's the difference between somebody
that voted for Trump and uh Mega
Republican and America Republican so my
mom is a mega Republican if Trump ran
independently and DeSantis ran under the
Republican ticket my mom would vote for
Trump She'll follow him to the end of
the Earth that's like a mega Republican
I think it's easy to mistake that
distinction
in these kinds of political speeches
because to me anybody who voted for
Trump can easily in the cut in the
context of the speech be interpreted as
a matter of Republican gotcha
I understand what you're saying maybe he
could have been more clear but like I
think in listening to that like
I think it's pretty obvious who he's
talking about but I guess if you have an
emotional response to it I can
understand the emotional response but
there's a lot of people I don't have an
emotional response I just don't like I
think uh I'm with what is it Michelle
Obama they go low we go high
meaning like to me a uniter doesn't
participate in derision sure unite or
might not but a leader has to be able to
accurately assess the situation before
him and make people aware of what's
going on you mean all the impeachment
trials all the censoring from social
media all of that didn't do the job
that's not his job I don't know that
mechanism his job is to inspire a nation
to unite a nation how can he do that
when half the people don't believe that
he was even legitimately elected like I
think he's done a good job at working on
legislation and doing stuff that
hopefully benefits all Americans but I
think it's important to recognize that
like there is a contingent of Americans
that don't even believe like this is
plenty of people that recognize that and
are fighting that and are constantly
screaming that from the rooftops his job
is to be the inspiring figure that makes
the majority of Americans be proud for
him to be a president of of the nation
they love and that's what the United
aspect is is you remind people that we
are one and we love this country will
have the ideas that it represents who
does that in other parts of that speech
it's like a 20 minute speech isn't it
but that's a [ __ ] up you just don't
participate in that division anyway I I
understand I understand I just wanted to
push back on the saying one of the
strength is that he's uh
he's uniting but yes that
that is an ideal that is a goal is a
great one and he is one that um espoused
that goal uh for a long time do you
think um what else does it so from
policy perspective and so on I thought
the way he's handled Ukraine and
everything thus far has been almost
perfect I think he did a really good job
at the political maneuvering and
bringing other countries into the fold
at establishing clearly like what our
mission was in relation to Ukraine I
thought he did a good job there I admire
him for pulling out of Afghanistan even
it was a little bit rough around the
edges like we got out and we're gone no
American lives are lost
um
the domestic policy he's passed more
major legislation than I think anybody
thought possible
um the green energy stuff for the last
bill the infrastructure Bill a lot of
the coronavirus relief I thought was
really good especially the expansion of
the child tax credit
um so from a policy perspective for an
end domestic I think he's been
successful rhetorically I think he's
generally been above board in terms of
like not attacking people being too
divisive he's trying to bring people
together and work on them what do you
think about the sort of popular in the
media criticism of his mental decline do
you think he's experiencing no he's not
a guy
what do you think I mean I do
yeah maybe a little bit but he's still
doing a good job so you know not from a
speech perspective you mean from a
policy perspective yeah I'm analyzing it
as a job yeah from speech perspective
maybe not the greatest but um yeah I
mean he's definitely what is he like 80
81 how old is he I lose track after so
many years yeah
but you did say that he's probably going
to run in 2024 and he's probably going
to win did I say that that he's probably
gonna win no way did I say that
somewhere he's probably gonna run okay
uh who knows who will win but I think um
I feel like the incumbent Advantage is
so strong you're really gonna throw that
away like it's not like one or two times
in history in the US right where like
the non-income the parties put somebody
else up yeah I mean the the concern is
like the just the age and the the the
the mental decline just the
the wear and tear of the campaign all
that kind of stuff all the speech you
have to make the debates and all that
kind of stuff yeah so you see what
happens
what the least excited uh I mean two
years when I was a long time and his
current mental state yeah he could run
and do it he could do a passable job in
two years man I don't know I've seen
videos of Bill Clinton recently he's
looking pretty rough
um you know if Biden is looking a lot
more rough worse for wearing two years
then maybe they actually do have to dig
out another person uh for run ionas
foreign what do you think about Trump
when he won in 2016 I think is when you
came to fruition politically speaking so
what do you think has winning the 2016
election represents
so for me
Trump the end the reason why I got into
politics
um was Trump was like this new
epistemic force in American politics
that like you'd kind of have to like
flirt with facts before even if you
wanted to be non-factual he super didn't
care lying was like a first language to
him just like in speaking in terms of
like the the way that he used language
to just say to you what he felt like you
needed to hear to support him and not
care at all about what is going on about
yeah that that's that's what Trump
represented to me in terms of like
things that I cared about he also
represents a lot more obviously that
there was this undercurrent of American
opinion that a lot of people didn't know
still existed and it did he got elected
um that the Overton window was
misidentified by even a large amount of
the Republican party that populism was a
lot more popular than a lot of people
figured you know yeah there's a lot of
it I guess he representing do you think
Trump should have been banned from
Twitter
can make the case for and against it so
you're a big supporter for free speech
yeah so the case in favor of do you
think he should be brought back
as Elon yeah because if he gets brought
back it's a higher chance that I'll be
brought back so I'm supporting that all
the way thank you Elon unban my account
um
so because you called me weak spine I'm
gonna have to message Elon okay at Omni
Destiny it was a verified Twitter
account uh Omni Destiny yeah no I'm just
kidding why'd you get banned from
Twitter Destiny I don't know I'll add
that to Elon I saw that there was a
screenshot of you uh referring to the
rape of somebody okay that was on an
older Twitter account and that was a bad
tweet you have multiple Twitter accounts
so you're trying to
um go around the bands that you keep
getting okay hold on you're slandering
me a lot right now okay let's get the
facts straight okay I don't even
remember why my first Chicago banned but
it was a wild account I tweeted some
wildly inappropriate things you regret I
don't like that word I'm gonna give the
answer to most people get but it's like
I don't regret it because I learned a
lot so I'm glad I had the bad
experiences why don't you like the word
for good I think if we look at where we
are
how do you feel about determinism
uh I believe in hard the hardest of
determinism that's who I am okay so sure
who I am today is the culmination of
everything that's occurred in the past I
believe you speaking of Sergeant Trump
uh I believe in you speaking about
regret is a nice way to communicate that
in this deterministic world you've
analyzed the acts of the past and you're
no longer that person yeah of course for
sure that's what that's what regret
usually means okay thanks for giving me
the human explanation okay true so in
that sense there's a lot of things I've
done that I regret oh you're what are
you you're not human you're a bot NPC is
my preferred okay all right
I wish I would have been smart enough at
the time to not have to have had made
those mistakes okay there you go good
job um but yeah obviously really dumb
really crazy Off the Wall tweets
um but that account got bad but then I
made another account
called um I can't believe I'm giving you
a history my Twitter accounts but
another account called Omni Destiny it's
an honor um and that was my I got
verified I was cool they let me have
that account because originally
abandoned I said appeal and I was like
oh let me have one more and back then
Twitter was cool and they're like okay
go for it and that account lasted for a
long time and I don't actually know 100
why that account got banned
um I believe that the tweet that showed
up in the final I got banned for hate
speech and it was because I was there
was a picture that I tweeted with three
different alt writers that are kind of
like Neo-Nazi people and they were all
uh like mixed race people and I said
like the new alt-right looks like a
Disney Channel original movie in terms
of racial composition and somehow that
got flagged for instigating violence
against minorities I think and I think
that's a tweet that got me banned
because I think that's what showed up in
the final report but I don't know maybe
there were other reasons because nobody
ever communicates but ever since that
account went under it's just been
renovating ever since so
a ban evading ever since so all my new
accounts have around just get banned
because they finally figured out it's me
and then they benefit there's like one
dude at Twitter HQ who's like constantly
looking for my new accounts and they get
me yeah yeah anyway yeah so
post Trump World
um but do you think okay I mean this oh
should it be banned oh you asked me to
make both cases
um should he be banned I mean damn dude
when you're tweeting out [ __ ] that's
arguably leading stuff like January 6th
I can understand why because it's like
what else is this wild dude go to tweet
out like is he gonna start instigating
other violent events so I'm sympathetic
towards the like okay well he can't just
be here saying stuff like this that's
insane we're gonna ban him um
instigating yeah your Instagram
violence in the physical world yeah like
if I would have Tweet stuff like that I
would get banned probably on the flip
side this is the president of the United
States it seems like he's like doing
presidential decree by social media
sometimes like is it really right that
one public or private I should say one
private company can um
like erase the president of the United
States words from the eyes of a lot of
Americans that are using these social
media feeds
um and one big one which I for sure am
against is the permanent ban yeah I
don't like that I hate that even in my
community if somebody comes back every
like a year like I mean did you just
compare yourself to the president of the
United States I've not got myself to
Twitter Banning the president United
States let me put it this way if I ban
Donald Trump in my chat room I don't ban
him in a year
a year yeah what's the process for on
banning Donald Trump what would he have
to do usually people send me an email
they're like listen I did this stuff I'm
sorry I was dumb I'll give them another
chance but a year what if they send an
email a month later usually I'll learn
better that's actually my I banned
pretty quickly my community but if you
ever asked softy okay I usually let them
back yeah I'm very well because I used
to be the worst type of Internet person
and I think I'm a little bit better than
I used to be so not that you're older
yeah now that I've matured yeah of
course age bestows a wisdom that just
can't be gotten any other way what's
your sense in general is there something
interesting you could say about your
view on Free Speech it seems like one of
those terms it's also over overused to
mean a lot of different things what does
it mean to you if you have a democratic
style of governance you are interesting
people with one of the most awesome and
radical of responsibilities and that's
saying that you're going to pick the
people that are going to make some of
the hardest decisions in all of human
history if you're going to trust people
to vote correctly you have to be able to
trust them to have open and honest
dialogue with each other whether that's
Nazis or KKK people or whoever talking
you have to believe that your people are
going to be able to rise above and make
the correct determinations when they
hear these types of speeches and if
you're so worried that somebody's going
to hear a certain political figure and
they're going to be completely
radicalized instantly then what that
tells me is that you don't have enough
faith in humans for democracy to be a
viable institution which is fine you can
be anti-democratic but you I don't think
you can be pro-democracy and anti-free
speech within reason so what's the
within reason so I mean do not you can't
post like child porn or something on
Twitter where people try to get you on
that stuff or like direct calls to
violence are probably not you shouldn't
be tweeting out like we're gonna meet up
tomorrow go bomb blah blah blah so do
you think it's okay to allow racism and
anti-Semitism and hate speech
hate speech Yes because that's can be
very broadly defined
um I can understand there being some
basic rules of like no slurs on like a
platform that gets into like acceptable
forms of moderation or like excessive
harassment and bullying I can understand
um but past that when the when the
moderation becomes ideological I get a
little bit nervous because you know for
for there's a whole other yeah there's
uh of course it's all a gray area but
when it feels like ideology has seeped
into the censorship not good yeah which
it's so fascinating to think especially
now that Elon bought Twitter how did you
engineer A system that
prevents ideology from seeping in and
nevertheless is able to
create a platform that has healthy
conversations because if you have one
guy who's just screaming nonsense
non-stop it it has this effect where the
quiet voices at the back of the room are
silenced yeah so like that that's what
you usually don't talk about like if you
let one annoying loud person in that's
actually censoring the voice of a lot of
people that would like to speak but they
don't get a chance that's one of the
things especially around like trans
discourse I have to constantly do that
like reminder for my audiences of like
when I'm dealing with these types of
people on the internet a lot of them
might seem really crazy A lot of these
types of people might seem insane but
like in the real world outside of like
the crazy Twitter activist world like
the vast majority of people you're
meeting from LGBT communities are like
the coolest normalist people all they
want is to like write to live their life
and the way they want to and to be like
unobstructed and like yeah but people
will get this impression of like an
online activist like a vegan or LGBT
person or whatever and then they think
that every single person in real life is
like that and it's a really negative
stereotype and then even the other
people in that group oh is Maria coming
over oh yeah know that's her okay uh
Molina just joined us what were we
talking about was it interesting you
were saying that you were going to talk
to Elon about getting at Omni Destiny
the verified Twitter account on ban I
said that's so it sounds like a lot
that's so gracious of you I can't
believe you would do that for me and
then you admitted that you tried to
evade the ban multiple times which I'm
sure would be very uh looked upon you
know I heard that in Norway in their
prison system they don't actually punish
you for trying to escape jail because
that's like the natural human thing to
do hug you what do they I don't know if
they but they don't punish you because
of course you're trying to be free
that's all I'm trying to be on Twitter
I'm just trying to be free oh that's the
natural human yeah that's the natural
hair of course it's the benefit you're
not a destructive force you're just no
I'm a positive I'm a Force for good
that's why all my accounts only get
banned for bad new Vanishing I don't get
banned for doing bad things on a
progressive show I'm like far left I
love like Progressive classes this is
what you criticize Hassan for being
I show them from a place of first
principles not from a Mindless AI
echoing kind of thing you know okay see
your free thinking bot yeah exactly all
right cool uh well I'm sure we'll return
to some politics that was beautiful uh
Malia can you tell us about yourself you
also a fellow streamer
your story I stream and I started
streaming because I met him basically
kind of but I don't do the politics I do
like travels or talk about relationships
talk to my audience basically you're
from that part of the world right Sweden
yeah so did you escape from prison and
they didn't that was Norway that's
different I actually really I've been to
Sweden a bunch of times I love it
there's a tech sector there that's
really like flourishing where did you go
which city I went to Stockholm I think I
gave a few lectures there there's a
vibrant Tech sector it was cool and
people are super nice
yeah we're friendly we're not like very
deep like we don't really have much deep
conversation it's like a meta oh there's
not many intellectuals that come from
Sweden we don't really speak very highly
ourselves but kind of like just chill
all the time we don't make a scene we
don't we're just like there's a you know
do you know what the name for that is
there's a specific name for it yeah the
login yeah
yeah oh there's a philosophy behind it
when you're part of like Sweden or
Norway you like you don't talk too
highly of yourself because it's seen as
kind of like rude like think of like
America except the exact opposite you
don't even really want to like you don't
want to make yourself into a victim too
much you don't want to be too much of
anything you're just like sticking to
the to the group don't make a big scene
about yourself
but that said you came here and you were
you put yourself in front of the camera
and became a streamer do you understand
how weird that is for my friends in
Sweden I just didn't talk about myself
and just like make a big deal about
myself for hours every day was that like
terrifying did you have anxiety about
that no because I don't see them but
then I come back and I'm like oh
so what do you feel like when you're
actually streaming you feel like you're
just alone in a room
um one-on-one type thing no I see I see
Chad I'm thinking oh they're like little
fairies they're not really real they're
just like out there I don't know what
they look like I just see little names
and they're just cute colors you know
you're talking to little fairies inside
your hands is that how you feel about
chat they're demons for me they're
demons okay my annivers are they so is
Chad a source of stress or happiness
like is there no for me that's a source
of happiness I've been very intentional
with like the construction of my
community so I'm really happy with where
it's at how are you able to actually
have deep political discourse while
playing a video game at the same time I
have a really good chat room in terms of
like the way that people engage in
conversations like I was one of the
earliest people to embrace the
philosophy of like I am in total control
of what people watch me think that like
I have a high level of responsibility
for how they conduct themselves and then
if I conduct myself in a certain way I
can expect a certain level of conduct
from them and for the most part it's
like worked pretty well for the past you
know nine or ten years yeah what about
the actual playing of the game and
you're able to paralyze the brain like
oh like it seems like factorial seems
like a super complex game yeah I don't
actually think that's possible I don't
think multitasking for human brain is
possible
um if you see me playing a game usually
what's happening is the conversation is
like I've had it a million times so I'm
not thinking about it I've automated
that or if the conversation is very
challenging
um then if you watch me if you really
watch what's happening again I'm
probably just running around in circles
because I have to think about the
conversation okay because with factorial
it looks like a lot of stuff is going on
sometimes yeah so like it's hard for uh
a person who hasn't played the game to
detect that you're not actually love is
like you're super intelligent can
multitask or does it come off as like
he's not interested in this conversation
at all yeah yeah there's a coolness to
it like when you're not paying attention
like
if if you're looking elsewhere like
you're checking your phone you're too
cool for this conversation there's a
sense like that yeah the reality is
though is if you watch it was easier to
see in Minecraft because in Minecraft
when there was a challenging
conversation if you watch me play I'm
literally just running around and
jumping in circles because I have to
think about the conversation 100 I can't
do a complicated task and think about
the conversation or like that people
always joke in my chat like oh no the
notepad came out if it's a really
challenging conversation I'll get rid of
the game and I'll bring out a notepad
and I'll start writing stuff down to
keep track of what's going on yeah so
what kind of stuff do you stream so
advice you talk about yeah like either I
talk to chat or I travel around
basically like could have a
conversations or we like
um go to countries I've been to like
Italy I was gonna live like one and a
half months just like traveling around
alone going to cities like having like
my camera with me and like streaming for
hours where's the where's the coolest
place you've been to ever it's probably
New Zealand New Zealand I think so yeah
after it's probably going to be Italy I
think because they're like history and
also both history because New Zealand is
also been beautiful it does both natural
beauty and historical Beauty yeah yeah
for sure I think I just really like the
like the Polynesian sort of culture I
think is very interesting like the ocean
people and it's just really beautiful
people are very relaxed chill they're
very far away which is interesting as
well because whenever they talk about
politics or they talk about
um just like the world it feels really
far away
so where is home for you is Austin home
yeah we travel we've lived in a lot of
different places and traveled around
yeah so that's what you think of home is
like I think so yeah I mean if if
they're gonna be a place it's probably
gonna be like my childhood places
probably yeah like my old country house
or something like that we don't have it
anymore but like that's that's like home
for me I guess so how'd you guys meet
each other
you're currently married yes to each
other yeah yeah to each other yeah
all right cool how'd you guys meet I was
watching his YouTube stuff like 2018 I
think like because it was the Swedish
election around that time and I was
interested in politics and then
um I think he said in one of his videos
that he had an Instagram and that he
needed people to stop dming him that
wasn't Cutie Pie's and then I messaged
him and said am I a cutie pie and the
Europe pie in like two minutes
and then that that's when I was in New
Zealand
and I guess you wanted to escape America
or like your life for a little bit and
um where were you mentally there look
because we've talked to this timeline
where it's 2018. was it 1819 where is
the low point
or says that was way early low Point
carpet cleaning that was like two
thousand uh 2010. oh okay 2018 was
probably your Peak what do you like now
is my Peak what do you mean that was my
pick why would you say that no nobody
ever admits being past their Prime just
just well I mean my promise okay it was
around it was probably around the time
where you were getting a lot of lefties
through your community and you were
really like thinking about that they
would go too far maybe that was I think
that was still when Hassan and vosh were
both in my community exactly so I would
say if it feels like there was not
really like much issues when it comes to
like to your stuff or like your work
stuff back then oh suddenly we didn't
talk about is it like um there were no
Politics on Twitch I exclusively
inhabited that place for like two years
because nobody else did it because it
was a really toxic environment for
politics so for a couple of years as it
grew like the I kind of grew the whole
Space because it wasn't nobody was doing
it yet what did that look like you're
having
like political debates political
discourse yeah mainly like going into
YouTube people to try to argue with them
or just doing Politics on stream like
reading stories researching stuff
talking about stuff but there's not like
other people on Twitch to debate about
politics because there was no politics
it was yeah was there a debate in the
space of Communism socialism social
Democrats kind of like this are you
trying to outline your own position
during that time I think it was mainly
me fighting against conservatives
because it was like Trump stuff and then
it was coming off the back of like there
was this movie called gamergate and
there was all this anti-sjw stuff on the
internet and I was like the sjw like the
progressor that was fighting on the
Progressive side of things so I think
that's what I was known for but I was
fighting with people off of twitch
because on Twitch there weren't very
many political discussions happening so
you were holding the sjw flag yeah uh to
what to what degree do you still hold it
like what's the best what's the Steel
Man case for sjw I mean like I'm still
very much that sjw from 2018 2019 but
the positions have moved so much farther
left that I don't know some people may
not call me that anymore I'm not sure it
depends on who I'm talking to because
basically what is a social justice worry
like being sensitive to the experience
of others yeah being sensitive and
empathetic towards the experience of
others and then trying to build a better
world that like suits as many different
types of people as possible while being
like aware of like their names okay
uh so you guys might from your
perspective is that does she she is she
telling lies is it accurate No it's
pretty accurate okay when did you guys
actually meet I flew out in 2019 like in
February yeah basically there was like
weird stuff happening in La I just come
off of kind of a weird not kind of sort
of relationship and I just wanted to
like go away for a while another company
reached out to me and they had like a
fun streaming device and they said
they'd sponsor a trip if I went
somewhere and I was like oh well I know
this person I know a couple people in
New Zealand I'm only it was one of them
it's like I'll go to New Zealand New
Zealand it'll be fun and uh yeah I did
that for two weeks do you guys believe
in love
hey
I feel like you're you lack the gotcha
got us into this I'm not sure to
disagree to what you have human emotions
I have quite a few okay
from your perspective when did you when
did you fall in love with Millions
the minute I saw her
um I don't know we our first two weeks
together were a lot of fun we had a lot
of chemistry in person
um I was kind of shocked that I wasn't
thinking about it because it was like we
spent like a week together and you said
I really want to tell you something and
you realize I don't remember you were
like stalling that for the longest time
I think she was oh he said that like I
love you no he basically just said like
I really like you and it never really
happens that's what he said and I was
like No And I thought hey I thought
so let's tell Ryan uh we said Trump
getting banned from Twitter is that what
we were talking about before oh yeah hey
you agree with me coming on here of
course I'm gonna be doing this how long
so how long did that take two weeks you
said Well that took like a week no I
don't know I think it was just like the
thing is my mind process is like
information so quickly two weeks to
somebody like you is actually like years
for me so oh like me yeah so there was
like a lot of like factorial type of
strategic thinking yeah going on I was
seeing like all the events like Doctor
Strange or whatever and the Avengers
when he's like singing to All the future
you saw me you just saw the future yeah
yeah you're doing like some game
theoretic simulation of all the possible
outcomes exactly okay
um but no yeah it was probably pretty
soon I realized that we had a lot of
chemistry yeah I think before I left
after my two weeks there I was like we
need to make sure you get like a ticket
to come visit me in the United States
because it'll be fun and everything and
then yeah I kind of decided that last
minute too it was like really like five
hours before your flight back we kind of
realized because because it was kind of
like men is just like a one-time thing
and then that was it they were like oh
no this is a lot of fun we should
probably hang out again oh so you
realized you would miss each other yeah
yeah
The Melancholy side of Love okay when
did you fall in love with dude I thought
he like hated me I don't know I thought
not hated me she still thinks I hate it
but no no I I remember like what he said
that he really liked me I was kind of a
little shocked about that because I I
don't know there was a lot of like
random things happening in New Zealand
it was a lot of fun but it was
definitely like very interesting like
things that happened
um because I I was like around a lot of
other people as well so I thought he
might have had like a really bad time
um but when he said that I was thinking
about it more and then we spent like
more time together like a week after
that and then it felt like that was more
like real and I think when he was about
to leave I kind of realized like no I
really like him did you guys ever say
love to each other like I love you yeah
of course yeah okay all right
I wasn't sure why would you ask that
what has you said before because I
haven't I haven't I don't think I've
heard you speak the only time I've heard
Stephen talk about love is when you're
like criticizing the the red pill
Community saying they don't ever talk
about love and relationships almost all
the time I'm giving criticism to people
like I said I'm kind of stepping in I'm
very disconnected from my own emotional
experience because I'm trying to talk
with him there so it's pretty rare that
I'll talk about what is your own
emotional experience exactly highly
blunted I guess there's a lot okay what
does that mean uh I mean what's the
what's deep in there I are you is this
just who you are genetically or are you
running from something
I think I have a pretty good
understanding myself a lot of people
make that accusation to me but I don't
think I am okay this is just who you are
that's just who I am yeah okay there's
not childhood stuff like drama uh it's
all sorted done
you figured it all out yeah in your old
age as I grow every year I figure out
more and more he did mention I think I
heard this somewhere that this is a
source of fights for the two of you the
H thing I felt the ageism throughout
this whole conversation
um he's basically he's saying that he
gambles like with time he's just like I
think she will be good later and then
just like it's like an investment yeah
yeah that's like what he's doing when
this treasury bond matures I'm gonna be
able to capture what do you think so far
is the stocks going up or
um it's tumultuous
it's like Bitcoins yeah I like Bitcoin
crypto Mill all right if you guys don't
mind one interesting aspect of your
relationship is you're in an open
relationship what's that like from a
game theoretic simulation perspective
what went into that calculation and like
how does that like how that started or
how did that started sure um the only
relationships I've ever done has been
open relationships since I was like in
high school because I didn't really
understand like why wouldn't you be able
to like do other things with other
people but then just like have your main
partner basically so what what is an
open relationship generally speaking
that means you have one main partner not
a monogamous relationship like you're
somehow allowed like in different ways
um you can see other people sexually
sexually but like there is one main
okay or it doesn't have to be that for
some people but like I think it's
probably easier and we probably don't
really have time or the energy for like
more than like one person to like really
like what about like emotional
it's really complicated there's a lot of
complicated stuff going on under the
hood there yeah
um I think broadly speaking you've got
like polyamorous relationships and
you've got like open relationships where
polyamorous is like oh I've got like
three different girlfriends and we all
hang out or sometimes even live together
or three boyfriends whatever and then
you've got like open relationships which
is like oh you know like you can
basically hook up with other people and
then you've got like your main
relationship and that's it I think ours
is probably somewhere in the middle of
that um to where like we've got like
long-term friends some of them we hook
up with and that's kind of how we yeah
it's a delicate dance that uh explodes
every six months on itself if it doesn't
explode you guys fight over it we fight
over some things yeah
I think it's mostly because a lot of
people can't handle it and they they
agree to something and then they realize
that they're way too cool and then they
get really obsessed and they think that
they can like get in there and then it
gets really dramatic have you figured it
out like I feel like we figure out
things more and more like when it comes
to like what's a good person for us to
hang out and what's not a good person
for us to hang out with or like I
probably have more opinions on like who
he hangs out with because he likes the
[ __ ] psychos yeah so you you like the
song you like the not like The Crazy
Ones like the baby trap sort of women
that's the that's the ones and I don't
remember that because that affects me
that affects your game theoretically
yeah right uh you like to surround
yourself like in general you've talked
about with crazy people
I say crazy and I really shouldn't it's
a humorous way it's like yeah they're
very unstable very can be unstable but
people that are very unique like when I
meet this person that's like not boring
yeah not boring yeah and you said that
you're progressively becoming not boring
yourself no I think I'm pretty stable I
don't let them affect me much but so you
don't think they affect your no if I've
said that I've said a joke I think I've
like I've got my stuff like really well
figured out it's what allows me to
engage with people like this so easily
because I can engage I can make them
feel seen and heard and then if it gets
insane I can cut off and I can be chill
like very few things affect me in the
long term you guys experience jealousy
usually like whenever I feel like he's
not spending the like the amount of time
that I'm asking for and he spends it on
his video games or his stream or like he
sees someone else like more than he sees
me or something like that that would
like not be good because then it affects
like our relationship do you have a good
sense of like is it literally time or is
it the energy put into the it's probably
like if like if he's with me that like
the attention in the time like when he
hangs out with me and then there's also
probably at a time so if I feel like
something else is distracting too much
like it could be work or it could be a
friend or it could be anything like if I
feel like it starts to take away from
like me then I'm having an issue with it
I don't think he really cares much I
guess the only jealousy you experience
is probably when you feel like
um
like if I get upset about him seeing
someone too much and then I go see
someone more and then he's like why
can't I go see my friend more like as
much as you so like that's the sort of
like thing that we're trying to navigate
on I guess
I think we uh we we are like
diametrically opposed sometimes in terms
of how we view like engagement with
people or engagement with the world
sometimes so like on her end of the
spectrum like a perfect week for her
might be like being in a cabin
watching like fireflies at night going
hiking every morning going swimming at
the beach because it's like you're
taking in like the Grandeur of nature
you're like connected with yourself
you're like very at peace everything is
like chill and cool there's the wind the
feeling of nature everything that's like
her Peak living experience I like being
present yeah and like my Peak
experiences are like people trying to
destroy my life like the challenge of
like navigating a really complicated
discussion
um like you know several different
dramatic offense unfolding that my in my
career like these things are like very I
like the stress and the action and the
entertainment and everything's like very
cool for me someone we're together she
generally wants me to be like more chill
but if I don't feel like I'm being like
stimulated a lot then it's easy for like
my mind to wander somewhere else or yeah
that's kind of the issue yeah we have a
very different way of like engaging with
them so how can you find
happiness and Stillness I feel like if
you're just like aware of it and we're
trying our best like whenever we like
we're supposed to do this one thing so
let's say that we want to go to New York
and I'm like we should just like go out
and do this one specific thing we try to
find something that he enjoys doing like
um now that we're in Texas we can go
shooting or do something fun that he
enjoys then we can do it
um and then I think like
just like for me also to be aware
um that like when he spends a lot of
time on crazy people it's not because he
like loves them or wants to be with them
it's just because he likes being like
having having his life destroyed like
you said which I don't really do this is
a completely different thing so like for
me to like understand more like how he's
thinking because it's so different from
mine and for him to understand how I'm
thinking about things and like what I
prioritize in my life I think that's
like how we navigate but I think it's
good I think the differences can be good
like when we're finding a way yeah well
I think you're you're relatable
like I always tell people that like if
you're dating me for like more than a
few years like you get like a an award
like a war zone that you've survived
absolutely you're like a veteran you get
a medals and stuff and it's always like
I think there's probably been like six
different I don't think she says it
anymore but they're like six different
times in our relationship where she's
like is it always like this is this
extra yeah and like every next year
isn't the beginning of about like you
were lying about that yeah you were not
you were like no it's just like right
now I'm having a huge argument online
about seeing the n-word in private and
it's just gonna be like this and I'm
gonna be streaming 24 hours a day and
I'm like we're like when are you gonna
come to bed it's been a week
I did playing League come into into this
uh I'm clean of League like six months
right now yeah what what do you uh hate
about legal aid I never humans
well speaking of which I my
participation in League involved on the
robot side good because I think that's
an improvement because uh uh both with
Starcraft 2 and and uh League of Legends
because open Ai and deepmind uh both
participating in creating bots and those
I was a professional speaker of two
players so I remember when the AI
started to play it's interesting the
types of restrictions that you would
have to put on like a gaming robot to
make it like functional and not totally
unfair to the other side yeah to make a
human-like yeah was that interesting to
you to see AI be able to play those
video games I think in some ways people
think things are more complicated than
they actually are and I think video
games is one of those things where
really oh my God there's like a million
possibilities at every second and who
knows and it's like no there's like
three or four things going at any point
in time and I'm willing to bet that like
an AI could probably solve some of these
games like pretty easily
um especially if there are no
constraints on how they can learn yeah
can I talk to you about relationships
yeah we already have so yeah I know but
more generally speaking we didn't get a
chance to talk about the the red pill
Community well first of all what is the
replica Community the manosphere in
general I'd love to get both of your
opinions on this sure
I I know I know you're probably not as
opinionated on that phone what do you
think I am that like probably not as you
like as much as you but I I do have
opinions yeah you do okay I usually
don't like speak out too much on it
because I feel like there's like a
language barrier I that's why I don't
really do politics because this is my
second language yeah that's right you
have to know the a little bit like you
know how to use you have to use
derogatory terms every other sentence
yeah so they understand you right
exactly yeah
I need like a good like you need to be
able to like speak really well for
people to take your seriously I think
and like that's the thing like if I if I
don't have like the words and I don't
have the like I can't pronounce things
correctly yeah I'm searching for words
like stupid essentially that's how
people view it yeah tell me about it I
have a podcast people listen to and I
mumble and they yeah wait is here what's
your first language Russian oh okay but
I speak both languages horribly I'm just
not
I'm not like there's definitely a big
disconnect between my brain and my mouth
module like I'm not able to generate the
thoughts efficiently like the things
you're able to do like speak like that
I'm not
it's very very tough plus there's a huge
amount of anxiety and social interaction
that I have which makes speaking even
harder
yeah yeah yeah it's tough I understand
gotcha okay it makes sense yeah the the
gotcha is both uh a symbol of compassion
and derision at once I'm just letting
you know I understand what you're saying
I'm just gonna sit there and stare at
you confirm no you have to say like yeah
get it like yeah yeah I get it yeah
no it's so it's so short I got you say
say a longer sentence but that means the
same thing I understand you yeah that's
good that's like not chills you know you
get chills yeah you understand me yeah
it feels good yeah I hear you I hear you
and like if you just like hold the other
person's hand that's even better you
gotta put in some emotion there okay
show that you have some
what do you think about it gotcha what
do you think about red pill uh what what
uh sorry what what is it first of all
for people I don't know yeah the red
pill Community obviously it's the Matrix
reference the red pill that you take is
when you realize what dating standards
and Norms really are in the world that
men are providers and have to become
some great thing to hunt and attract you
know the woman who are just kind of
there floating around looking for people
to give them the most resources and it's
like coming to a realization of what the
world of dating really is broken away
from the Hollywood standards and the
romantic stuff that they try to sell you
and you know stories so there was kind
of maybe you can kind of educate me on
this but red pill used to be associated
with
just um
maybe anti-establishment views I don't
know uh maybe maybe a republican
conservative Viewpoint people yeah right
yeah they use red pill a lot in like
different communities like when you say
the red pill Community yeah that usually
means dating the dating thing but a lot
of people say oh Trump voters the red
pill are you Red pilled on like politics
whatever people say stuff like that yeah
okay cool and then there's like the
manosphere that's all the similar type
of stuff and Andrew Tate is somebody
that represents kind of the figurehead
of the manosphere of like the red pill
stuff yeah I would say so I'm pretty
sure yeah okay all right cool so uh what
are some ideas that they represent and
what do you think about them I think
they do a good job at speaking to
disaffected young men who feel like the
rest of the world has kind of left them
behind or isn't willing to speak to them
and they do Identify some true and real
problems feels like on the left we have
a really hard time doing like
self-improvement or telling people how
to better themselves we focus too much
on like structural or systemic issues
rather than what can an individual do to
uplift or Empower themselves and it also
feels like they do a good job at
speaking to some of the positive aspects
of masculinity that it's okay to be like
strong and brave and a soldier and a
warrior and provide for your family and
blah blah blah
um types of like those are like positive
messages like self-improvement and
everything that come from the red pill
Community what's the negative
I think the analysis on how men and
women interact is a way to transactional
all of like the Romanticism and love and
chemistry has totally sucked out of it
everything is very like sex based like
how do you basically have sex with the
most amount of women possible and that's
going to make you happy
um and then I think people's motivation
sometimes are just spoken about in such
a shallow derogatory way that I don't
think is always reflective of reality
like a woman only wants you because you
make six figures and you're tall and a
guy only wants you because he wants to
have sex with you like it feels like
there's a lot of that going on a lot
yeah and that misses some fundamental
aspect about relationships yeah about
meaningful relationships and so on I
don't think I've never heard red pill
people ever ever talk about like
meaningful relationships it's always
just how to get in one or how to have
sex really
malware bothers you about some of that
philosophy I feel like people that are
like are like pill people I feel like
their solution is something that
they work out
like where it work out it works out for
some people people that makes a lot of
money is like really successful in that
sort of way but it's not going to help
most men out there so I feel like it's
just like a pointless like speech to
give to these like really lost guys and
they really do believe that they can
like they can become successful they can
uh get money and like and when they get
all these things they can get girls but
most of them is not gonna achieve that
ever to get the money part or become
successful just become a billionaire you
know like and you'll get all the girls
and which is true but not everyone can
do that so I feel like when these guys
are speaking to these men and there's
like we just care about these men out
there you know they need to hear this it
doesn't really help a lot of them and it
doesn't
um Inspire them to develop compassion
toes the opposite sex which is probably
something required to have that is for a
relationship and also like they they
seem to complain a lot about women
um like only wanting men that have money
and that's tall and that's muscular
whatever you know all those things
um and but they complain about that but
that's like also kind of what they're
trying to
make the men try to do for themselves so
they kind of like fall into the same
sort of behavior and it seems like
they're kind of unaware of that as well
um they're just playing a part of the
game instead of trying to find a woman
that doesn't look for those things and
that are looking for
not those things yeah I actually would
love to have like straight up data
on
people in that world versus not in that
world how often they get laid Yeah like
literally so
I think for sure people in that world
have fewer meaningful long-term
relationships that are fulfilling they
actually help them succeed in life that
help them be happy and content and all
that kind of stuff but just even the
straight up the the shallow goal of
getting laid
I wonder because it's very possible that
like just the the roughness with which
they uh treat intellectually women that
might lead to lower success not higher
success it's very adversarial which I
think is always disappointing anything
that talks about men and women I think
it's good to acknowledge differences but
when it becomes like adversarial
especially when you talk about sex sex
is something that men are getting and
it's something that women are giving and
that type of like trade-off and the way
they talk about it is like yeah it sets
people against each other in a really
toxic way I think
how do you talk to people from that
world from the red pill world like would
you would you ever talk to like somebody
like Andrew Tate oh yeah if I had a
chance to I've been on the uh fresh and
fit podcast three times and then I've
got a friend sneako who's like very red
pill that stuff um
if I'm trying to talk to them usually
the um it's kind of like approaching it
like a scared cat the first thing you
have to do is like be very gentle and
say like I understand your issues I
understand your complaints I know that
you're I'm scary because you think I'm
gonna say like toxic masculinity and
feminism and all these scary words at
you so the first thing is always to
recognize it like a lot of what they
talk about there are like true aspects
to what they're talking about that
people on the left won't recognize so I
think it's good to acknowledge those
things that like men and women are kind
of different we do look for different
things in general when it comes to
relationships it's okay to say that it's
not there's nothing bad there and then
it'll usually be like once I've got your
trust and I'm in your bubble like let's
talk about the things that you want and
maybe like some of the strategies that
you're employing aren't necessarily
going to get you some of the things that
you want so for instance if you're
really worried about like shallow girls
like ruining your life like Molina said
um it's probably not best to build your
entire world view around trying to get
shallow girls that are going to ruin
your life like if your way of attracting
a girl is to go to the gym get a whole
bunch of money and try to like flaunt
your wealth as much as possible you're
going to be attracting the very same
type of women that you're here like
decrying on your stream you think we've
talked about that on the boat because
like you probably want to have a woman
that's going to be there if you lose
your job if it's still there length that
cares about the things that's not just
your job yeah
um it's more stable and also I don't
help you become a great man
uh great like grow like I feel like a
great friendship and a partnership like
it helps you make you a better person
some of the most successful people I
know I mean they have families and
there's clearly a dynamic there that's
like that makes them they wouldn't be
that without they're not an island yeah
yeah and uh the kids actually a big part
of that too like for most people if
you're like a good parent they make you
step up somehow in life you have to take
responsibility for getting your [ __ ]
together and excelling in ways that uh
I guess the philosophy of the Red Bull
does not quite get to that's always an
interesting I think I've asked that a
couple times where it's like would you
let your daughter date Andrew Tate and
it's always funny to watch them kind of
like squirm around those answers
sometimes but see if they if they don't
have a daughter like I you know I don't
have a daughter I think your whole
philosophy changes once you have a
daughter sure like they can they know
that what they're answering they feel a
little bit weird about it it's funny to
watch them like they even they know it's
like ah [ __ ] you know well they they
might say like I I want my daughter to
date like a high value male
to the degree that he's a high value
male yes but like I don't think you'll
feel that way the definition of high
value change is completely certainly the
stereotypical
measures the value contribute to the
calculation but it's so much more than
that I think on the chemistry of the
whole thing is is bigger uh you've also
mentioned about body count you guys both
have a high body count his body count
matter or depends like like you said
it's low in some people's eyes it's high
in other people's eyes does body count
matter in relationships it's the past
matter yeah well the past matters I
don't think body count not to me I don't
really care not just as it is no yeah
I mean the past does yeah well the past
is who you are right like somebody tells
me like they have a 200 body count and
they're 16. something's probably going
on there that's not good I was thinking
about that you're like because it could
be like really young people that are
having some sort of like mental yeah
it's going on or somebody's like yeah 45
and they've like never had sex before
there's probably something going on
right so I could be indicative but if
somebody's like in their 20s and they've
had sex with you know 100 people or 50
people whatever it's you know whatever
there's more experience which can be
good sure okay so that that just
represents you're like sexually open and
so it doesn't really necessarily mean
any kind of not necessarily it could
though the number alone doesn't mean
anything yeah okay well you could meet a
guy that's like I just really really
like Wanna [ __ ] a lot of people because
it makes me so cool like okay you can be
someone like that which is like the body
count doesn't matter but like where it
comes from like yeah like why why have
you slept with the people you slept with
yes does it hurt like the Romantic
aspect the relationship knowing that
there's a lot of people in the past I
don't know not for us no is it part of
the relationship fundamentally romantic
for us yeah I understand okay
what you come up with such a cold person
no I was just in my head thinking and I
wanted to just say gotcha right there
it's so judgmental I think when it comes
to the sex thing there's always like the
way that I explain it is and I
understand like
um I have to say this because I don't
advocate for what I do for everybody or
what she does for everybody because
obviously there's a whole bunch of
natural feelings of jealousy that pop up
for a lot of people but when people ask
me you know it's always like oh like
isn't this like horrible that you guys
are doing this and you don't love each
other from my perspective I can have sex
with like any person and it can be sex
like that's not like a special thing
between two people in my eyes it's like
anybody can have sex but there are like
certain activities and ways you can
spend time with each other where you're
like carving out these like precious
little moments in time with a certain
person that can do things that are
special to that person and those are the
kind of like events that I remember more
than anything else so like the idea of
like like oh wow I had sex with a person
that was so special doesn't mean as much
as like you know us traveling to like
New Zealand or sharing some special
moment doing like some really fun
activity or event or whatever that's
usually how I like it I am so a shared
intimate moment yeah I kind of agree but
I can definitely connect the romance
with sex boring I'm curious if she's a
woman say that's where the red pill is
right
that's exactly we've also talked about
misogyny which is you're clearly the
embodiment of that what were you saying
so there's some there's a connection
between romance and yeah I think it is
because I think sex could be a lot of
things right
it's it's some sort of bonding I'd say
in some way they say that you really
like BDSM you kind of like you become
submissive to someone or you take
control over someone it's like in a very
bonding like intimate moment I'd say and
that's romantic the intimacy is amazing
I I think it is if you can show yourself
as really submissive or like weak when
you have like absolutely no control over
yourself and you let someone else do it
or you are the one being that like you
are the dominant for someone I think
that's a really like intimate thing
because you show like the weakest Part
of Yourself kind of I just feel like I
personally
to me some component romantic but to me
this is not judging to others to Me
Maybe it's how I was brought up
the romance increases if the number of
intimate interactions are limited to one
person
like for me for some reason
spreading it out
decreases like
um exponentially the the feeling of
romance you feel or that I don't know
what that could be just like sort of
having grown up in the Soviet Union
there's a kind of there's the fairy tale
stories and you're kind of maybe living
through them
yeah I mean I think what you're saying
is like really normal like most people
probably feel that way yeah but but
because you guys are able to
successfully not do that I just want to
question my own understanding of it you
know like like why is that why is that
why am I being very
um jealous for no reason like maybe you
can maximize the number of intimate
experiences if you just open up and let
go of the jealousy essentially I think I
feel like in Sweden like in Scandinavia
we're extremely just sexually open like
in general we we're not like super
religious either we're very like relaxed
we don't like we don't feel bad about
ourselves like it's just like a
different sort of thing and I would say
like it's we're more Progressive when it
comes to feminism and stuff so it's more
common they will meet women with a
higher body count than like when I meet
like American Girls all of them I have
like vaginous smell like super
suppressed like sexually and yeah like
what did you just use they have like
issues to like they can't relax during
sex so it just hurts for them
isn't that what it's called yeah
um so like I meet so many girls that are
having like a lot of issues with sex and
they have like a very low body count
because they just can't relax or they
yeah and it's probably and usually they
come from like a very religious
background
um so they have just been told like you
cannot wear that you cannot be like that
you can't like you know and like where I
grew up it was not like that at all but
you see it as more like a casual thing
so then you can just maximize
the awesomeness of the experience yeah I
guess
exactly and I think the important thing
I think for everybody to realize is
there's always pros and cons to
everything like my lifestyle like
obviously I get to have a lot of fun
experiences that's like a huge Pro and
that's super cool and if you're like a
more monogamy brained person you're not
going to get those experiences but if
you're a monogamy brain person like when
you're sharing that special moment of
time with somebody else like that moment
can be really really really special
because now it's the thing that you're
showing yourself and opening yourself up
to another person and they're only
trusting you to do that and that's like
a really special thing that only the two
of you are sharing with each other so I
mean like there's always like pros and
cons to everything like I think we both
would say like like doing an open
relationship is probably not like we
would not recommend it yeah I don't
think we would no
yeah recently fasted for three days and
I ate a chicken breast at the end of
that and it was like the most delicious
food I've ever eaten so like there's
some aspect of fasting and scarcity and
so on that like you have to figure out
what for your own psyche what works the
best it's good to be a little bored or
like not do something or like work
because you can just enjoy the time when
you're doing something really fun it's
more fun otherwise you're just gonna get
numb in general with everything yeah
yeah I personally just never get bored
like I guess the boring thing is
exciting to me the just like you're like
me because everything I like is boring I
gotta ask you we talked about massaging
in the in the he's trying to battle it
out on the internet what's what's your
what's your sense as a woman
but the level of massaging and the
internet and the streaming community and
how to fight it
for me because I get I guess I get it
every single day somehow like because I
haven't online like I have a chat that
goes that's live right and um but I have
like mods moderating that all the time
so I don't really need to see much of it
I think it's just pretty annoying
because you get to like see it all the
time
um and become like background noise
yeah a little bit and it's like the same
Commons over and over again but it's
usually for me I don't personally care
that much I understand that other people
do especially when it comes into like
when there's like a lot of sexism and
stuff and um when there's a lot of like
men not taking women seriously like I
definitely get that and I used to get
that even more like a few years ago uh
with my accent and everything and like I
used to be blonde as well like a few
months ago so I feel like people
wouldn't take me seriously because of
that uh that's a bit annoying but I I
feel like it's pretty easy to like see
through when someone acts that way and
for me personally I don't really care
but
um it's a bit annoying like being online
and like getting stuff every single day
uh I would say like the probably the
worst thing is
when you feel like you put in a lot of
effort into some sort of work everyone
is just going to say you just got that
because you're a woman and you're
attractive and that's that's probably
like the worst thing is there a way to
fight that you think yeah I don't think
you can I think it just comes up all the
time I just like it is what it is I
guess you just gotta keep doing whatever
you do and like not let it like
emotionally control you somehow I think
having more women in those spaces is
always good it's probably good yeah like
a lot of the guys you can tell online
don't bring on the worst ones then stuff
she just did it she did the misogyny
Thing by having some bad women on she's
saying all women see you well you you
know it's true
right simply I disagree with you and I'm
older than both of you and therefore
wiser right so okay bye and we're older
than I think
yeah we've got combined age or it could
be it could be the same thing as like
also the age thing in like the woman
thing a lot of people think that I'm
just copying every single thing that he
says which I think has been annoying as
well so I can never really like a sonic
character of that one yeah which has a
bit annoying too much you know uh it was
about the defunding police
and love and respect which you uh both
have had for a time and have lost in I
would like you to regain it let's try to
increase not decrease the amount of love
in the space what do you think about
some of the harshness of this of his
language which we talked about
uh our word in the past when he used
n-word
all that kind of stuff what are you used
to do I mean no like what do you think
about it like do you give them advice to
not speak a certain way no like a little
more civility I was just trying to get a
second opinion on this second opinion
about army people not internet people
are way more extreme than yeah
no that's not true okay so okay so
here's thing for me okay I was not
online until three years ago at all like
I would watch YouTube that's pretty much
all I would do I wouldn't do anything
else really I didn't grew up playing
video games or anything so I'm like
extremely new to everything
um so when I came into this world and I
started seeing clips from him in the
past I don't think I really had much of
an opinion because it just sounded like
it was just a different like words that
we're using but it didn't mean anything
that's what it feels it was just like if
you're saying the r word it's because
you just want to call someone stupid but
you want to like do it a little bit more
like but it's not like it didn't feel
like it was like a it's not like racist
more like you know it's not agreement on
this side here all right so like if he
was saying the f word because it was
just like a word to like insult someone
and he was like I don't think he was
ever I don't think he were ever
homophobic back in the day or anything
like that but I think it was just like a
way to express yourself maybe back then
I don't know I didn't do it there's no
videos of me or anything because I
wasn't even online back then but yeah so
my case was I I definitely don't think
Stephen is homophobic or race or any of
those obviously so there's a good heart
there and a good mind I was just saying
he just likes being mean I think well
there is some you lose yourself and
forget the bigger picture that he's
pushing for more effective discourse on
the internet he's like an inspiration to
a lot of people especially now of like
how you can use effective conversation
to make for better world to radicalize
people and so on and then you lose some
of that power
by losing yourself
in in like the language just more
language of emotion versus effective
communication but it's a gray area I
would say like something that is
probably recently done in that case
because it's been joking about women a
lot like it's women's fault they're bad
like it's just it's been like a lot of
jokes when it comes to misogyny I guess
in your community and I think it's
actually turned people a little bit that
way that's why we've done the research
yes so that's I guess that's actually
true because I don't think it was pretty
I don't think it was clear enough I
don't think it actually was I think you
did that mistake
um but I think back then I was even
saying like hey you should probably not
like you should probably you probably
should not do that
because it actually is pretty hard for
me because whenever I come into His
commuter like his chat people are just
gonna spam it's like a woman moment it's
a woman moment whenever I say something
and it's kind of like yeah it's getting
pretty annoying as I said it's just
annoying when you see it every single
day and there you go uh wisdom from
somebody younger than you wisdom can
come from all kinds of people yeah of
course just sometimes it's very limited
quantities
and learn something from anybody what
advice would you give to uh young people
the both of you
that you have both audiences where young
people look up to you in general if you
were to give advice to somebody in high
school like how to
create a life they can be proud of what
would you say
the most important thing that I've
learned is to view people as different
and not better or worse and when UV
people is different instead of better or
worse you learn that there's almost
something that you can learn from
anybody uh like being open and
empathetic towards other people's
experiences nobody does anything by
random Choice like there's always
reasons why people act the way they do
and as long as you're willing to kind of
like be open and receptive to the lived
experiences of other people you're going
to be able to gather information and
create like a more cohesive and better
view of the world than any of your peers
will
do you have any kind of advice you can
give to Young Folks
I have something that I see especially
in America a lot is that a lot of people
kind of get told what to do early on
like in high school they're supposed to
become this thing uh like education wise
like they're supposed to like become a
doctor or this thing or whatever and
then they kind of just like give up on
things that they're actually passionate
about so I think a lot of teenagers get
really confused they get an education
and then they get that job and they hate
everything and they think that when
they're when they're reaching the job
when they're reaching like the journey
they're going to get happy that's like
where the happiness is going to be but
then when they get to there they just
hate everything and then they go become
really depressed and I've seen this so
much like I've seen this all the time
and it's it's pretty sad to me to see so
many people that are just wasting time
and then they just get really confused
and I don't know it's the same thing
with relationships too no one really
knows what they want anymore I feel like
everyone is just kind of doing whatever
like Society is saying or the parents
are saying or their friends are saying
um they're never really doing anything
that's super meaningful anymore and like
they don't so what I would say is like
try to find something that are that's
that is important to you it could be
anything really like some sort of
passion maybe like your friends maybe
like like what matters to you like
figuring those things out I think is
really important and that comes from
being able to listen to like some inner
voice it's just not gonna come from
elsewhere it's really hard because
you're living the life and like there's
things happening around you and people
tell you what to do and what not to do
and you know no one really has like
their own opinions everyone is just kind
of like listening to the the cooler
thing or you know except even if he
seems to stand on his own yeah I'd say
so and like a hashtag like something I
realized too like because we just went
to twitchcon and we were talking to a
lot of streamers
uh it was interesting I I thought it was
interesting because the the few people
that I feel like I that seemed really
cool and that I look up to like in the
streaming world all of them wants to
quit streaming all them wants to do it
no one wants like no one likes it and
they're so successful like they are
around successful people they they're
working every single day they're working
hard they're making so much money and
everyone is just complaining and like
they're complaining about
um like not being able to see their
partner or you know because they need to
live somewhere else because and I see
these things and they seem extremely
unhappy and but it's so hard for them to
just cut all these successful stuff off
because that's like what you you know
learn to do and that's like supposed to
be like your happiness but it isn't
everyone is really unhappy yeah there's
something about maybe assuming is
different but you do folks to have
interacted with a few and
um even in podcasting space people
become obsessed about the views and
numbers and subscribers and stuff like
that
um so I turned I never talk about that I
I don't pay attention to that uh I feel
like that's a drug that destroys your
mind your your mind is an artist the
ability to create really unique things
um also your mind in terms of the
anxiety the ups and downs of the
attention mechanism uh and then also
being just if it's something that you
make is not popular but it meant a lot
to you you will think of it less yes
because it's not popular yeah that's a
really dangerous thing and because
everyone around you is reinforcing like
I'll get messages like wow this thing
got this many views or something great
job it's like no you don't get it like
that's not that's not everyone is
enforcing this like this language of
views and likes and so on and it's it's
correlated of course because truly
impactful things will get a lot of
attention often but it's not on the
individual local scale like temporarily
is
it's uh it can really [ __ ] with your
mind and I see that in the creators they
become
um addicts to the algorithm lost and
chasing views like we know friends that
yes we know cool people and then they
start streaming and eventually they go
they're like chasing the dragon of like
and they change like they're yeah it's
like really and there's like this is
something I've always said that like one
of the biggest blessings and biggest
curses of humanity is we are very good
at acclimating like you can become
paralyzed you can have all sorts of
horrible things happen to you and you'll
get used to it and you'll be okay you're
gonna have like a good Baseline but it
works the other way too and that you can
get more and more and more and more and
you acclimate to it almost immediately
there's like this is a phenomenon that I
bet it happens in the YouTube world but
I know what happens in the steering
world where you're streaming 1000
viewers every day huge event happens and
you blow up and you got like 15 000
viewers for a day or two and then it
starts to go down and down and down and
down and down and then after all the
drama started off you're at like 3 000
concurrent viewers now in the macro you
went from one thousand to three thousand
that feels awesome but you actually feel
like [ __ ] the whole time because you're
remembering when you had 10 or 15 000
and now Everything feels horrible and
you'll see people climb over time like
[ __ ] like but whatever that one huge
stream I had like I've never like been
able to and it's like dude you're doing
great what's yeah that happens a lot
there's so many people that we know that
we find super super cool they're
passionate about things they have so
much interest
and then they just get like so addicted
to these numbers and like all the
everything is just ruined like all the
cool things about them is ruined because
they stop doing the things that they
actually like
to do something else that gives the more
viewers more money and it's really sad
to see yeah that that temporary
sacrifice that seems
temporary is that it uh it actually
destroys you like for one time making a
choice because I come across those
choices often like I can do this you can
kind of know what's going to be popular
and not and you have to ask yourself
that question like is this gonna
sacrifice because if people are
sacrificing like intimate relationships
they're sacrificing time with their
family their sex sacrifice in time with
things that they feel good about and
that they like
and that's something I kind of realized
last year because I was working so much
and I was just grinding and grinding
grinding but because it was kind of new
for me and then New Year's came by and I
was like wait what did I even do like
the entire year like I traveled to a
bunch of places but nothing actually
really meant anything to me because I
felt like I was just working the entire
time I felt like I was just numb through
the through the entire year and it was
really scary
um like I rented a like a super pretty
house like for a week with my dad and my
sister because I wanted to spend time
with them but the entire time I was just
streaming and I actually didn't ever
like calm down and just like chill with
them and I like that's like time I'll
never get back I don't I don't give a
[ __ ] about the money that I made that
week but I lost the time
and like that is really important to me
and I yeah and a lot of people are doing
that um and I feel like you as you said
like you can definitely see that in like
artists for sure I feel like if you look
at like artists like back in the 60s or
70s I feel like things were just so much
better back then and it feels like they
were actually making music that meant
something to them they were actually
making art and I feel like today
everything is just kind of like whatever
is cool whatever sells whatever you know
sounds in a certain way everything is
kind of the same thing and everything
that is very artistic and very cool is
actually not that popular at all and uh
that's kind of sad I think yeah of
course there's now bigger mechanisms and
platforms to spread stuff music so as
long as you could be content with not
being popular I think you can still
create yeah but not like when people get
a little popular they get addicted to
that so fast yeah it's weird yeah you
have been somewhat good at least from my
outside of perspective because I think
you I can at least imagine you making
choices that could make you more popular
and you don't seem to make those choices
sabotage
but it is very intentional like you said
like and I made that choice at every
single stage of My Life One is because
from the perspective of being a carpet
cleaner my life is way better than that
was or ever would have been so I'm
already doing way better than I ever
thought somebody like me ever could be
um but then two I super love my job
every time I wake up every time I fly to
a place to a podcast every time I get to
talk to really cool people like every
single part of my job I super like if
it's something I don't like I just cut
it off because I don't care because I'm
already making plenty of money doing
what I do and why would I ever wake up
and not like what I'm doing when I kind
of like what I'm doing how do you guys
find through that given that
you love it and you sometimes maybe lose
yourself in the drug of it how do you
find like work life balance together
inside a relationship
like time for each other
I don't at all so I'm not a good person
to ask what do you love more uh male or
effect factor factor is a really good
game that's like not a fair comparison
okay you're talking about one of the
best cleanest games best support ever
made cleanest code base like yeah this
is
yeah it's more factorial time for me
starting to understand where the
massaging comes from by the way is is
the uh is Factor legit a really good
game yeah of course yeah if you're like
uh do you enjoy programming of course
that's all I do that's all that's okay
do you got like a programming is is the
game in itself that I enjoy probably
more than anything else but yeah it's
very much a game like that like if
you're into stuff like that like you can
lose hundreds of hours like very quickly
to like you have a problem and then you
think of a solution and then you iterate
on that over and over and over again in
larger larger schemes sometimes you got
to redesign stuff sometimes you get like
it's very much like that kind of game
this is essentially building a factory
like what on a foreign planet or
something like that it's basically it's
like a bunch of you're trying to
automate different problems so that you
can build bigger things so that you can
automate bigger problems so you can
build bigger things and automate bigger
problems so it's more complicated than
like a city building game like some City
type of thing I wouldn't say it's more
complicated it's more like it's like
factorial is like a game of like logic
like strictly like logic like it's
almost like you're building a circuit or
something yes yeah there's like their
circuitry and you've got your an orgs or
Gates you like there's stuff like that
it's very much like that like the
enemies in the game like what um they're
like try to bite you and you can get
guns and shoot and kill them but as I
saw there's like shooting going on yeah
but that's like a mine it's just another
problem to solve in the game basically
yeah okay all right so you see what we
do there we just started talking about
the game as we're trying oh my God
that's like a game okay that's that's
horrible anyway is there is that
basically the struggle not stop struggle
how to get human
like intimate human time
I feel like it was like a little bit
more in the past I feel like it's been
better
lately but I think it's because
um when we started dating I wasn't
streaming and I kind of just like gave
up like my trip in New Zealand I gave up
like like I left Sweden so I was just
like in LA which I hate I hate La I
don't like it late at all uh it's hard
to make friends that are like real that
are into the same stuff as you it's it
was just really hard for me to connect
with anyone especially also like being a
European and like being around Americans
was very strange so the only thing I had
when I came here was him
and I um and I didn't expect the
situation because yeah because we had we
had like two weeks of hanging out and
like he would be in his computer
sometimes and like do emails and stuff
but I wasn't thinking that he would
stream like 12 hours a day and it was
pretty like it was pretty intense like
in the beginning of it as well and I
realized it was really hard to like get
attention and get time because his like
love meter would be like full if I was
just in the house and that's just kind
of like the way he is and for me back
then when I didn't have anything else to
do
um was kind of like a it was kind of
crazy uh for me I feel like right now
because I do work as well and I have
things going from for me and I have
other friends uh now that I made I feel
like it's a lot easier because and and I
can definitely like enjoy just like
being in separate rooms and just like
hear him in the background is really
nice I can I I can sit and paint and
like in my room and I will do that for
hours while I'm just like hearing a
scream in the background it's kind of
like comforting that he's he's just
there and it feels nice I like it
because to you that's the sound of
Happiness yes because I know he's right
there yeah it's nice and then we'll come
in and check on me sometimes and it's
it's kind of like it's actually very
comforting it's very nice I like it yeah
I think that's kind of what a
relationship is like you do fun things
together you know you share moments
together but also just like having
someone like around you is really really
nice uh and I think that's probably
maybe it's me growing up maybe that's
what it is and like I start liking like
the kind of I feel like we're like an
old couple like we're like 80 and we're
just like around we don't really have to
talk much it's it's nice that fills you
Your Love Meter
um
I need both I mean okay you met you're
making it sound like that I'm like
craving like I haven't said anything I'm
not saying anything I ever said a single
thing I know exactly what you're
thinking so much judging going on
there's no judgment um no but like we I
think I think whenever we do plan
something out like if we if we go on a
trip like every other month or once a
month uh I feel like usually like that's
enough as long as he's not playing
Victoria the entire time like if I feel
like he's going on these trips with me
and he's not like doing things for me or
he's done he's not interested in like
spending time or like being present with
me then I feel like I just feel like I'm
just wasting time right now and then I
get kind of disappointed but otherwise I
think this like this is fun I think this
is like spending time together because
we're like doing something together yeah
it's fun yeah my love meter is full it's
my social life we like to we like to
think about it that way that like I need
like a little bit more of like this one
thing like quality time and he needs
like almost zero quality time but like
let's say that we took away like
physical touch you would probably not be
very happy
um so you need physical touch so it's
not just Factoria huh no I'm a very
kindly person yeah like cuddly and then
you're like I guess like acts of service
like if I do something for you get
really happy like hot chocolate yeah
like if I give him hot chocolate in the
morning he gets really happy so the
actual it's not the hot chocolate it's
the giving of the hot chocolate no it's
just the hot chocolate but if she gives
it to me I didn't have to get away is it
just physical touch to you like that's
really nice
all right well if you have to choose
between Factoria and the drama
or political discourse we probably
political discourse probably my calling
but I am a good factorial player
like what role exactly does factorio
play in your streaming life oh well
right now it's just usually there are
like these games that I play in the
background as I have conversation
because it's hard for me to just sit on
the computer just talk and not like be
playing a game at the same time so it's
just something to keep me kind of like
occupied you know some people buy like
little like widget things I guess yeah
that's what yours yeah basically yeah
it's like Minecraft or factorial for me
all right well my love meter is full
from this well thank you so much for
joining us this is really fun um you
guys are fascinating human beings
um thank you for existing I'm glad to
live in a world where you exist and I
can't wait to see what kind of beautiful
uh thing you create next and the crazy
kind of art that you create through the
different people you interact with
Destiny Steven you're an amazing human
thank you so much for talking to me it's
an honor hope to talk with you again
talking to Ben Shapiro you've given me a
lot of inspiration it's an honor to talk
to the Ben Shapiro of the left yeah well
thanks a lot for having me I appreciate
it thank you guys thank you
thanks for listening to this
conversation with Destiny to support
this podcast please check out our
sponsors in the description and now let
me leave you with some words from Lewis
Carroll it's no use going back to
yesterday because I was a different
person then
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time